. GOOD MORNING TO
EVERYONE WHO IS HERE WITH US
TODAY WALKING INTO TODAY'S
HEARING OF THE ASSEMBLY
COMMITTEE ON JOBS ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT AND THE ECONOMY FOR
THE 200-019-2000 TWENTY
LEGISLATIVE SESSION I AM
ASSEMBLY MEMBER SABRINA
CERVANTES AS I HAVE BEEN
SERVING AS CHAIR THIS LAST
SESSION FOR THIS JOBS COMMITTEE
BUT HAVE BEEN A COMMITTEE
MEMBER I SINCE FIRST SELECTED
IN TWO THOUSAND SIXTEEN. WITH
US THIS MORNING THERE ARE
SEVERAL COMMUNITY LEADERS ARE
LOCAL AND REGIONAL LEADERS THAT
I WOULD LIKE TO MENTION WE HAVE
WITH THE CITY OF CORONA WE HAVE
OUR MAYOR MAYOR JASON SCOTT
WITH US THANK YOU MAYOR WE HAVE
COUNCIL MEMBER JACQUI GASEOUS.
WE ALSO HAVE COUNCIL MEMBER
WEST SPEAK. WITH US THIS
MORNING FROM THE CITY OF EAST
RAIL WE HAVE COUNCIL MEMBER
JALPA JOCELYN YARROW JOINING US.
I WILL ALSO MENTION THAT MY
COLLEAGUE ASSEMBLY MEMBER JAMES
RAMOS DOES HAVE HIS SENIOR
FIELD REP WITH US AND THAT
WHICH IS BRANDON WILES WITH US
IN THE AUDIENCE THANK YOU
BRANDON. I WOULD LIKE TO TAKE A
MOMENT OF JUST PERSONAL
PRIVILEGE TO RECOGNIZE MY
DYNAMIC STAFF WHO WERE ON THE
GROUND EACH AND EVERY DAY
REPRESENTING ME I'VE BEEN MY
EXTENSION HERE FOR THE SIXTIETH
ASSEMBLY DISTRICT AND THAT IS
MY CHIEF OF STAFF SUNSET ON
DOC. MY DISTRICT DIRECTOR
RACHEL BINS I GOT. MY
COMMUNICATIONS DIRECTOR
CASSANDER CASTER. LEGISLATIVE
AIDE NATALIE BUT SENSE YEAH.
SENIOR FIELD RAP LOUISA TO SIGN.
FILL REPRESENTATIVE EDDIE
TORRES AND FILLED
REPRESENTATIVE BROAD WEST WHO'S
WITH ME ON THE DÍAS TODAY. AND
OF COURSE WE HAVE OUR A DYNAMIC
ASSEMBLY COMMITTEE STAFF WE
HAVE TO MY LEFT TONY SIMON'S
OUR CHIEF CONSULTANT FOR THE
ASSEMBLY JOBS COMMITTEE AND WE
ALSO HAVE BEEN WAR HEIGHT OR
COMMITTEE SECRETARY. WAS ALSO
WITH US. I DO WANT TO GIVE A
COUPLE ARE MORE RECOGNITION
SURE LDC TEAM WE HAVE BRADLEY
BEN'S WORK BUT IT'S WORTH AND
PETER. R. ROVI HERE WHO ARE TO
MY RIGHT BUT MOST OF ALL I
WANTED KNOWLEDGE IS CITY OF
CORONA AND THE CITY STAFF FOR
COMMITTEE IN THIS COMMITTEE TO
CONVENE THIS FIELD HEARING
TODAY. ARE THE COMMITTEE ARE
COULD NOT HAVE GONE FOR WITHOUT
THE COMMITMENT FROM THE CITY OF
CORONA I THIS FIELD HEARING SO
I WANT TO THANK THE MAYOR OF
THE VICE MAYOR OF COURSE AND OF
COURSE OUR COUNCILMEMBERS BUT
THE CITY STAFF HAD BEEN DYNAMIC
TO WORK WITH AND I JUST WANT TO
ACKNOWLEDGE. ANGELA AND YET
THOUGH WHO HAS SERVED AS OUR
PRIMARY CONTACT THANK YOU
ANGELA FOR OUR YOUR WORK.
LEADING UP TO TODAY. AND
THERE'S TWO OTHER INDIVIDUALS
THAT I LIKE TO ACKNOWLEDGE I
THAT IS KYLE EDGEWORTH. AND WE
HAVE A NAY C. VIOLA. WHO'S ALSO
BEEN A TREMENDOUS HELP TO OUR
COMMITTEE SO THANK YOU ALL. IT
IS NOW MY GREAT HONOR TO
INTRODUCE OUR COLOR GUARD. FROM
THE AMERICAN LEGION JOE
DOMINGUEZ POST IF WE CAN ALL
STAND FOR THE FLAG SALUTE WHICH
WILL BE LED BY MERRY AND
SHERMAN
. PLEASE PLACE YOUR
RIGHT HAND OVER YOUR HEART
READY BEGIN I PLEDGE ALLEGIANCE
TO THE FLAG OF THE UNITED
STATES OF AMERICA. AND TO THE
REPUBLIC FOR WHICH IT STANDS
ONE NATION UNDER GOD
INDIVISIBLE WITH LIBERTY AND
JUSTICE FOR ALL
. THANK YOU
AGAIN TO THE AMERICAN LEGION
JOE DOMINGUEZ POSTS AND THANK
YOU ALL FOR YOUR SERVICE. WE
WILL GO AHEAD AND BEGAN AT
TODAY'S HEARING IS THE THIRD IN
THE SERIES OF HEARING SPONSORED
BY THE ASSEMBLY COMMITTEE ON
JOBS TO EXAMINE THE CALIFORNIA
ECONOMY AND PRACTICAL ACTIONS
THAT CAN BE TAKEN TO SUPPORT AN
INCLUSIVE ECONOMIC GROWTH. THE
PART HEARINGS WITNESSES ENGAGED
WITH COMMITTEE MEMBERS ON
CALIFORNIA'S MANY ECONOMIC
STRAINS AS WELL AS STATE
GOVERNMENT AND PRIVATE SECTORS
INITIATIVES. THAT WERE BEING
USED OR COULD BE USED TO
SUPPORT UPWARD MOBILITY. REDUCE
RACIAL DISPARITIES WITHIN THE
WORKPLACE AND MAKE COMMUNITIES
MORE RESILIENT TO ECONOMIC AND
ENVIRONMENTAL CHALLENGES SUCH
AS NATURAL DISASTERS. BASED ON
MANY MANY HOURS OF PUBLIC
TESTIMONY AND RESEARCH THREE
THEMES HAVE EMERGED THESE
INCLUDE. UPSCALE THE INDIVIDUAL
TO ME INDIVIDUAL TO MEET MARKET
CHALLENGES. ESTABLISH
INTEGRATED AND ACCOUNTABLE
GOVERNANCE STRUCTURES TO BETTER
ALIGN WITH THE NEEDS OF
BUSINESSES PROGRAM AND PREVENT
SERVICE PROVIDERS AS WELL AS
INDIVIDUALS. AND NUMBER THREE
REMOVE BARRIERS FOR STARTUPS
ENTREPRENEURS AND BUSINESSES
THAT ARE LOOKING TO EXPAND
INCLUDING MANUFACTURERS. IN
ORDER TO ADVANCE THE JETTIES
COMMITTEES UNDERSTANDING OF HOW
SUSTAINABLE AND INCLUSIVE
ECONOMIC STRATEGIES CAN
ACTUALLY BE IMPLEMENTED IN THE
REAL WORLD THIS THIRD HEARING
IS BEING CONDUCTED OUTSIDE OF
THE CONFINES OF THE STATE
CAPITOL. WE WILL BE
HIGHLIGHTING REGIONAL
INITIATIVES IN THE INLAND
EMPIRE INCLUDING BEST PRACTICES
INNOVATIVE SOLUTIONS AND
REINVIGORATED REGIONAL VISIONS.
STRUCTURALLY THE HEARING TODAY
IS ORGANIZED INTO THREE PARTS
FIRST WE WILL HEAR FROM OUR
VERY OWN DR KARTIK GRAMMAR
CHRISTIAN DIRECTOR OF THE UC
RIVERSIDE CENTER FOR SOCIAL
INNOVATION ONE OF OUR REGION'S
LEADING EDGE PUBLIC POLICY
CENTER'S. SECOND WE WILL HEAR
FROM AMBER BOLDEN WITH
CALIFORNIA FORD. WHO WILL BRIEF
THE COMMITTEE ON HOW THE INLAND
EMPIRE IS REGIONAL NEEDS AND
PRIORITIES FIT WITHIN THE
CURRENT STATES ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT ACTIVITIES. AND
THEN WE WILL HEAR FROM A PANEL
SPEAKERS WHO WILL SHARE THEIR
EXPERTISE ON ESSENTIAL
COMPONENTS OF THE COMPREHENSIVE
REGIONAL AGENDA THAT IS CAPABLE
OF DELIVERING INCLUSIVE
ECONOMIC PROSPERITY. THE KEY
TOPICS WILL BE K. THROUGH
TWELVE EDUCATION AND WORKFORCE
PREPARATION STRATEGIES THAT
SUPPORT ENTREPRENEURSHIP AND
THE CREATION OF HIGHER VALUE
BUSINESSES AND JOBS BY BUILDING
REGIONAL INNOVATIVE ECOSYSTEMS.
UNFORTUNATELY WE DID HAVE A
SPEAKER ON THE HOME BASED
BUSINESSES I WAS NOT ABLE TO
JOIN US THIS MORNING ARE WE
WILL ASK MR HARY DEMAND WITH
THE EAST WILL CHAMBER OF
COMMERCE TO JOIN US AT ANOTHER
EVENTS I SO THAT WE CAN HAVE A
DISCUSSION A HOME BASED
BUSINESSES WHICH WE DO HAVE
MANY IN THE SIXTIETH ASSEMBLY
DISTRICTS. FOLLOWING OUR FORMAL
PRESENTATION THERE WILL BE AN
OPPORTUNITY FROM THE AUDIENCE I
TO PROVIDE OUR PUBLIC COMMENT.
DURING THE PUBLIC COMMENT
PERIOD. LET ME JUST TRY YOUR
ATTENTION TO THE BACKGROUND
REPORT PREPARED BY THE
COMMITTEE STAFF. AMONG OTHER
INFORMATION YOU WILL FIND AN
OVERVIEW OF OUR STATE ECONOMY.
THE INCREASING CHALLENGE INCOME
INEQUALITY IS HAVING ON MANY
CALIFORNIANS. A SHORT PROFILE
ON THE INLAND EMPIRE. AND THEN
JUST SPECIAL TENDENCIES ON THE
ECONOMIC IMPACT OF
INTERNATIONAL TRADE WHICH IS
WHAT THE COMMITTEE DOES
OVERSEE. ARE THE CURRENT STATE
OF SMALL BUSINESSES AND RELATED
LEGISLATION REPORTS AS WELL AS
BUDGET ACTIONS. REPORT ALSO HAS
AN APPENDIX ON OPPORTUNITIES
JONES WHICH AN ERROR WHICH IS
AN AREA THAT HAS BEEN RECEIVING
A LOT OF ATTENTION OVER THIS
PAST YEAR. AS A REMINDER FOR
THOSE THAT DO YOU WISH TO SPEAK
DURING THE PUBLIC COMMENT
PORTION OF. THAT IS GOING TO BE
AN AGENDA ITEM FIVE PLEASE SIGN
UP YOU CAN SIGN UP AT THE
REGISTRATION TABLE TO
PARTICIPATE IN THE PUBLIC
COMMENT. THE COMMITTEE IS ALSO
ACCEPT JEAN WRITTEN COMMENTS
UNTIL OCTOBER THIRTIETH OF TWO
OF TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN. LET'S
GO AHEAD AND START WITH OUR
FIRST SPEAKER ALLOW ME TO
INTRODUCE. OUR FIRST SPEAKER
WHOSE DOCTOR CARTOGRAPHIC
CHRISTIAN CHAIR OF THE CENTER
FOR SOCIAL INNOVATION AT THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA
RIVERSIDE DR I'M A CHRISTIAN
ALSO INSTRUCTS AT THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA
RIVERSIDE AS A PROFESSOR IN THE
SCHOOL OF PUBLIC POLICY. HE
COMES TO THESE DUTIES WITH THE
UNIQUE PRIVATE SECTOR
BACKGROUND I HAVE INSERTED THE
SENIOR PARTNER WITH MACKENZIE
IN COMPANY IN A LECTURE ON
INEQUALITY AT THE STANFORD
BUSINESS SCHOOL. WE HAVE
INVITED DR I'M A CHRISTIAN TO
BRIEF THE COMMITTEE ON
ACTIVITIES OF NEW INITIATIVES
THAT HE LAUNCH THIS YEAR IN.
WHICH IS CALLED INLAND
CALIFORNIA RISING. TO PRESENT
RESEARCH FROM THE CENTER STATE.
ARE FROM THE CENTERS STATE OF
THE INLAND EMPIRE SERIES IN ITS
RECENT COLLABORATION WITH THE
BROOKINGS INSTITUTE I ADVANCING
OPPORTUNITY IN CALIFORNIA'S
INLAND EMPIRE. WE WILL BE GOING
INTO. DISCUSSING PROJECTS AND
INITIATIVES THAT HAVE COME OUT
OF ALL THIS RESEARCH A DOCTOR
I'M A CHRISTIAN PLEASE BEGIN
WHEN YOU'RE READY. GREAT THANK
YOU AND THANK YOU CHAIR
CERVANTES ALLAH AND MEMBERS OF
THE MEMBERS AND STAFF TO THE
COMMITTEE AND MEMBERS OF. THE
PUBLIC ONE THING I SHOULD
NOTICE A CORRECTION THAT MIGHT
HAVE BEEN LINEAMENT DUNCES FIVE
WITH MACKENZIE. I AM A SINNER
ENTREPRENEUR OF SORTS BUT THAT
DID NOT WORK IN THE CAN. WHAT
I'M GONNA DO TODAY AND THANK
YOU FOR THIS OPPORTUNITY TO
HELP SET THE STAGE WHILE I'LL
TALK A LITTLE BIT ABOUT OUR
CENTER. MOST OF OUR WORK IS IN
PARTNERSHIP WITH COMMUNITY WITH
BUSINESSES WITH NON PROFITS
MORE BROADLY SO IT'S A WEIGHTY
RESPONSIBILITY BUT ALSO AN
EXCITING AND IMPORTANT
PRIVILEGE. TO BE ABLE TO SET
THE STAGE ABOUT ALL OF THE
IMPORTANT THINGS HAPPENING. IN
OUR REGION AND ONE THING I'LL
SAY IS. THESE KIND OF
PARTNERSHIPS ARE EVIDENT NOT
ONLY IN TERMS OF THE ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT WORK. BUT EVEN SAY
IN TERMS OF CENSUS OUT REACH SO
ARE CENTER IS WORKING. HAND IN
GLOVE WITH BOTH COUNTIES BOTH
RIVERSIDE COUNTY AND SEPARATE
IN COUNTY. AS WELL AS THE
PRIVATE SECTOR IN THE NONPROFIT
SECTOR. TO MAKE SURE THAT
EVERYONE COUNTS BECAUSE IT
MEANS SO MUCH WHEN IT COMES TO
RESOURCES. FROM THE FEDERAL
STATE GOVERNMENT BUT IT'S ALSO
IMPORTANT FOR BUSINESS
INTELLIGENCE AND THAT'S- PART
OF THE MESSAGE WE'RE TRYING TO
SEND AS WELL. IS THAT SENSES IS
VITAL FOR BUSINESS AND WE NEED
TO HAVE ALL BUSINESSES INVOLVED
IN ENGAGE WHEN IT COMES TO
INSURING. AN ACCURATE AND
COMPLETE COUNT. SO TO SEE A
LITTLE BIT ABOUT CSI WE ARE NOT
THE LATEST CBS SHOW. FEATURED
IN RIVERSIDE IT'S THE CENTER
FOR SOCIAL INNOVATION. AND ONE
OF THE PAST AS YOU WILL SEE.
THAT WE USE. IS INLAND AND OF
IT. PART OF WHAT WE- DO IS
RESHAPE THAT PART OF THE- AND
MORE GENERALLY INLAND
CALIFORNIA I'LL TALK ABOUT
LATER. WHEN PEOPLE THINK ABOUT
WHERE INNOVATION IS HAPPENING
THEY DON'T THINK IMMEDIATELY OF
THE INLAND EMPIRE OR OF INLAND
CALIFORNIA AND IT'S IMPORTANT
FOR US TO NOT ONLY FOCUS ON THE
CHALLENGES THAT WE HAVE IN OUR
REGION. BUT IMPORTANTLY TO
FOCUS ON THE LEADERSHIP THE
IMPORTANT INITIATIVES AND
ULTIMATELY TO SHOW NOT ONLY THE
INNOVATION. BUT TO SHOW THE
INVESTMENT READINESS SO THAT WE
CAN HAVE A LOT MORE
INVESTMENTS. ARE COMING INTO
THE STATE. WE HAVE BOTH AND
BOTH IN THE MATERIALS THAT IT
THAT HAVE BEEN SHARED WITH THE
COMMITTEE AS WELL AS MATERIALS
THAT WE HAVE HERE. SEVERAL
REPORTS AND I'LL BE DIGGING
MORE DEEPLY INTO THE STATE OF
WORK REPORT. BUT ANOTHER
IMPORTANT REPORT THAT RELATES
TO WHAT WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
TODAY IS THE STATE OF
IMMIGRANTS IN THE INLAND EMPIRE
DID THAT IN PARTNERSHIP WITH.
OUR INLAND COALITION FOR
IMMIGRANT JUST AS WELL
CALIFORNIA IMMIGRANT POLICY
CENTER. SO WHEN WE THINK ABOUT
OUR PERFORMANCE MANY WILL HAVE
A STEREOTYPE OF THE INLAND
EMPIRE AS ONE WHERE IMMIGRANTS
ARE NOT IMPORTANT. WILL BE
SHIPPED IN THAT REPORT AND IN
THE ACCOUNT FOR ONE OUT OF
EVERY RESIDENTS IN THE STATE.
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT PARTICULAR
SECTORS LIKE AGRICULTURE IN
EASTERN. ACCOUNT RENTS ARE
SEVERELY ALL PURPOSE THERE OR
IF WE TALK ABOUT THE LOGISTICS
SECTOR AND WESTERN SAT IN A
COUNTY. IMPRINTS ARE HAPPILY
REPRESENTED THERE AS WELL. BUT
ON TOP OF THAT. NOT JUST ABOUT
THOSE PARTICULAR SECTORS. WE
LOOK AT IMMIGRANTS THEY'RE ALSO
INVEST IN THE HEALTHCARE
SECTOR. ESPECIALLY IF YOU LOOK
AT EIGHT AND IMMIGRANTS. IN THE
INLAND EMPIRE OF WHICH THERE
ARE NUMEROUS AND FAST GROWING.
AND WE ALSO FIND PARTICULAR
DYNAMICS OF ASIAN IMMIGRANTS
IN. THIS REGION FOR EXAMPLE
WITH FILIPINOS BEING A MUCH
LARGER PART OF THE ASIAN
IMMIGRANT COMMUNITY HERE THAN
THEY ARE IN ORANGE COUNTY OR LA
COUNTY. SO HAPPY TO DIG DEEPER
INTO THAT IF THERE ANY
QUESTIONS. SO DO CAN BE
PRESENTS SOME BASIC FACTS THAT
YOU'LL SEE IN OUR REPORT AS
WELL AS SEVERAL OTHER REPORTS
THAT SET THE STAGE. ONE
UNEMPLOYMENT WAS VERY HIGH IN
THE INLAND EMPIRE PARTICULAR.
AND THE PEAK OF THE GREAT
RECESSION. BUT WE'VE COVERED IN
PRETTY SIGNIFICANT WAY SO IF
YOU LOOK AT THE JOB GROWTH
STORY. IN THE INLAND EMPIRE
CLIMATE ABOUT WHERE IT IS FOR
ALL FORMULA AND WHERE IT IS FOR
THE RIGHT COUNTRY SO. IT HAS AN
IMPACT OF GROWTH IN OUT IN JOBS.
RIGHT WAY TO LOOK AT THAT IS
JOB GROWTH OUR RIVERSIDE CAP HE
AND SEVERAL COUNTY VIEW FROM
TWO THOUSAND ONE TO TWO EIGHT
JOB RATE HAS EXCEEDED THE STATE
AVERAGE. AND YET AT THE SAME
TIME THE ECONOMIC RECOVERY HAS
BEEN ON EITHER. I AND PLAN
PARRIS ISLAND AND YET. IN THE
INLAND EMPIRE. AS IN THE IN THE
NATION ARE HIRING TO INSECTS ON
THE PROPERTY THE SESSIONS ABOUT
THE NUMBER CHALLENGE.
PARTICULARLY GIVEN INCREASE IN
HELPING CALL OVER THE LAST FEW
YEARS IN THE STREET. OUR COMMON
INTEREST ALL HIGHER UP AFTER
CONSERVE TINO'S SOME. TENSION
TO THE EQUITY LANDS. POLICE
PURPOSE BY YOU PLEASE PUT FULL
TIME THIRTY HOURS MORE PER WEEK
AND YOU WHICH IS FIFTY REFER TO
EXPRESS. I'M FINE PARTY TO
HIGHEST AMONG AMERICAN AFTER
CANCEL TINO'S AND AMONG WOMEN
ESPECIALLY AMONG THESE
COMMUNITIES OF COLOR. AS A
REMINDER LATINOS REPRESENT A
MAJORITY OF OUR REGION IN A
RECENT HAS BEEN QUOTE UNQUOTE
MAJORITY MINORITY FOR MANY
YEARS NOW. WE ONE OF THE
QUESTIONS WE ARE ON THAT REPORT
OUR WEATHER EARNING ENOUGH GET
THE HIGH COST OF LIVING. TECH
IS TO LIVE EIGHT STANDARD
WITHOUT OKAY LATER IS THAT ARE
PARTICULAR TO THE REASON COMING
UP THE UNIVERSE WASHINGTON. ARE
SO THAT'S EIGHTEEN DOLLARS AN
HOUR IF YOU LOOK AT THE WORKERS
THAT ARE EARNING THREE THOUSAND
MORE. ABOUT JUST SHY OF 40%
MEET THAT STANDARD AND THERE'S
SIX TAKEN ON AT GAPS AS WHAT
WAS JEFF GAPS. ENTER WORK TO
MEET THAT STANDARD. WE COMPARE.
IN THE AUTUMN PART TWO OTHER
OPTIONS CALVET IN ORDER
SPEAKERS FIND THAT A LOT THEY
PROVIDE ACCESS EMPLOYER
PROVIDED HEALTH INSURANCE AT
LESS ACCESS TO TIME YOUR CHOPS.
WE DO HAVE A HIGHER SKILLED AS
A SET OF OCCUPATIONS ARE A AND
SECTORS THAT BETTER RICHER IN
THOSE BUT THEY ARE UNDER
REPRESENTED IN THIS REGION
COMPARED TO OTHERS A ONE OF THE
KEY THEMES THAT I PERSONALLY IN
OUR CENTER WILL RECOMMEND BUT
IT ALSO COMES THROUGH IN SOME
OF THESE REPORTS. IS THAT WE
NEED GREATER DIVERSIFICATION IN
IN TERMS OF OUR ECONOMY TO NOT
ONLY PUT PROVIDE THOSE PATHWAYS
TO. MIDDLE CLASS JOBS FOR THOSE
WITHOUT A COLLEGE DEGREE BUT
ALSO TO PROVIDE OPPORTUNITIES
FOR THOSE WHO DO HAVE COLLEGE
DEGREES WHO FIND THAT THEY HAVE
TO COMMUTE OUT TO LA COUNTY IN
ORANGE COUNTY IN ORDER TO SEEK
OPPORTUNITY. OUR CENTER ALSO
DID A SEARCH IN COLLABORATION
WITH A CALIFORNIA NEWS WHICH
INCLUDES ENTITIES LIKE THE
RIVER BY PRESS CENTER AS AND
TEMPORARY NOT ON BUT ALSO
FORGED REGISTER AND THE- DAILY
NEWS. AND WHAT WE FOR THEIR
RESPECT TO WHAT THE. WANTS TO
SEE AN INTERACTIVE IMPROVING
JOB SPECS REGION. WE FIND THAT
THERE OF WAITING THIS DICHOTOMY
BETWEEN SAY UPSCALING BOB'S AND
IN ORDER TO ACTION. AT THIS
POINT BECAUSE THIS SUPPORT BOTH
FOR IMPROVING OUR PROTECTING
WORKERS RIGHTS WHICH YOU'LL SEE
A RIGHT HAND AND ALL. ACTUALLY
SET UP BOTH PANELS AS WELL AS
AS- IT'S A GOOD CAREER
TECHNICAL EDUCATION WHICH IS IN
A RAP BATTLE IN TERMS OF
GOVERNMENT NEEDING MORE UP. IS
STRONG SUPPORT FOR THOSE RIGHT
BECAUSE OF THE FORTY PERCENT.
AFTER ABOUT FORTY. S. SUPPORT
FOR BOTH OF THIS STRATEGY AND
SO THAT'S JUST READ PORTENT. IN
MANY WAYS TIED INTO THE WORK
FUTURE THE COMMISSION I IN THE
STATE HOUSE. A IS THAT WE DON'T
HAVE TO LEAVE FOR AN UPSCALE.
IT'S IMPORTANT FOCUS ON THAT AS
WELL AS A WORKER TIONS TO MAKE
SURE. REALLY BY THOSE DOES
PATHWAYS. TO ONLY MIDDLE CLASS
JOBS BUT ALSO MIDDLE CLASS
LIVING IN OUR REGION. THAT'S A
LITTLE BIT ABOUT BROOKINGS AND
THEIR ROLE IN AYE EGO WHICH IS
AN ECONOMIC GROWTH AND
OPPORTUNITY IT'S A IT'S I'D
LIKE TO WHICH I WAS THE WE
ACTUALLY THE LOCAL LEVEL
WORKING PARTNERSHIP WITH CHILD
CARE IS SET YOU SHOW US SHOP
AND GOODMAN. FOR THE CALL
AUTHORS OF AN ECONOMIC
INTELLIGENCE REPORT THAT SET
THE STAGE FOR THE STRATEGY
WRECKED NATION HAVE AS PART OF
AYE EGO ARE YOU CAN FIND THIS
REPORT ON THE BROOKINGS
WEBSITE. AND WE HAVE COPIES. OF
THE AYE EGO STRATEGY REPORT
HERE. AND THE THEMES WILL BE
VERY FAMILIAR. RIGHT EVEN
THOUGH WE'VE HAD AT OUR JOB
GROWTH AND SIMILAR CHART IN THE
BROOKINGS REPORT THAT SHOWS
IMPROPER JOB GROWTH. A FAMILY
THAT ARE STRUGGLING TO GET BY
THE MEASURE THEM WHAT WE HAD
WHICH IS A LIVING WEEKS
INVOLVING INVEST WORKERS. USING
THIS MEASURE LOOKING FAMILY
FORTY PER CENT WORKING FAMILIES
ARE STRUGGLING AND HAS REMAINED
PERSISTENTLY HIGH WE HAVE MADE
PROGRESS IN GETTING THAT DOWN.
BROOKINGS ALSO PIONEERED A NEW
WAY OF LOOKING AT QUOTE UNQUOTE
GOOD JOBS AND OPPORTUNITY JOBS
GOOD JOBS ARE THOSE THAT PAY
EIGHTEEN HOURS AND HOURS OF
USING THE CPAP WE HAVE. HAVE
PLAYED PROVIDED HEALTH
INSURANCE. AND THIS IS A FULL
TIME WORK. AND WHAT THE NINE IS
THAT ABOUT FIFTY PERCENT. OF
JACOB'S ARE HERE ARE TING FOR.
LOOK AT WHO DON'T HAVE WAS THE
EIGHTIES I'M ONLY 17% OF. CAN
BECAUSE THE FIGHTER AT AS JOB
THE 4% ARE PER SE. ALL THE
GREAT ABOUT IS WHAT THE AND
GRAY. AND THOSE ARE BOB SAID
NEITHER GOOD NOR PROMISING
MISSING THOSE ARE NOT NOW I CAN
PRO I'D MOBILITY POWER PLAYS
FOR WORKERS WITHIN THE NEXT
DECADE TO HAVE THAT PROFILE IN
TERMS OF WAGES AND BENEFITS. I
CAN BE A FIVE GOOD SO THIS IS
SOMETHING THAT SHOULD CONCERN
US ALL IN AND FORTUNATELY.
THERE ARE SEVERAL INITIATIVES
UNDER WAY TO TRY TO ADDRESS
THIS. THE BROOKINGS REPORT ALSO
SHOWS SIGNIFICANT RACIAL AND
ETHNIC GAPS SO IF YOU LOOK. AT
ALL LEVELS OF EDUCATION. FIVE
AND THAT OUR COMMUNITIES OF
COPPER AND ESPECIALLY HISPANIC
WOMEN AND BY WOMEN OUR
DISADVANTAGE WHEN IT COMES TO
BEING ABLE TO ACCESS THESE JOBS
AND PROMISING. TO SUMMARIZE
SOME OF THE KEY FINDINGS WHICH
YOU FIND OF THE REPORT.
AUTOMATION PROVIDES
OPPORTUNITIES AS WELL AS
SIGNIFICANT THREATS IN AREAS
LIKE LOGISTICS IN OUR REGION.
REASON HAS IMPORTANT ASSETS
INITIATIVE SECOND GROW GRASS
MANY STRING. EMERGING SECTORS I
AM TALK ABOUT THOSE IN A MINUTE
OUR OPPORTUNITIES. FOR UPCOMING
DIVERSIFICATION IN A LITTLE
CLASS. TO THAT AND FINALLY
THERE ARE IMPORTANT AND
WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT EFFORTS
OF REASON. TO BE SCALED UP AND
BETTER CONNECTED CROPS THIS
BASS REASON OF THE INLAND
EMPIRE. IN TERMS OF KEY
STRATEGIES THAT FLOWED OUT OF
THIS I SHOULD NOTE THAT THE
LASER FOCUS OF THIS REPORT IS
TO GROW BUT ACOSTA FOR THOSE
WHO DON'T HAVE COLLEGE DEGREES.
SOME OF THE RECOMMENDATIONS
HERE. THINK OF THIS AS THE
BLUEPRINT FOR A REASON I THINK
IT IS A BLUEPRINT FOR VISION
AND I'LL TALK ABOUT OUR-
INITIATIVES ANOTHER THEMES THAT
ARE IMPORTANT TO INVEST IN AS
WELL. WHAT MAKE THE WRITTEN THE
HOME OF GLOBAL IN XIN AND THE
LOGISTICS. STREET TAKE SOME
RIGHT NOW THAT IS. CLINTON A
PROBLEM AND TO TURN IT INTO AN
SET SOMETHING THAT WE CAN
IMPROVE ON. TING ON MEASURES OF
AND- AN ABILITY. IN TERMS UP OF
WORKER PAY AND BACK THAT'S- AS
WELL POTENTIALLY SAW US SOME OF
THE OTHER TOWNS AS WE MIGHT
FACE. ESPECIALLY IN TERMS OF
VEHICULAR TRAFFIC AND THERE ARE.
IT SHOULD IS N. ASSETS REGION
OR WORKING ON THESE ISSUES.
NEXT ANOTHER KEY STRATEGIES TO
STRENGTHEN THE COMPETITIVENESS
OF THE REGION'S ADVANCE
MANUFACTURERS MANUFACTURING HAS
DECLINED OVER THE LAST TWENTY
YEARS IN OUR REGION IT'S IN A
BIT OF A REBOUND. WHAT CAN WE
DO TO MOVE FROM STANDARD
MANUFACTURING TO ADVANCED
MANUFACTURING THAT'S GOING TO
BE KEY CHALLENGE FOR THE REGION.
NEXT WE NEED TO ACCELERATE THE
GROWTH OF PROMISING EMERGING
INDUSTRIES WITH BUT THE
POTENTIAL OF GROWING A LOT OF
MIDDLE CLASS JOBS. THIS IS
ESPECIALLY TO THE RELOCATION OF
THE CALIFORNIA AIR RESOURCES
BOARD IT'S CALIFORNIA OFFICE.
TO RIVERSIDE FROM EL MONTE.
THERE ARE A LOT OF HIGH SKILLED
JOBS THAT ARE COMING WITHOUT
WITH THOSE RESEARCHERS THAT ARE
PART OF CARB. BUT NOW WE'RE
EXTENDING BEYOND THE TO SEE
WHAT ARE THE KINDS OF
ENTERPRISES CONNECTED TO
EMISSIONS TESTING. AND LATER
I'LL TALK ABOUT GREEN KNOWLEDGE
NON EMISSIONS TESTING. PART
COULD BE IN CHANGE IN OUR
REGION. MANY OF US ARE ARE
LOOKING AT. IT THAT WAY AND I'M
HAPPY TO TALK ABOUT THAT MORE
IN THE. SELECT IS OPEN
IMPORTANT. SECTOR THAT THAT
SHOWS PROMISE OF FINE LITTLE
MIDDLE CLASS JOBS AND FINALLY
CYBERSECURITY ESPECIALLY WITH
THE ASSETS AT CAL STATE SAMBAR
DINO NATIONALLY RECOGNIZED
CENTER FOR TRAINING AND
CYBERSECURITY IT'S MOSTLY
COLLEGE GRADUATES BUT
POTENTIALLY WITH SMALL BUSINESS
SUPPORT WE OFFER THE POTENTIAL
FOR THOSE WITHOUT FOUR YEAR
COLLEGE DEGREES THOSE WITH
TECHNICAL CERTIFICATES TO BE
ABLE TO TAKE ADVANTAGE OF THOSE
OPPORTUNITIES. AND FINALLY AS I
MENTIONED BEFORE ANOTHER KEY
STRATEGY RECOGNITION THE SIX
ARE THE ADOPTION OF WORK IS
CAREER TECHNICAL EDUCATION.
WITH A PROTECTIVE FOCUS ON
ATTRACTING WOMEN AND HE'S OF
COLOR. AGAIN I WOULD REFER YOU
BACK TO THAT SLIDE THAT SHOWED
THAT WOMEN IN COMMUTERS COLORED
ESPECIALLY WOMEN OF COLOR OR
SEVERELY DISADVANTAGE IN TERMS
OF THEIR ACCESS TO GOOD JOBS
AND PROMISING JOBS. NEXTEL GO
BEYOND A YOU GO THIS IS
SOMETHING THAT WE PREPARED IN
COLLABORATION WITH I. E. P. FOR
THE REGION'S RISE TOGETHER. BUT
AS YOU SEE CIRCLE ONE WHICH IS
EXPECTING BILLS COACH OUT. BUT
THE NOT THE ONLY IMPORTANT PART
HE'S IN OUR GEN. OTHER PARTIES
AS WELL TO JUST IT HIGH SKILL
JOBS AND RESEARCH
COMMERCIALIZATION. THREE GREEN
TACK N. SUSTAINABILITY OTHER
IMPORTANT SURE THAT IS IT GEN.
ARE CONNECTED TO CARVE AS WELL
AS OTHER GREEN TECHNOLOGY.
IMPORTANT RESEARCH ASSETS THE
UNIVERSITY CAL HI BUT ALSO WITH
INCUBATORS I'M SORRY GEN.
BETTER CONNECT ON THAT ISSUE.
CRADLED CAREER ARE SOME OF THIS
ALREADY IS PART OF IT. BUT IT
DOES BE UNDER JOB AT THE FOCUS
OFF. ON A CERTIFICATE AND WAYS.
TO GO TO GO FOR PRE K. ALL THE
WAY THROUGH A CAREER SUCCESS.
FIVE FOCUSED ON ENEMY IN
PLANNING HONEST PLEA. SURE.
BOTH LOCAL REGIONAL AND THE
CONVERSATION ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT NOT I STATED AND IN
CONJUNCTION WITH SMART THING
WHEN IT COMES TO HOUSING WHEN
IT COMES TO TRACK PATIENT AS
WELL AS ENVIRONMENTAL
SUSTAINABILITY GREAT TUNE THREE
AND THIS IS IN THAT K. GORDON
WHO'S THE HEAD OF OFFICE IN
PLANNING AND RESEARCH HAS THAT
AS CAP GROWTH DEVELOPS
ECONOMICALLY WE NEED TO BE
SMARTER AND HOW WE DO IT AND
ESPECIALLY. FOR ME TO BE IN OUR
GREENHOUSE GAS EMISSION GOALS.
AND FINALLY IT MIGHT BE STRANGE
TO SEE A THEME LIKE STRONGER
NONPROFITS AS WE TALK ABOUT
INCLUSIVE ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT.
BUT NONPROFITS ARE SUCH AN
IMPORTANT PART OF OUR REGION.
WE TALK ABOUT OUR COLLEGES AND
UNIVERSITIES WE TALK ABOUT THE
HEALTH CARE SECTOR. AND ALSO IF
WE TALK ABOUT SMALLER
NONPROFITS THAT ARE PROVIDING
EMPLOYMENT. AND ARE DOING
IMPORTANT WORK AT ALREADY
REFERENCED ARE THE WORK OF THE
SENSES AS ONE IMPORTANT
EXAMPLE. AND WE HAVE FOR YOUR
REFERENCE IN IN THE DOCUMENTS
AVAILABLE TO THE COMMITTEE AS
WELL AS HERE TODAY. AS LISTING
A IT'S A PRELIMINARY LIST. WE
TRY TO FIT AS MANY INITIATIVES
AS WE CAN INTO TWO PAGES UNDER
THESE THEMES. BUT THE BOTTOM
LINE IS THIS. THERE ARE A LOT
OF INCREDIBLE THINGS HAPPENING
IN OUR REGION. WE DON'T WANT
ANYONE'S PITY WE DON'T WANT
ANYONE'S CHARITY WE WANT
EVERYONE'S INVESTMENT WE WANT
THEIR ATTENTION. AND THIS IS
PART OF WHAT INLAND CALIFORNIA
RISING IS TRYING TO DO SO THIS
A LITTLE BIT ABOUT INLAND
CALIFORNIA RISING. WHEN WE
START OUR CENTER A YEAR AND A
HALF AGO WE INVITED ACTUALLY
SWEAR ENGINE FORMER MAYOR
MODERATE REPUBLICAN FROM THE
CENTRAL VALLEY. WHO IS A
PRAGMATIST SHE'S NOT
IDEOLOGICAL. SHE WAS LASER
FOCUS ON FIGURING OUT HOW CAN
WE GROW INVESTMENTS IN FRESNO.
AND TO WORK ACROSS THE AISLE
THE OBAMA ADMINISTRATION AS
WELL AS A BROWN ADMINISTRATION.
ARE TO MAKE SURE THAT ECONOMIC
BENEFITS CONNECTED TO HIGH
SPEED RAIL ANOTHER IMPORTANT
TRANSPORTATION INVESTMENTS HAD
FRESNO IS AN IMPORTANT AREA OF
INVESTMENT. SO WHEN WE STARTED
OUR CENTER WE WANTED TO FEATURE
SOMEONE THAT WE COULD. WE COULD
LOOK AT AS AN EXAMPLE OF COURSE
WE COULD LOOK TO COASTAL
CALIFORNIA. BUT SO MUCH OF WHAT
WE FACE ARE SIMILAR TO WHAT
OTHERS AN INLAND CALIFORNIA
FACE. SO WHEN I. FIRST
PRESENTED AND I STILL USE THIS
MAP OF CALIFORNIA AND I THE
THOUGHT EXPERIMENT. I SAY IS
THAT I SOMEONE TO DROP PINS ON
A MAP IN TERMS OF WHERE IS
INNOVATION HAPPENING IN
CALIFORNIA WE ASK MOST PEOPLE
DROP THOSE PLANS. WILL BE A
WHOLE BUNCH IS A DROP IN THAT
AREA. I'M A MAYBE MORE SAVVY
AND KNOW ABOUT ENTERTAINMENT
TECHNOLOGY MY DROP A WHOLE
BUNCH OF PENS AND- IN LOS
ANGELES. OR THEY KNOW ABOUT I
TECH IT'S AN ATTACK IN IRVINE
AND SAN DIEGO. THEY'LL DROP ALL
THOSE PENS THEIR- VERY RARELY
WILL YOU FIND THE AVERAGE
CALIFORNIAN DROPPING PENS IN
INLAND CALIFORNIA. WHEN ASKED
ABOUT ONLY INVASION IS. THAT'S
NOT BECAUSE IT IS NOT HAPPENING
BUT THAT'S WHAT OUR DOMINANT
ENTERED. UNFORTUNATELY MANY OF
US INTO THIS TRAP ONLY FOCUSING
ON ALBUMS IN TOWN IS WITHOUT
TALKING ABOUT WHAT ARE THE GOOD
PERHAPS WHO'S DOING IT WHO DO
WE NEED TO INVEST IN. AND
THAT'S WHAT OUR THAT AND PART
OF OUR DNA FROM THE BEGINNING
THIS TO CHANGE THAT NARRATIVE.
TO FOCUS ON THE CHANGE MAKERS
TO FOCUS ON THE INNOVATORS. AND
TO REALLY PUSH HARD ON THIS
NOTION THAT WE NEED TO GROW
INVESTMENTS AND INLAND
CALIFORNIA. WE HAD A SET OF
CONVENING WE HAD OUR LUNCH IN A
MINUTE FEBRUARY. WHERE WE HAVE
IDEAS WITH KEY MEMBERS OF THE
OF THE LEGISLATURE INCLUDING
SPEAKER RENDON. WE ALSO HAD A
MEETING WITH KEY MEMBERS OF THE
GOVERNOR'S TEAM. IT WAS A
COALITION OF MAYORS COMMITTEE
FOUNDATION CEOS AND UNIVERSITY
PRESIDENTS THAT'S ALL THE
PEOPLE WE COULD FIT INTO THE
GOVERNOR'S CONFERENCE ROOM THAT
DAY. SINCE THEN WE'VE HAD A
SUMMIT HERE WHERE WE HAD THE
HONOR OF HAVING YOU SO MEMBER
CERVANTES ADDRESS AS WELL
ADDRESS THE CROWD AS WELL AS
OTHERS. WE ALSO HAD STRONG SHOW
OF SUPPORT FROM STATE PARTNERS
INCLUDE INCLUDING LADY MAN
DANSA. THE HEAD OF GOLD IS AS
WELL AS QUE GORDON FROM OPR. AS
WELL AS AN IMPORTANT SHOW OF
SUPPORT FROM MAYOR ERIC
GARCETTI FROM LOS ANGELES. JUST
LAST WEEK WE HAD A FOLLOW UP
MEETING IN STOCKTON AND THAT
WAS ALSO VERY WELL ATTENDED.
AND IMPORTANTLY KATHLEEN KELLY
JANICE WHO THE GOVERNOR SENIOR
ADVISER ON SOCIAL INNOVATION.
WORK WITH US AND THE CITY OF
STOCKTON. TO HAVE A MEETING OF.
PHILANTHROPIC LEADERS IN THE
STATE INCLUDING JAMES IRVINE
FOUNDATION THE CALIFORNIA
ENDOWMENT I SHOULD KNOW THAT
I'M ON THE BOARD OF THE
CALIFORNIA DOWN AT. GATES
FOUNDATION CHAN'S OCCUR
BERGENHUS ELEVEN MANY OTHERS IT
WAS REALLY INSPIRING TO SEE AND
WE'RE HOPEFUL. THAT WOULD
EFFORTS LIKE THIS THAT WE WILL
GROW INVESTMENTS ALL UP AND
DOWN INLAND CALIFORNIA. TWO
INITIATIVES ARE THAT ARE
CENTERS WORKING ON THAT COME
OUT OF INLAND CALIFORNIA
RISING. ONE RELATES TO
OPPORTUNITIES OWNS. SO HERE WE
HAVE THE GOOD FORTUNE OF
PARTNERING WITH AMERICA SAID HE
AND HIS EX OPERATOR FOR AMERICA
INITIATIVES. IN PARTNERSHIP
WITH FUSE CORPS. SO IF PEOPLE
ARE NOT NO FUSE CORPS FOR A FEW
YEARS NOW HAS BEEN PLACING VERY
SUCCESSFUL MID CAREER
EXECUTIVES IN LOCAL GOVERNMENT.
TO WORK ON INNOVATIVE EFFORTS.
NOT HAD THE GOOD FORTUNE IN OUR
REASON TO YET HAVE A FUSE
FOLLOW BUT NOW I'M PROUD TO SAY
THAT WE HAVE TO FUSE FELLOWS
WORKING IN PARTNERSHIP WITH OUR
CENTER ONE WITH RIVERSIDE
COUNTY EDA AND THE OTHER WITH
SOMEBODY IN COUNTY EDA THE
ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT AGENCIES
AND BOTH OF THOSE COUNTIES. TO
LOOK AT WHAT ARE THE
OPPORTUNITIES HERE TO GROW
INVESTMENTS BUT TO DO SO IN A
WAY. THAT PROVIDE SOCIAL AND
ECONOMIC MOBILITY AND ADDRESS
SOME OF THESE RACIAL. AND
GENDER DISPARITIES THAT WE
FLAG. RIGHT WE DON'T JUST WANT
TO THROW MONEY. TO ADVANTAGE
WINNERS WHO ARE ALREADY DOING
FINE. WE WANT TO HAVE THAT
FOCUS ON HOW TO IMPROVE THE
SOCIAL GOOD. AS WE GROW
INVESTMENTS AND ALLOW
OPPORTUNITIES FOR INVESTORS TO
PROFIT IN THIS REGION. IN
ADDITION TO THAT WE ARE ALSO
EXPERIENCING AN EFFORT CALLED
INLAND EMPIRE INTO AN ECOSYSTEM
OR BE SQUARED FOR SHORT. IN
PARTNERSHIP WITH SOME PARTNERS
THAT YOU WILL HEAR FROM LATER
ON TODAY CLEANING THE OUR COG
THE WATSON RIVERSIDE COUNCIL
GOVERNMENT'S. COUNTY RIVERSIDE
VARIOUS JURISDICTIONS INCLUDING
THE CITY OF CORONA. AS WELL AS
OUR PARTNERS IN SAN PRETTY
ACCOUNT. HOPE TO DO IS TO
PRODUCE A COMPANION REPORT TO
AYE EGO. BECAUSE WE DON'T WANT
TO LEAVE THE IMPRESSION THAT
THE ONLY JOBS WERE CREATING
THIS REASON ARE ARE FOR THOSE
WITHOUT COLLEGE DEGREES WE
KNOW. THAT OUR COLLEGES AND
UNIVERSITIES PRODUCE TENS OF
THOUSANDS OF GRADUATES OVER A
DECADE HIGH SKILLED. WE ALSO
KNOW THAT WE HAVE SO MANY
ASSETS IN THIS REGION IN TERMS
OF QUALITY OF LIFE AND HOUSING
AFFORDABILITY. THAT CAN ATTRACT
HIGH SKILLED WORKERS NO MATTER
WHERE THEY GOT THEIR DEGREES.
SO THAT IS GOING TO BE AN
IMPORTANT FOCUS. IN TERMS OF.
IN TERMS OF DOING COMPREHENSIVE
RESEARCH BUT IMPORTANTLY
GETTING THE MESSAGE OUT. THAT
PEOPLE SHOULD HAVE A
COMPREHENSIVE VIEW OF WHAT.
INCLUSIVE ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT
IN THIS REGION LOOKS LIKE. I
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME AND
OPENED ANY QUESTIONS. THANK YOU
SO MUCH FOR YOUR PRESENTATION I
DO HAVE A COUPLE FOLLOW UP
QUESTIONS AND FOR THOSE IN THE
AUDIENCE IF YOU DO HAVE
QUESTIONS I HOPE BY A DOCTOR
I'M A CHRISTIAN IS ABLE TO
STAY. TO THE END THANK YOU. SO
WE HAVE MANY REGIONAL LEADERS
IN THIS ROOM TODAY LOCAL
LEADERS FROM SAMBAR DO NOT
COUNTY TO RIVERSIDE COUNTY.
REPRESENT MANY DIFFERENT AREAS
I WANTED TO KNOW WHAT ARE THE
MOST IMPORTANT ACTIONS THAT THE
INLAND EMPIRE CAN TAKE TO
SUPPORT A POOR MOBILITY WITHIN
THIS NEXT YEAR. EXCELLENT
QUESTION. WELL I THINK WE HAVE
A LITTLE BIT OF THAT ROADMAP
ALREADY AS I'VE MENTIONED BUT
THESE INITIATIVES I THINK THE
KEY AND THIS IS WHERE. THE
STATE CAN BE AN IMPORTANT
PARTNER. WE'RE SAYING THIS FROM
THE GOVERNOR'S OFFICE WERE
SAYING THIS FROM THE
LEGISLATURE PEOPLE ARE
INTERESTED IN REGIONAL
DEVELOPMENT THEY UNDERSTAND
THAT IN ORDER TO HAVE A STRONG
CALIFORNIA YOU NEED TO HAVE
STRONG REGIONS. THEY ALSO
UNDERSTAND THAT IF WE'RE GOING
TO BE TALKING ABOUT A
CALIFORNIA FOR ALL WHICH IS THE
HASHTAG AND THEME THAT THE
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE IS IT IS IT
IS NOT JUST USING IT'S KEY TO
THEIR FRAMING OF WHERE
CALIFORNIANS TO GO. WE CANNOT
HAVE A CALIFORNIA FOR ALL IF WE
DON'T HAVE AN IN THE INLAND
EMPIRE THAT A STRONG. RIGHT
WERE OVER FOUR AND A HALF
MILLION RESIDENTS IN THE NEXT
CENSUS IS PROBABLY GOING TO
SHOW AN EVEN GREATER JOB IN
THOSE NUMBERS. SO THE KEY IS TO.
HIGHLIGHT THOSE OPPORTUNITIES
BUT I THINK AN IMPORTANT PIECE
WILL BE TO SEE HOW CAN WE BEST
LEVERAGE. PUBLIC PUBLIC DOLLARS
TO ENCOURAGE PRIVATE INVESTMENT.
WE ALSO NEED TRANSFORMATIONAL
INVESTMENTS IN OUR REGION I'VE
ALREADY TALKED ABOUT THE
RELOCATION OF CARB THAT WAS A
SIGNIFICANT HEAD AND HEAVY LEFT
WHERE WE HAVE PARTNERS
THROUGHOUT OUR REGION NOT JUST
IN THE CITY OF RIVERSIDE
RIVERSIDE COUNTY BUT ALSO IN ST
REDDING COUNTY SEEING THAT THAT
WOULD BE A GAME CHANGER FOR OUR
REGION. WE'RE HOPING IS THAT WE
CONTINUE TO CAPITALIZE ON THAT
AND NOT JUST REST CONTENT. BUT
THAT BY ITSELF IS GOING TO BE.
TRANSFORMATIONAL FOR A REGION.
SO THIS IS WHY FOCUSING ON A
GREEN TECH CLEAN TECH ECOSYSTEM
IS GOING TO BE SO IMPORTANT.
BUT ANOTHER IMPORTANT PIECE IS
WHAT THAT FUTURE OF LOGISTICS
IS GONNA LOOK LIKE. WE HAVE
RESEARCH FROM THE UNIVERSITY OF
REDLANDS. THE PORTRAYS A PRETTY
GRIM PICTURE OF WHAT AN
UNEMPLOYMENT WILL LOOK LIKE IN
THIS REGION. IF WE DON'T GET
AHEAD OF WHAT THAT AUTOMATION
REVOLUTION WHICH IS ALREADY
UNDER WAY. WHEN IT REACHES ITS
ADVANCED STAGES WITHIN THE NEXT
FIVE YEARS WHAT THAT'S GONNA
MEAN FOR THIS REGION. ECONOMIC
DIVERSIFICATION IS GOING TO BE
AN IMPORTANT PART TO MAKE SURE
THAT WERE RESILIENT. BUT
THERE'S ALSO IMPORTANT
INNOVATIONS THAT WE NEED TO DO
WITHIN OUR WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT. IN LOGISTICS TO
MAKE SURE THAT WERE PREPARED
FOR THAT EVENTUALITY. AND THEN
JUST A FOLLOW UP QUESTION YOU
ACTUALLY JUST TOUCHED ON
PRIVATE INVESTMENT IN PUBLIC
DOLLARS. AND MY QUESTION TO YOU
IS HOW CAN THE INLAND EMPIRE
SUPPORT LOCAL AND REGIONAL
EFFORTS TO REALLY CATALYZE
CATALYZE PRIVATE INVESTMENT IN
BUSINESS DEVELOPMENT AND
HISTORICALLY. UNDER SERVED
POPULATIONS IN OUR REGION. AND
THERE'S MANY POCKETS THROUGH
ABSOLUTELY ABSOLUTELY. NO ONE
OF THE THINGS IN THE COURSE OF
DOING RESEARCH ON THE AYE YOU
GO REPORT BUT EVEN AS WE'RE
WORKING ON IT SQUARE NOW.
PEOPLE TALK ABOUT THE LACK OF.
CRITICAL VENTURE CAPITAL
INVESTMENT IN THIS REGION. A
LOT OF IT IS EITHER CONCERT
HERE IN THE BAY AREA OR THEIR
THEIR THEIR OR IMPORTANT
DEVELOPMENTS HAPPENING IN LOS
ANGELES AS WELL AS- AN ORANGE
COUNTY. WE HAVE NOT YET SEEN
THOSE BENEFITS ONE OF THE GOOD
NEWS I WOULD SAY IS FOR EXAMPLE
OF RIVERSIDE COUNTY FUSE
FOLLOW. COMES WITH A VENTURE
CAPITAL BACKGROUND SO HOPEFULLY
SOME OF THOSE RELATIONSHIPS
WILL MATTER. WE CAN DO SO MUCH
MORE. AND VENTURE CAPITAL CAN
CAN BE LARGE AND SMALL WE CAN
THINK OF CROWDFUNDING
MICROENTERPRISE LENDING AT A
VERY. LOCAL LEVEL IS MAKING A
DIFFERENCE AS WELL. AND WITHOUT
WERE PARTNERING WITH RED IF
WHICH IS VERY ACTIVE IN LA WITH
AN INITIATIVE CALLED LA RISE SO
SOCIAL ENTERPRISE. THEY TEND TO
SUPPORT LARGER ORGANIZATIONS.
BUT WE'RE WORKING WITH RIGHT IF
THE COMMUNITY FOUNDATION GOOD
WELL AND OTHERS. TO SEE HOW CAN
WE- DO. DO MORE A SOCIAL
ENTERPRISE INVESTMENTS IN OUR
REGION IT'S IN A VERY EARLY
STAGE. BUT THE KEY IS THAT WE-
WE NEED TO HAVE. SUPPORT WE
HAVE THE SUPPORT INTERNALLY.
BUT WE NEED TO HAVE EXTERNAL
SUPPORT BUT ALSO. WE NEED TO
CHANGE THE PERCEPTION. WITH
MANY OF HIS INITIAL IS PEOPLE
DON'T EVEN KNOW THAT THIS IS
HAPPENING. WE NEED TO BE MUCH
MORE EFFECTIVE AND I SEE THIS
IS AN IMPORTANT OPPORTUNITY
WITH DECISION MAKERS COMING
FROM SACRAMENTO. TO TALK ABOUT
VARIOUS INITIATIVES THAT ARE
HAPPENING SO THE PEOPLE DON'T
HAVE A ONE SIDED STEREOTYPICAL
VIEW. OF WHAT IS HAPPENING HERE
AND IS WHAT WHAT IS WORTH
INVESTING IN. BUT CHANGING
PERCEPTIONS JUST STEP ONE. WE
NEED TO FOLLOW IT UP. AND WE
NEED TO CREATE THE CONDITIONS
THAT WILL MEAN MORE INVESTMENT
BOTH LARGE AND SMALL IN OUR
REGION. WONDERFUL THANK YOU SO
MUCH DOCTOR I'M A CHRISTIAN FOR
BEING HERE THIS MORNING
PROVIDING YOUR EXPERTISE AND
INSIGHT ON THIS ISSUE MY
PLEASURE. IF OUR NEXT SPEAKER
WILL JOIN US AT THE
PRESENTATION TABLE I WILL
PROVIDE A BRIEF FRAMEWORK OF
THIS AGENDA ITEM. AS WE JUST
HEARD FROM OUR PRIOR SPEAKER
REGIONAL LEVEL STRATEGIES HAVE
MANY ECONOMIC AND BUSINESS
DEVELOPMENT BENEFITS. IN THE
STATE AS LARGEST CALIFORNIA AT
THE REGIONAL MODEL CAN BOTH
CATALYSE ACTIONS LOCALLY. BUT
ALSO SERVE TO AMPLIFY LOCAL
STAKEHOLDER VOICES TO THE STATE
AND FEDERAL GOVERNMENTS WE HAVE
WITH US AMBER BOLDEN SENIOR
PROJECT MANAGER I CALIFORNIA
FOR TO DISCUSS A NUMBER OF
THESE TYPE OF REGIONAL
INITIATIVES. AMONG OTHER
INITIATIVES MISS BOLD AND WILL
BRIEF THE COMMITTEE ON GOVERNOR
NEWSOME'S REGION'S RICE
TOGETHER INITIATIVE FOR WHICH
ORGANIZATION. IS A KEY PARTNER
MISS WALDRON IF YOU'D LIKE TO
BEGIN. THANK YOU SO MUCH MA'AM
CHAIR AND THANK YOU TO MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE AND THANK YOU
FOR HAVING ME THIS MORNING I
ALSO WANTED TO. JUST EXTEND OUR
GRATITUDE TO DR I'M A CHRISTIAN
FOR REALLY SETTING THE STAGE
AND REALLY MAKING A CLEAR
FRAMING OF THE THINGS THAT WE
WERE DISCUSSING AT THE REGION'S
RISE TOGETHER. MEETING SO THIS
WAS THE FIRST IN A SERIES OF
MEETINGS THAT ARE GOING TO BE
HOSTED THROUGHOUT THE INLAND
EMPIRE SO SPECIFICALLY THAT WAS
SAM BERNIE DINO AND RIVERSIDE
COUNTY BUT ALSO IN THE SAN
JOAQUIN VALLEY. AND THE PURPOSE
OF THESE MEETINGS AND I WANT TO
FIRST BE VERY CLEAR THAT THE
PURPOSE OF THESE MEETINGS IS TO
HELP LISTEN TO HELP. HERE WITH
THE REGION SAYING THE GOVERNOR.
UNDERSTAND. THAT MAKES THE
REGION'S OTHER READ THAT THE
STATE IS TO BE SUCCESSFUL UNDER
ENDING THAT HAS RECEIVED REALLY
SPEAK TO WHAT HELPS THE
REGION'S IS TOGETHER IT'S GOING
TO BE FOUND IN THE KING'S IN IN
THESE DISCUSSIONS SO. WHEN
YOU'RE FOR A PARTNERSHIP WITH
OUR- THE APARTMENT IS YOU HE
YOU SEE ARE AT THE SIX THE
FIRST SHOW INNOVATION AND THE
COMMUNITY FOUNDATION I EAT P.
OR YOU'RE IN ONCE. REGARDING
THREE SPECIFIC WE IN SIGHT
COMING AND SAMBAR NINETY NOW.
OUR WE WERE ABLE TO BRING A
WIDE RANGE OF STATE THIS
TOGETHER TO HAVE A DISCUSSION
ON WHAT THE INTO YOU KNOW WHAT
IT IS THAT LOOKING. AT AND WHAT
IT IS THAT IS REALLY GOING TO
HELP THIS READ. AXE IS AN BY
TALLY OF ALL THE REASONS THIS
FOR. SO IN DOING I WOULD
DEFINITELY SIGN UP FOR TO BE TO
GAUGE. THE REGION'S RISING THE
NATION AS YOU CAN SEE PROMOTE
AGENTS ARE PLANNING A
PARTNERSHIP KING THE- MAP
HEALTH AS ONE IN. PARTICULAR
ALLEN IS THE WORKING TO
OVERCOME INCOME RATIO IN WITH
THIS EFFORT AND IMPROVING THE
CONNECTION THE COSTA RICA. AND
LINK CALIFORNIA. NICE THAT. ALL
OF THE REGIONS HAVE BEEN IT'S
NOT THERE IS A COLLECTIVE
STRATEGIC PARTNERSHIP THAT
NEEDS. IN ORDER TO MAKE SURE
THAT ALL OF THE- ACT. ALL OF
THEM ARE AT THEIR HIGHEST
CAPACITY. DURING THE REGION'S
RISE TOGETHER. MEETING ONE OF
THE THINGS THAT WE HEARD WELL
BEFORE WE BEFORE I MOVE THEY
ALSO WANT TO MAKE SURE THEY
WERE VERY CLEAR ABOUT OUR
PARTNERSHIP AND THAT. WE DO
HAVE THE EMMA USE AVAILABLE
UPON REQUEST IF THAT'S
SOMETHING THAT YOU'RE
INTERESTED IN TO JUST KIND OF
DETAIL EXACTLY WHAT THE
PARAMETERS ARE OF OUR
RELATIONSHIP WITH KOBE IS. AND
ALSO CALIFORNIA FORWARD AND
WHAT WE ARE EXPECTING TO SEE
FROM OUR PARTNERSHIP THESE
MEETINGS ARE GOING TO BE HELD.
PLANNING AND WE'RE ACTUALLY
PLANNING RIGHT NOW EVEN THROUGH
THE SAN JOAQUIN. ALTHOUGH WE'RE
HOUSING AND THE SAN JOAQUIN
VALLEY AND- RIVERSIDE COUNTY
AND SAN BERNARDINO COUNTY. THE
REGION'S WILL BE THESE MEETINGS
WILL BE HOSTED THROUGH NOVEMBER
OF TWENTY TWENTY. SO VERY
QUICKLY I MEAN THIS IS A PRETTY
SIMPLE DIAGRAM AND OF HOW THIS
ALL PLAYS TOGETHER SO FIRST
IMAGE YOU CAN CLEARLY SEE THE
STARTS WITH THE REGION'S AND
REGIONAL INITIATIVE. OUR
REGIONAL PARTNER AND ONE OF
VERY CLEAR THAT IT REQUIRES
COLLECTIVE ACTION SO AS WE CAN
ABOVE REMOTE. BUT THE REGION IN
ORDER TO BE SUCCESSFUL WHAT IT.
ALLEGES. IS MY PARTNER FROM THE
PEOPLE WHO ARE. HERE THE RIGHT
PRICE TOGETHER AT SOME THAT
REALLY. THE OWNERSHIP AND PUTS
THE AGENTS STARTING WITHIN THE
REGION'S REALLY ELEVATED BEGIN
THE CONVERSATION IT'S EIGHT
EIGHT WHAT WE NEED THIS THE ACT
NOW WE ARE LOOKING FOR. AND
THEN WE CAN ARTICULATE. ASIANS
TO THE STATE SO YOU SEE. YOU
KNOW WHAT WE BEGIN THE
DISCUSSIONS WITH WITH THE ROAD
ENDS WITH FOCUS AGAIN. IN THE
INLAND EMPIRE AND THEN AND THEN
MOVING. WHEREBY AGAIN STARTING
STACKS THEY WERE WERE MAKERS
OKAY FAN ONE VALLEY. ALSO IS IN
THE COLLECTIVE ACTION USING.
VISITATION FOR LIKE THE SENATE
SOCIAL INNOVATION AND ALSO
PARTNERING WITH COLLECTIVE
ACTION INITIATIVES LIKE A
CALIFORNIA AND THE INLAND
EMPIRE AND RISING WE WANT TO
MAKE SURE THAT WE ARE USING THE
WHAT IS BEING DONE SUCCESSFULLY
IN THE REGION AND INSTEAD OF
DUPLICATING THOSE EFFORTS WERE
LEVERAGING. EFFORTS SO MOVING
FORWARD AS WE APPROACH THE
ECONOMIC SUMMIT WHICH IS GOING
TO BE HOSTED IN FRESNO SO WE'RE
VERY EXCITED ABOUT THAT BUT
MOVING FORWARD TO THE ECONOMIC
SUMMIT WE'RE GOING TO BE
COLLECTING INFORMATION FROM ALL
OF THESE MEETINGS. COLLECTING
THAT MOVING IT FORWARD TO THE
STATE AND THEN USING THAT IN
OUR WORK GROUPS TO MAKE BACK
LEGISLATIVE RECOMMENDATIONS
DURING THAT TIME AND THEN
GETTING YOU BACK FROM THE
GOVERNOR FOR WHAT HIS
INITIATIVES ARE. AND HIS WHAT
HIS PLAN IS FOR THE FOR THE
INLAND EMPIRE AND FOR THE
INLAND REGIONS IN THE SAN
JOAQUIN VALLEY SPECIFICALLY.
I'M IN A DAY AND SO THE THING
IS THAT. DR RAMAKRISHNAN
DIMENSION DURING HIS INTONATION
WERE. NUMBER THE THEME WITH
BOSCH. AT THAT THAT EVIDENCE.
STATIONS THAT WE WERE HAVING
THAT. BUT I ALSO WANT TO. BILL.
WE GO THERE THERE WERE A WIDE
RANGE. FOR STATE AND WE
DEFINITELY THINK THAT REALLY
KANSEN PROVIDED. BY STE
QUESTION WHAT THE REGION'S ME
WE ARE LOOKING FOR. WE ARE THE
FEEL AND WHAT WE GAP WAS
CONTROL THE NARRATIVE WITH
DEFINITELY SOMETHING THAT
REGION ARE YOU CAN. GET WE
DON'T WANT TO BE. DEPENDING ON
WHAT THIS IS ABOUT. NOT THOUGHT
LEADERS THAT WE DO NOT. THE
KEEP THAT WE'RE NOT MAKING AN
EXCEPTION HERE FOR THE REGION
WITH AND THE REGION. THE THINGS
THAT WE ARE DOING AND WHAT DO
REAL ON THE COLLECTIVE ACTION
CAN. RELY ON THE- OF THE
UNIVERSE EASE OF THE PROFIT
WORLD AND WORKS DEVELOPMENT AND
FOR SOME REASON OR MAKE THAT
HAPPEN. SO WE ARE A LOT THAT IN
ADDITION WITH LEAKS ABOUT IT IS
THAT WE SO CALLED ACTION DURING
THE MEETING SO NOT ONLY WHERE
WERE WE TALKING ABOUT THE TEAMS
ARE WHERE WE KIND OF LAYING THE
GROUNDWORK FOR WHAT WE THINK
COULD BE BETTER BUT ALSO SAYING
WHAT CAN WE DO AND SO THAT
INCLUDED. BEING MORE INVOLVED
IN COMMISSIONS BEING MORE
INVOLVED IN GRANT BEING MORE
INVOLVED IN THE PLANNING OF THE
REGION AND ALSO MAKING SURE
THAT WE ARE WHEN WE TALK ABOUT
THE REGION PUBLICLY ON THAT WE
ARE SPEAKING ABOUT IT WITH A
SENSE OF AGENCY A SENSE OF
PRIDE A SENSE OF WE ARE
CHOOSING TO BE HERE. NOT THAT
WE ARE. KIND OF. JEFF ON THE ON
THE AISLE LIARS OF MORE
INNOVATIVE. AGENT REGIONS IN
ADDITION I THINK ONE OF THE
OTHER. CONVERSATIONS THAT WAS
REALLY ELEVATED WAS BEING
STRATEGIC ABOUT BRINING OUR
CIRCLES AND EMPLOYMENT SO
INSTEAD OF JUST. MAINTAINING
SILOS AND THAT WAS ANOTHER
MAJOR DISCUSSION THAT WE HAVE
SO MAKING SURE THAT. BRENT THAT
WE ARE BRANCHING OUT AND HAVING
DISCUSSIONS WITH. DIFFERENT
GENERATIONS MAKING SURE THAT
YOU ARE. MAKING A WHERE YOU
KNOW THE POLICIES THE
INITIATIVES THAT EACH
INDIVIDUAL ORGANIZATION IS
WORKING ON AND NOT JUST KEEPING
THAT WITHIN YOUR OWN SMALL
GROUP GOES A VERY LONG WAY AND
REALLY ELEVATING THE NARRATIVE
OF WHAT OTHER REGIONAL WHAT
PEOPLE THINK ABOUT THEMSELVES
AND THEN ALSO WHAT THE REGION
BEGINS TO THINK ABOUT ITSELF
AND THEN WHAT. PEOPLE FROM
OUTSIDE OF THE REGIONAL AWFUL
THING. AND I THINK ONE OF THE
OTHER THINGS THAT I'VE BEEN
ACTUALLY PRIVILEGE TO DO WAS
HAVE ONE ON ONE DISCUSSIONS
WITH. PARTICIPANTS SO I REALLY
WAS ABLE TO GET A BIT MORE
GRANULAR AND THAT INFORMATION
ONE THE THINGS THAT HAS ALSO
COME THAT THAT HAS BEEN VERY
VERY CLEAR IS THAT. DURING
THESE LISTENING SESSIONS IT'S
REALLY GREAT TO GET THIS
INFORMATION AND WE WERE REALLY
EXCITED TO DO AND TO SHARE IT
WITH THE STATE AND WE ARE
EXCITED ABOUT OUR RULE TO BE
ABLE TO PARTICIPATE IN THIS
BECAUSE IT REALLY. UNDER IT
EIGHT IT SERVES THE TRIPLE
BOTTOM LINE OF WHAT CALIFORNIA
FORWARD IS DOING. BUT WE ALSO
WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT WE ARE
NOT USING A SINGULAR
PRESCRIPTIVE RECOMMENDATION FOR
THE INLAND EMPIRE OR FOR THE
FOR THE INLAND REGION. TRULY
WHAT WE ARE LOOKING FOR IS
SOMETHING THAT IS CONSIDERING.
THAT IS DELIBERATE AND THAT IS
REALLY PAYING ATTENTION TO THE
DIFFERENCES AND THE VARIANCES
OF THE REGION VERSES. THE FOR
EXAMPLE COASTAL REGIONS. THE
REQUIREMENTS AND THE CHALLENGES
THAT THE AND THEN REGION SPACE.
OR EVEN THAT THE THAT THE
COUNTY SPACE IF WE'RE BEING
VERY SPECIFIC SAMPOERNA TINA
VERSES RIVERSIDE COUNTY IS
DIFFERENT AND SO IF WE'RE
MAKING. RECOMMENDATIONS WE ARE
WORKING WITH OUR PARTNERS IN
MAKING SURE THAT. THOSE
RECOMMENDATIONS THAT ARE COMING
FROM THE STATE OR EVEN THE
RECOMMENDATIONS THAT. ARE EVEN
BEING INVESTED OR DEVELOPED
WITHIN THE REGION ARE VERY
CONSIDERATE OF THE VARIATIONS
WITHIN THE REGIONS WITHIN THE
COUNTIES AND THE CAPACITY AND
THEIR ABILITY TO. TO COMPLETE
THAT ACTION. SO IT WAS. A MAJOR
OPPORTUNITY. THAT WE SAW HIM
OUT THERE WE'RE GOING TO
CONTINUE TO WORK AND DEVELOP
AND THEN WE'RE GOING TO.
CONTINUE TO TAKE THIS
INFORMATION TO MOVE FORWARD ALL
AS WERE LEADING UP TO THE
SUMMIT SO WE'RE VERY VERY
EXCITED ABOUT THAT. AND I JUST
WANNA CALL YOUR ATTENTION TO
SOME OF THE IMPORTANT DATES AS
YOU CAN SEE TODAY SEPTEMBER
TWENTY FIFTH WE DO HAVE. A
REGION'S RISE AGAIN MEETING IN
YOUR SKILLS WERE VERY EXCITED
ABOUT THAT. ON OCTOBER THIRD
WE'RE GOING TO BE IN BED. AND
WE ARE. NOT FOR SEVEN SO WE'RE
REALLY. LOOKING AT LIGHTNING
SPEED UP UNTIL THE SUMMIT IN
THIS. THE GOVERNOR WILL SPEAK
IT TIME. IS AN INFORMATION THAT
WE COLLECT. AND WITH THE. READ
IN ALSO MAKING THAT THE CLIENT
TO EMMA AND STATE INTENT FOR
WHAT THE- PLAN AND DEVELOP WILL
BE FOR SPECIFIC. REGIONS BUT I
DON'T WANT TO. LEAVE WITHOUT
ALSO PRICING THAT. WE
DEFINITELY REQUIRE WE DEPEND ON
THE PARTNERSHIP OF THE
NONPROFIT OF OUR REGIONAL
PARTNERS TO REALLY DO THIS WORK
SO AND OUR LEGISLATORS TO MAKE
SURE THAT AS WE ARE DOING THIS
WORK THAT WE'RE KEEPING YOU IN
THE LOOP AND ALSO ARTICULATING
WHAT IT IS WE NEED SO THAT
THOSE CONVERSATIONS WHEN
THEY'RE BEING LEVERAGED. THEY
CAN BE REINFORCED ON THE POLICY
SETTING AGENDAS SO WE
DEFINITELY SEE THIS IS A
COLLABORATIVE EFFORT AND WE ARE
MOVING IT FORWARD. YOU KNOW
THAT FAST AND FURIOUS ON UP
INTO THE SOME IN AND THEN
BEYOND. THANK YOU YOU HAVE ANY
QUESTIONS I WOULD APPRECIATE
THAT. IF YOU HAVE A MOMENT FOR
A COUPLE QUESTIONS I DO I DO
WANT TO TOUCH ON IT WHAT IS THE
COMMUNITY ENGAGEMENT STRATEGY
THE CALIFORNIA FOR IT IS YOU
SEE AN OFFER REGION'S RICE
TOGETHER FOR SURE. SO AGAIN
WITH OUR PARTNERSHIP FOR WE ARE
REACHING OUT AND REALLY RELYING
HEAVILY ON OUR PARTNERS ARE
REGIONAL PARTIES TO. TO EXTEND
THE STAKEHOLDERS AND SHARE
THEIR NETWORKS WITH US IN
ADDITION I AM AND I LIVE HERE
SO I AM A GRADUATE OF YOU SEE
OUR AND I WAS ACTUALLY REALLY
ENCOURAGED TO HEAR. THE. WHAT
DOCTOR OCCASIONALLY SING
WISHING I FEEL LIKE YOU SEE OUR
UNIVERSITIES LIKE THAT
DEFINITELY GIVE THE OPPORTUNITY
FOR PEOPLE TO STAY TO BE AND TO
BE THOUGHT LEADERS HERE SO. SO
WE'RE USING THAT NETWORK WERE
USING PEOPLE WHO ARE WHO ARE
FROM THE REGION WE'RE LOOKING
FOR. FEEDBACK FROM PEOPLE WHO
LIVE HERE WHO WORK HERE WHO
PLAY HERE IN JUST TRYING TO
UNDERSTAND WHAT IT IS THAT THE
NEED. AN ADDITIONAL WE I AM
FULLY AVAILABLE MY INFORMATION
IS AVAILABLE IF ANY IF THERE'S
EVER ANY FEEDBACK BUT I'VE
DEFINITELY ME STRATEGIC EFFORTS
TO REACH OUT TO THE PEOPLE. WHO
ARE WHO ARE OUR PARTNERS IN KEY
STAKEHOLDERS AND PARTICIPATING
IN THESE. WELL I LIKE TO GIVE A
SHOUT OUT TO THE HIGHLANDER IS.
A AS A FELLOW HIGHLANDER
MYSELF. BUT I DO WANT TO I JUST
ASKED HOUSE ORGANIZATION
HELPING GO BIZ AND FOR THOSE
THAT YOU. ARE THEY MAY NOT BE
FAMILIAR WITH THE TERM GO BIZ
THAT'S THE GOVERNOR'S OFFICE OF
BUSINESS AND ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT. HOW IS YOUR
ORGANIZATION HELPING GO BIZ THE
MORE INCLUSIVE FOR SURE SO
THANK YOU AN EXCELLENT QUESTION
AND AGAIN WE ALSO HAD THE THEM
USE HERE TODAY IF THAT'S
SOMETHING THAT YOU'RE
INTERESTED IN BUT- BY. HAVING
REGIONAL REPRESENTATION AND
EVEN. THE OUR ABILITY TO BE
PRESIDENT AND BECAUSE INTO THAT
THE TO THE BORN TO HEARING
TODAY. REPRESENTS OUR ABILITY
TO CONNECT GO BASE BECAUSE GO
WITH DOES NOT EXIST. EVERYWHERE
IN THE WAY THAT WE WOULD LIKE
BY HOSTING THESE MEETINGS IN
THESE QUÉ AND EVEN THE SORTS
OF CONVENING IT ALLOWS THEM TO.
HAVE DISCUSSIONS WITH THE
REGION'S IN A WAY THAT THEY
WOULD NOT BE ABLE TO INTERFACE
WITH THEM ON A REGULAR BASIS
SO. THE PLANNING OF THESE
REGIONS THE INVITING OF THOSE
STAKEHOLDERS AND THEN ALSO THE
SYNTHESIS THEY FANTASIZING THAT
INFORMATION IN A WAY THAT IT'S
GOING TO BE. SOMETHING THAT CAN
REALLY INFORMED THEIR ANALYSIS
IS THAT. THAT IS OUR OUR MEAN
RELATIONSHIP. WONDERFUL THANK
YOU SO MUCH MISS BOLD AND THE
REJECT YOUR TIME TODAY THANK
YOU. WHAT AND JUST A QUICK
STATEMENT BEFORE YOU BRING UP
THE NEXT TO OUR PANEL WHO WILL
BE DISCUSSING INNOVATIONS IT
UPWARD MOBILITY I'M A VERY BIG
BELIEVER IN COMMUNITY LEVEL
WORK I BUILDING POLICY FROM THE
GROUND UP AS YOU HAVE SEEN FROM
MANY. OF OUR PIECES OF UP
POLICIES THAT WE'VE INTRODUCED
SINCE BEING IN OFFICE AND THOSE
THAT HAVE MOVED FOR TO THE
GOVERNOR'S DESK. I BELIEVE THAT
IT'S ALWAYS VERY IMPORTANT THAT
WE AS CONVENERS ARE VERY
INTENTIONAL AND TO WORK
CONSTANTLY CHALLENGING
OURSELVES TO BE MORE INCLUSIVE
AND TO RECOGNIZE WHOSE VOICES
ARE NOT BEING HEARD. AND SO I
WOULD ENCOURAGE ARE ALL THE
LEADERS IN THE ROOM I TO THINK
ABOUT THAT AS WELL AS WE- ARE
CONVENE AT DIFFERENT GROUPS
DISCUSSING DIFFERENT ISSUES AND
TOPICS THAT ARE IMPORTANT TO
OUR COMMUNITIES. I WANT YOU TO
KNOW THAT USE OUR OFFICE AS
WELL. TO FACILITATE MEETINGS WE
ARE HERE TO COLLABORATE WITH
THE COMMUNITY FROM CITY COUNCIL
TO OUR- OUR BORDERS SUPERVISORS
AND SO FORTH BUT AGAIN I
BELIEVE. THAT BEING INCLUSIVE
IS ABSOLUTELY IMPORTANT. THE
NEXT SPEAKERS WE HAVE IF YOU
CAN PLEASE JOIN US ON THE PANEL.
WE WILL HAVE A FORMAL
PRESENTATION THAT WILL CONCLUDE
WITH THE KIND OF ECONOMIC AND
WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT
PROFESSIONALS WHO WILL
HIGHLIGHT PROJECTS RESEARCH AND
INITIATIVES THAT SUPPORT UPWARD
MOBILITY AND INCLUSIVE
ECONOMIC. PROSPERITY IN THE
INLAND EMPIRE WE ARE PLEASED TO
WELCOME MOLLY WILSHIRE
ASSISTANT DIRECTOR OF SAMBAR
DINO COUNTY WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT I DEPARTMENT DOCTOR
ELSA MACIAS. AUTHOR OF A REPORT
PUBLISHED BY HIS SPINE US
ORGANIZE FOR POLITICAL EQUALITY
OTHERWISE KNOWN AS HOPE. AND IT
MATTHEW HORDE CHURNET ASSOCIATE
DIRECTOR WHO WE WORKED WITH
EXTENSIVELY IN SACRAMENTO FOR
THE CENTER FOR REGIONAL
ECONOMICS AND CALIFORNIA CENTER
AT THE MILKEN INSTITUTE I THANK
YOU FOR JOINING US TODAY I KNOW
THAT WE MAY HAVE ADDITIONAL
FOLKS JOINING US ON THIS PANEL
SHORTLY AFTER. EACH IF YOU GET
YOUR PRESENTATION. OUR FIRST
PRESENTER THIS MORNING WILL BE
MISSED WILSHIRE WHO WILL
PRESENT A CASE STUDY. ON ITS
GENERATION GO CAREER PATHWAYS
INITIATIVE WHICH INTEGRATES
EDUCATION INDUSTRY AND WORK FOR
SYSTEMS INTO ONE SYSTEM
DESIGNED TO PRODUCE AND RETAIN
IT RELEVANT TALENT IN THE
INLAND EMPIRE. CURRENTLY FUNDED
THROUGH DECEMBER DINO COUNTY'S
BOARD OF SUPERVISORS AND THE
WORK FORCE INNOVATION
OPPORTUNITY ACT THE INITIATIVE
HAS DEMONSTRATED AN ABILITY TO
BUILD UNIQUE AND CONNECTIONS
BETWEEN HIGH SCHOOL YOUTH AND
LOCAL BUSINESSES I ACTUALLY GOT
TO TOUR THIS FIRST HAND.
SEVERAL MONTHS AGO WHEN I WAS
INVITED BY MY COLLEAGUE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER JAMES RAMOS WHO
REPRESENTS THAT DISTRICT AND
THE REGIONAL LEADERS AS WELL
WHO INVITED US TO SEE FIRSTHAND
I THIS INITIATIVE AND HOW
POWERFUL CAN BE AND BRINGING
THAT UP TO SCALE I MISS
WILSHIRE PLEASE BEGIN WHEN
YOU'RE READY. OKAY THANK YOU SO
MUCH THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND
I WANT TO THANK THE JEDI STAFF
MEMBERS FOR THIS OPPORTUNITY AS
WELL WE'RE REALLY EXCITED ABOUT
IT AND TALKING ABOUT CHANGING
THE NARRATIVE AROUND INNOVATION
HAPPENING RIGHT HERE IN THE
INLAND EMPIRE. I BELIEVE THAT
THIS IS REALLY A PROGRAM THAT'S
DOING JUST THAT SO I'M EXCITED
ABOUT THIS OPPORTUNITY TO SHARE
A LITTLE BIT MORE ABOUT IT WITH
YOU ALL. AND THANK YOU AGAIN TO
MADAM CHAIR FOR TAKING THAT TO
WERE WITH US THAT WAS VERY
EXCITING. IN THE INTEREST OF
TIME I WILL SKIP A FEW SIGNS
BECAUSE I'VE BEEN TOLD I TEND
TO TALK ON AND ON SO JUST. BEAR
WITH ME HERE. SO SAN RENO
COUNTY WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT.
IS REALLY TAKING EIGHT OCTOBER
WHICH DEVELOPING. AND
RETAINING. OR SO RESPONSE TO
INDUSTRY NEEDS. OKAY BROWN THE
YOUTH PROGRAM UNDER SHOULD
PATHWAYS IS ONE COMPONENT OF
THAT OUR OTHER COMPONENTS OF
FOCUSED ON SERVING AT SCHOOL
USE THOSE THOSE AGES SIXTEEN
TWENTY FOUR TODAY WE'LL BE
TALKING SPECIFICALLY ABOUT HER
CAREER PLEASE PROGRAM. WHICH
FOCUSES ON IT PLEASE. SO AT THE
HEART OF THIS INITIATIVE IS
REALLY THE INTEGRATION OF
DIFFERENT SYSTEMS HAVE PRICKLY
WORK INSIDE. TOGETHER AND
EDUCATE INSISTED THAT INCLUDES
K. TWELVE AS WELL AS OUR
COMMUNITY COLLEGE. THE WORK
SYSTEM AND OUR INDUSTRY AND NO
ONE SYSTEM THAT'S DESIGNED TO
DEVELOP AND PRODUCE A SKILLED
AND RELEVANT PIPING A FEW FOR
TALENT. IN THE- EFFORT WE HAVE
PARTNERED WITH OUR SCHOOL
TRICKS WITH OUR LOCAL COMMUNITY
COLLEGES. AND MISS THE
COMMUNITY TO REALLY HONE OUR-
HEATING ARGUES FOR THE FUTURE
WORK. WHAT IS THAT LOOK LIKE.
UP LET ME DESCRIBE THAT PROCESS
SO A STUDENTS AS YOUNG AS
KINDERGARTEN ARE ARE LEARNING
HOW TO USE UP AND OPERATE THREE
D. PRINTING PRINTERS THREE D.
PRINTERS BY THE TIME THEY GET
MIDDLE SCHOOL. THERE AFTER A
CELL IN OUR THEIR WORK ON A
WEBSITE. FOR ON THE AMERICA'S I
LEFT I'M A LITTLE TOOK FROM
CURTIS A MIDDLE SCHOOL IN SAN
MARINO WHICH WAS ONE OF OUR
STOPS IN ORDER TO WORK. AS A
CONTINUE LEARNING THEIR CRAFT
IN IN SCHOOL BY THE TIME THEY
GET TO HIGH SCHOOL THAT'S WHERE
THE WORKFORCE SYSTEM COMES INTO
PLAY. DURING THEIR JUNIOR YEAR
STUDENTS ARE COMPLETING A
CAREER READINESS COURSE AND
THAT'S REALLY TEACHING THEM THE
SOFT SKILLS THAT EMPLOYERS AND
WE'VE ALL HEARD ARE TELLING US
THAT THEY NEED WE NEED SOMEBODY
WHO'S GOING TO SHOW UP ON TIME
WE NEED SOMEBODY WHO'S DRESSED
APPROPRIATELY WHO'S NOT GOING
TO BE. SCROLLING ON FACEBOOK
ALTHOUGH NOW I'M TOLD IT'S MORE
INSTAGRAM THE YOUNGER
GENERATIONS EVEN YOUNGER THAN
MINE ARE NOT USING FACEBOOK
ANYMORE IT'S INSTAGRAM. ARE
SNAPCHAT WHATEVER IT MAYBE US A
REALLY TEACHING THEM THE SOFT
SKILLS THEY HAVE TO COMPLETE
THAT COURSE WHICH IS TAUGHT BY
A COMMUNITY COLLEGE PROFESSOR.
PRIOR TO THEM BEING READY FOR
AN INTERNSHIP PLACEMENT. OF WE
RECOGNIZE THAT OUR
RELATIONSHIPS WITH OUR
BUSINESSES ARE KEY SO THEREFORE
WE'RE REALLY INTERESTED IN
MAKING SURE STUDENTS ARE
PREPARED PRIOR TO THEM GOING
INTO A AN OFF SITE WORK
LOCATION. SO WHEN THEIR SENIOR
YEAR THAT'S WHEN THEY'RE READY
TO HIT THE GROUND RUNNING
THEY'RE GOING TO BE PLACED OUT
IN A IN A BUSINESS OF THEIR
CHOICE WITHIN A CAREER PATHWAY
THAT THEY'D HAVE EXPERIENCE IN.
AND THEIR COMPLETING A HUNDRED
AND TWENTY HOURS OF INTERNSHIP
WITH A LOCAL EMPLOYER. WHILE
ALSO BEING CAN CURRENTLY
ENROLLED IN COMMUNITY COLLEGE.
SO THE STUDENTS ARE GRADUATING
HIGH SCHOOL NOT ONLY WITH THE
DIPLOMA BUT WITH SOME COLLEGE
CREDIT AND WORK EXPERIENCE ON
THEIR RESUME. SOME OF THE TYPES
OF PATHWAYS YOU CAN SEE THERE
ARE MANY DIFFERENT PATHWAYS
THROUGHOUT THE COUNTY THAT
SCHOOL DISTRICTS ARE ARE
HEAVILY INVOLVED IN. HEALTH
RELIGION IS AND ITS
MANUFACTURING. SOME INITIAL
THAT WE CURRENTLY WORKING WITH
OUR SHOWN THERE LOGISTICS. A
FAX TRAIN THE MEDICAL OR UP
FASHION. OFFICE AND. SO
CURRENTLY WE ARE STILL IN WHAT
WORKS WHEN OUR PILOT PHASE
BECAUSE WHILE OUR THREE YEAR
AGO BEFORE COHORT IN OUR STATE
BUT WE TRUST. SO WE PILOTED
THIS PROGRAM WITHIN THE CITY OF
SAN DINO UNIFIED SCHOOL
DISTRICT. I AND COLTON JOINT
UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT. WE
DECIDED TO START AND HEALTHCARE
PRIMARILY BECAUSE- OF THE
TEACHERS VOLUNTEERED. THIS
CLASS SO WE'VE LEARNED REALLY
ONLY ON THAT TEACHER AND IS
CRUCIAL AS THE LINE BUT THE
WORKING THESE STUDENTS GET
EXCITED ABOUT THIS TYPE OF WORK
AND IT IN EASY DECISION TO
START THEIR AT WITH AN EARLY
ADOPTER. HEALTHCARE IS ALSO ONE
FIVE AREAS FOR THE BOARD ON AS
IT'S A GROWING INDUSTRY HERE IN
THE REGION. WE JUST STARTED HAD
NO MEDICAL CENTER BECAUSE OF
OUR PARTNER. WITH THEM WITH A
PRE EXISTING. A REALLY NICE
LIKE OTHERS WHO ARE GOING WITH.
RECRUITMENT AND RETENTION NEED
THAT I NEED TO GROW THERE. EASY
EASY START THERE. THE IDEA HERE
IS THAT THESE INTERNSHIPS
PRIMARY HAVE BEEN DRIVEN BY
THEIR CAREER. HEARING CENTER A
OF HAVE THROUGH THEIR K. TWELVE
EDUCATION AND REALLY TRYING TO
EXPOSE THEM EARLY ON TO THE
CAREER OPPORTUNITIES THAT EXIST
HERE IN THE REGION THAT THEY
THEY THEY DON'T NEED TO LEAVE
WE HAVE HIGH SKILLED JOBS
AVAILABLE WE HAVE AREAS FOR
THEIR THEIR INTEREST RIGHT
HERE. OVER TIME OTHER PARTNERS
HAVE COME FORWARD WE WE'VE
BRANCH OUT OUR LARGEST COHORT
WAS A HUNDRED AND EIGHTY TWO
STUDENTS. WHO COMPLETED A WORK
EXPERIENCE THAT WAS WITHIN
TWENTY DIFFERENT COUNTY
DEPARTMENTS FOR BEING OKAY AND
TWENTY PRIVATE BUSINESS OWNERS.
AND SO. OVER TIME I HAS
MENTIONED PARTNERS HAVE COME
FORWARD AND I WOULD LIKE TO
JUST AT LEAST ACKNOWLEDGE ONE
OF THOSE KEY PARTNERS ON IN THE
PRIVATE INDUSTRY SIDE OF THINGS
IS TO GARNER WHOLE PRODUCTIONS
WHICH IS THE ANIMATRONICS
MANUFACTURER BASED IN REDLANDS.
AND IT HAS BEEN ONE OF THE
BIGGEST ADVOCATES FOR THESE FOR
THIS INITIATIVE HERE HE MAKES
YOU KNOW THE ANIMATRONICS THAT
YOU SEE AT DISNEYLAND OR NOT
VERY FAR IN THE STUDENTS HAVE
BEEN VERY EXCITED TO GET THE
OPPORTUNITY. TO MAKE THOSE AND
WHILE GARNER HOLE WAS TALKING
TO THE STUDENTS YOU KNOW HE'S
WHAT I HAVEN'T YOU SEEN OUR
WORK IN AT DISNEYLAND AND MANY
OF THE STUDENTS TO SAID. I'VE
NEVER BEEN TO DISNEYLAND AND
GARNER HOLE WAS YOU KNOW
SHOCKED BY THAT BUT THESE ARE
STUDENTS WHO ARE COMING FROM
VERY. LOW INCOME BACKGROUNDS
WOULD GENERATE FACING
GENERATIONS OF POVERTY AND SO
HE DECIDED TO PAY FOR ALL THEIR
STUDENTS AND TAKE THEM TO
DISNEYLAND SO THAT THEY CAN SEE
THEIR WORK SO I JUST WANT TO
MAKE SURE I TALK ABOUT HOW.
VITAL THAT THAT PARTNERSHIP HAS
BEEN. SO HOW DO WE REALLY DO
THIS. OUT RELATIONSHIPS THAT'S
THE KEY TO EVERYTHING RAINS
OTHER RELATIONSHIPS. WE AS YOU
CAN IMAGINE WE'VE TO REALLY
BREAK DOWN BARRIERS AND BREAK
DOWN SILOS. THE EDUCATION
COMMUNITY HASN'T NECESSARILY.
HAD CONVERSATIONS WITH THE
BUSINESS STREET IN IT STORE ALL
PERSPECTIVE. I'M SO BREAKING
DOWN THOSE. THOSE YEARS AND
WHAT WE'VE BEEN IT IS FINE. YOU
KNOW. REALLY CHAMPIONS DOCTOR
DEL MAR STAND. NOT SUPER.
STAMINA CITY UNIFIED HAS
INCREDIBLE AN EFFORT AS HE-
TRULY BELIEVED THIS
DEVELOPMENT. OUR FEET I FIND.
IN OUR LOCAL. UP THEN I'M DIANE.
RODRIGUEZ FROM SIMI VALLEY
COLLEGES ANOTHER KEY PARTNER.
AS WELL AS OUR WORKFORCE BOARD
MEMBERS AND OUR BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS WHO HAVE RECOGNIZE
THAT MAYBE NOT EVERY STUDENT
DREAMS OF BECOMING A COUNTY
EMPLOYEE. AND WE AS A COUNTY
ARE ALSO STRUGGLING WITH
RECRUITMENT JUST LIKE OTHER
BUSINESSES ARE IN THIS LOW
IMPLANT UNEMPLOYMENT
ENVIRONMENT THAT WE'RE IN AND
SO THE BOARD OF SUPERVISORS
MADE A COMMITMENT TIMES
THEMSELVES OF FINANCING
INTERNSHIPS THERE AT THE COUNTY
AND SO WE'RE VERY THANKFUL FOR
THEM. YOU KNOW THIS IS AN EASY
WORKING WE CONTINUE TO LEARN
ABOUT OUR PARTNERS AND THEIR
PERSPECTIVES. COMMUNICATION
REALLY IS KEY SO WE STARTED IN
A SCHOOL DISTRICT WHERE MOST OF
THE STUDENTS ARE COMING FROM.
VERY DISADVANTAGED BACKGROUNDS.
I'M GONNA SKIP SOME OF THIS IS
AN INTEREST OF TIME BUT I DO
WANT TO POINT OUT THAT ONE OF
THE KEY. INDICATORS OF SUCCESS
FOR THIS WAS TO OUR PARTNERSHIP
THE FOUNDING. FOR CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY COLLEGES. I WANT
PENSION NOT IS THAT WE- ACT
WITH THAT WHEN WHAT YOU'RE
CALLING CAREER CAP BECAUSE THEY
SAY. UP THE BIGGEST BARRIERS TO
MAKING SOME OF THE SUCCESSFUL.
THE BUSINESS IS OR HAS TO BRING
UP. TURN ESPECIALLY SCHOOL KERN
OF LIABILITY ISSUES WORKERS
COMP AND THAT'S A HEAVY BURDEN
TO CARRY PARTICULARLY FOR OUR
SMALL BUSINESSES AND WE REALLY
WANTED TO MAKE SURE THAT ARE
ARE THE STUDENTS ARE ARE BEING
PLACED WITH SMALL BUSINESSES AS
WELL AND SO BY CONTRACTING WITH
CAREER CATALYSTS. THEY ACTUALLY
CARRIED OUT THERE THE EMPLOYER
OF RECORD AND SO THAT BURDEN
HAS BEEN SHIFTED FROM THE
EMPLOYER WHO'S PARTICIPATING
OVER TO CATALYST. SO
SUSTAINABILITY CHALLENGES OR
OPPORTUNITIES AS I CALL THEM
I'M MOVING FORWARD AS I'VE SAID.
WHEN THEY WERE STILL EARLY ON
AS WHERE TEST THE SYSTEM IN AND
LEARNING FROM THEM. IT'S WORK
BUT HASN'T WORKED OUT HOLD CAN
BE MEANS WE DO FOR THAT SS TO
UNDERSTAND WHAT WHAT'S IN IT
WORK ON THEIR END UP THERE ARE
THE THING IS THAT HAVE MOUNT.
THAT. WE IN ORDER TO ROUTE MOVE
THIS FORWARD WE NEED TO BETTER
UNDERSTAND. AND SO THAT IS YOU
KNOW INDUSTRY BUYING WE JUST
NEED TO GET IN FRONT OF CUBAN
LEADER. IN A MORE DELIBERATE
AND EFFECTIVE WAY FOR THEM TO
UNDERSTAND THAT THESE AREN'T
STUDENTS COMING IN WHO. THEY
HAVE TO BABYSIT BY GIVING THEM
SOME FILING TO DO OR SOMETHING
LIKE THAT THERE THESE ARE
STUDENTS WHO THEY CAN TAKE
BLOOD PRESSURE AND THEY CAN
TAKE THE CHECK VITAL SIGNS THEY
CAN ACTUALLY INTERACT WITH.
WITH THE CUSTOMERS AND
CONSUMERS IF THAT'S WHAT THAT
BUSINESS NEEDS THEY CAN OPERATE
MACHINERY. AND SO GETTING IT'S
KIND OF A CHANGE IN MINDSET
AROUND. AROUND EMPLOYING
SOMEONE WHO MAYBE SEVENTEEN YOU
KNOW EVEN AN EIGHTEEN YEAR OLD
THEY'RE HESITANT TO BRING ON SO
CHANGING THAT MINDSET AND
ULTIMATELY. A HELPING THEM TO
UNDERSTAND THAT THIS IS THIS IS
THE WAY OF THE FUTURE IF WE'RE
GOING TO KEEP OUR OUR TALENT
LOCAL. AND REALLY THEY'RE
STRUGGLING TO FIND EMPLOYEES
YOU KNOW WE NEED TO GROW OUR
OWN SO THAT'S REALLY KEY. FIRST
INFORMACIÓN SAY WE YOU KNOW MY
DEPARTMENT WE OPERATE UNDER THE
WORKFORCE INNOVATION AND
OPPORTUNITY ACT. THAT'S HOW
WE'RE FUNDED FEDERALLY FUNDED
UNDER THAT AND WE REALIZED
EARLY ON. THAT THROUGH OUR
FUNDING WE CAN'T NECESSARILY
FUND THIS. BECAUSE WE STARTED
WITH A CITY IN THE CITY OF SAN
MARINO HAVE VERY HIGH POVERTY
MOST OF THE STUDENTS IN THE
SCHOOL DISTRICT ARE QUALIFY FOR
FREE AND REDUCED LUNCH. BUT
THEY'RE DOING SUCH AN AMAZING
JOB THAT MOST OF THOSE STUDENTS
DON'T MEET THE ADDITIONAL
BARRIERS THAT ARE REQUIRED
UNDER. WE UNDER OUR LAW BECAUSE
THEY'RE STELLAR FRANK THEIR
HIGH PERFORMING IN AND THEY'RE
DOING GREAT THINGS AND THAT'S
VERY EXCITING. BUT ALSO LIMITS
US IN OUR ABILITY TO. TO SERVE
THEM UNDER OUR UNDER OUR GRANT
FUNDING AND SO WE'RE LOOKING
FOR OTHER OPPORTUNITIES TO
EXPAND THAT BUT EVEN EVEN. IF
WE COULD OF FULLY FUND THIS IS
UNDER AN OATH WITH WE AND IT'S
STILL NOT ENOUGH YOU KNOW WE
RECOGNIZE THAT YOU KNOW. THE
WORK FOR SYSTEM IS A LOT LARGER
THAN WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT
DEPARTMENT OR THE BOARD YOU
KNOW IT REALLY IS A COLLECTIVE
EFFORT AND THAT'S GOING TO
REQUIRE. ADDITIONAL SUPPORT
FROM YOU KNOW HOPEFULLY FROM
OUR LEGISLATORS AT THE STATE
LEVEL WHO MAYBE CAN HELP.
DIRECT FUNDING INTO THIS TYPE
OF WORK BUT ALSO FROM OUR
INDUSTRIES WE'RE HOPING THAT
OUR INDUSTRIES CAN RECOGNIZE
THIS AND PUT FORWARD. SOME
FUNDING THEMSELVES TO BRING ON
THE STUDENTS. AND IT'S REALLY
YOU KNOW. ASKING EVERY MEMBER
IN THE SYSTEM TO REALLY
RETHINK. HOW WE DO BUSINESS
WE'RE DOING NOT AS A WORK FOR
SYSTEM. RECOGNIZING THAT YOU
KNOW WITH A LOW UNEMPLOYMENT WE
YOU KNOW HOW ARE WE REALLY
HELPING OUR BUSINESSES MEET
THEIR NEEDS. BECOMING MORE
RESPONSIVE. AND WE'RE HAVING
REALLY. EARLY INDICATORS THAT
POINT TO SUCCESS WITH THIS
PROGRAM SO AND I LEFT A PACKET
MADAM CHAIR FOR YOU. AND WILL
MAKE THIS AVAILABLE TO THE
PUBLIC AS WELL TO SHEET THAT
SHOWS SOME OF OUR SUCCESS. IN
EARLY ON AND SO. FROM A FROM A
JUST A BROAD PERSPECTIVE
ODYSSEY THAT HIGH SCHOOL
GRADUATION RATES FOR THESE
PARTICIPANTS IS HIGHER THAN FOR
THOSE WHO ARE NOT
PARTICIPATING. WERE SEEN LOWER
ABSENTEE RATES. LOWER RATES OF
SUSPENSION. AND ABOUT 50% OF
THE INTERNS WHO HAVE
PARTICIPATED SO FAR ARE
REMAINING IN PLAY. 86% OF THE
PARTICIPANTS HAVE CONTINUED ON
IN COLLEGE SO WE'RE SHOWING IN
REALLY GREAT SUCCESS EARLY ON
EVEN THOUGH WE'VE HAD SMALL
COHORTS IS TO BEGIN WITH. AND I
WANTED TO THIS POINT TO THIS
PHOTO THAT I HAVE UP ON THE
SCREEN HERE THIS IS LOUISE FROM
INDIAN SPRINGS HIGH SCHOOL HE
ACTUALLY JUST GRADUATED THIS
PAST YEAR. AND HE WAS GOING TO
BE HERE TODAY EIGHT TWO BECAUSE
IT REALLY MEANS MORE COME FROM
SOME. WHOSE EXPERIENCE SO HE
CAN OFFER A PUBLIC COMMENT BUT
HE TOLD ME HE THE MID TERM. AS
I SAID WELL YOU KNOW SCHOOL
FIRST I UNDERSTAND. THE NEXT
TIME. THIS IS A PHOTO OF HIM
ACTUALLY TESTIFYING BEFORE THE
SENATE BUDGET SUBCOMMITTEE THIS
PAST SESSION AS WE- HAD A
BUDGET REQUEST AND CARRIED BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER RAMOS. AND SO
HE WAS SO EXCITED AND I CAN SAY
THAT I THINK HIS TESTIMONY RANG
TRUER THAN ANY OF THE REST OF
US OUT THERE. BECAUSE HE TALKED
ABOUT THE IMPACT THIS PROGRAM
HAS HAD ON HIS LIFE HE WAS
LEARNING ABOUT MANUFACTURING
ADVANCED MANUFACTURING AND HAD
AN INTERNSHIP WITH SORENSON
ENGINEERING IN YOUR PAPER. THEY
LOVED HIM SO MUCH THEY WANTED
TO OFFER HIM A FULL TIME
POSITION AND HE TURNED IT DOWN.
BECAUSE HE WANTS TO GO AND HE
IS OUT CAL POLY POMONA STUDYING
ENGINEERING. AND SO HE'S
WORKING THERE PART TIME. AND HE
HOPES THAT YOU KNOW DO THAT
FULL TIME IN THE SUMMER.
ALTHOUGH I WILL SAY THAT HE DID
MENTION THAT YOU'RE GETTING THE
BEST OF TESTIFYING. HE'S
CONSIDERING A CHANGE OF PUBLIC
AND TO POLITICAL. EITHER WAY
RIGHT I DO TO SEE NEW THINGS
COME FROM HIM. SO WHERE WE GO.
OF THE LONG TERM HOPE FOR THIS
IS THAT WE CAN TO EXPAND THIS
PROGRAM ACROSS THE COUNTY
OTHERS THIRTY THREE SCHOOL
DISTRICTS ACROSS THE COUNTY BUT
THAT'S GONNA TAKE A LOT OF WORK
AT THE GROUND LEVEL A LOT OF
SUPPORT AND A LOT OF BY IN. AND
SO IN ORDER TO DO THIS FOR
GOING TO NEED TO ENGAGE
ADDITIONAL PARTNERS IN THIS
EFFORT WE NEED TO ENGAGE MORE
CITIES YOU KNOW IT CITIES ARE
ALSO LOOKING FOR EMPLOYEES JUST
LIKE THE COUNTY WE'RE HOPING
THAT THE BUY INTO THIS AS WELL.
AS EMPLOYERS AND ALSO TO HELP
GET OUT OF THE WORD TO THEIR TO
THEIR BUSINESSES THROUGHOUT
THEIR CITY. HOW MANY TO ENGAGE
MORE PRIVATE EMPLOYERS YOU KNOW
THROUGH CHAMBERS OF COMMERCE
WE'RE SAYS HOW WE AS WE
CONTINUE TO EXPAND WE LOOK AT
GETTING AHEAD OF. THE COVERT
READY. TO GO SOMEWHERE WE NEED
SOME SUMMER PLACE THEM IN SOBRE
TALK THE CHAMBERS. AMHERST
STREETS ASSOCIATIONS. UP AND A
CITY I MENTION. BUT I'M NOT
EIGHT WE'RE LOOKING HOPEFULLY
SECURE ADDITIONAL FUNDING. THE
MIX OF PUBLIC AND PRIVATE ON
DOLLARS TO REALLY MAKE THIS
THING EXPAND COMPLETE COUNTY
WIDE BECAUSE WE THINK IN THAT
IT CAN SERVE AS A MODEL FOR
OTHER AREAS AS WELL IT'S STILL
EARLY ON BUT WAS HE INDICATOR
SHOWING THAT IT CAN WORK. WE
JUST NEED TO GET THE RIGHT
PEOPLE AT THE TABLE AT THE
RIGHT TIME AND I THINK IT'LL BE
A SUCCESS SO I JUST WANT IS YOU
KNOW THROUGH THIS EFFORT WE ARE
REALLY RE ENVISIONING WHAT THE
FUTURE OF THIS REGION COULD
LOOK LIKE. BY CHANGING NOT ONLY
THE TRAJECTORY OF THE STUDENT'S
LIFE BUT REALLY TRANSFORMING
HER COMMUNITY. MY DISRUPTING
DECADES OF GENERATIONAL POVERTY
SO I WANTED TO THANK YOU FOR
THIS OPPORTUNITY TO SHARE OUR
EXCITING WORK AND WE LOOK
FORWARD TO CONTINUE PARTNERSHIP
ABOUT ROUND THE FUTURE WORK IN
THE INLAND EMPIRE. AND I'M
HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR YOUR
TESTIMONY TODAY AND JUST IN THE
INTEREST OF TIME WILL MOVE TO
THE NEXT SPEAKER BUT MAYBE
WE'LL DO QUESTIONS Q. NA AFTER
ALL THREE SPEAKERS. I IF WE CAN
HEAD TO OUR NEXT SPEAKER WE
LIKE TO HEAR FROM DOCTOR ELSA
MACIAS AUTHOR OF TOO BIG TO
IGNORE LATINA MICRO BUSINESS
OWNERS WHO WILL PROTECT KEY
FINDINGS. AND RECOMMENDATIONS
FROM THE REPORT SHE PREPARED
FOR. AS WE KNOW AS I MENTIONED
HE SPENT AS ORGANIZED FOR
POLITICAL EQUALITY WITH THE
BUSINESS OWNERSHIP AMONG LIKE
THE NOW ENTREPRENEURS OUTPACING
ALL OTHER BUSINESSES. BUSINESS
OWNERSHIP GROUPS UNDERSTANDING
THEIR NEEDS IS VERY VERY
IMPORTANT TO EVERY REGIONAL
ECONOMY IN CALIFORNIA. WE
PROVIDED A LEAN TO HOPE. THE
REPORT THAT IS IN THE COMMITTEE
BACKGROUND REPORT NIGHT COURAGE
EVERYONE A THIRD TIME. TO
REVIEW THAT REPORT IN THE FIND
DEAN'S DOCTOR MUSAEUS YOU CAN
BE GOTTEN. WELL THANK YOU VERY
MUCH AND GOOD MORNING TO
EVERYONE THANKS FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO ADDRESS THE
COMMITTEE AND OTHER INSERT
INTERESTED STAKEHOLDERS WHO ARE
GATHERED HERE TODAY. AT HOPE
HAS PRODUCED A SERIES OF
REPORTS ON THE ECONOMIC STATUS
LETTING US IN CALIFORNIA AND
SOME OF OUR FINDINGS ON MEDINA
BUSINESS OWNERS IN PARTICULAR
PROMPTED US. TO TAKE A CLOSER
LOOK. SO AS MADAM CHAIRMAN
YOU'VE MENTIONED THAT THE KNOWN
BUSINESSES IN CALIFORNIA HAVE
POSTED VERY IMPRESSIVE GROWTH
BETWEEN TWO THOUSAND SEVEN AND
TWO THOUSAND SIXTEEN.
INCREASING BY ABOUT FOUR
HUNDRED AND THIRTY THREE
THOUSAND FIRMS OR HUNDRED
ELEVEN CENTS. THAT'S ALSO
INDICATE NOT ONLY WITH THE
GROWTH RATE A DOUBLE WITH.
OFFER ALL UP BUSINESSES HOWEVER
FIRMS TEND TO BE SMALLER
COMPARED TO THE NATIONAL
AVERAGE RIGHT NOT INCOME START
LESS REVENUE AND MOST ARE WOMEN
OWNED BUSINESSES. OF MY
BUSINESS IS ARE DEFINED AS SOUL
FIRE SHIPS WITH MORE THAN FOUR.
IN ABOUT EIGHTY NINE CENTS. ALL
BUSINESSES ARE MICRO.
COLLECTING OUT. A BUSINESS IS A
BUSINESS WITH NO EMPLOYEE AND
IT. USE LESS THAN FIVE YEARS
OLD. SO ALL OF THE NUMBERS OF
LATINO OWNED BUSINESSES ARE
SURGING THE DESPAIR IN THE ACT
AND YOUR NEWS FROM TWIN THEM AT
OTHER DEMOGRAPHIC GROUPS ARE
SIGNIFICANT. SPECIAL WHEN YOU
COMPARE WITH OUR AVERAGE USE
FOR WHITE WOMEN BUSINESSES SO
FOR INSTANCE YOU CAN SEE THAT
THE BRIDGE I ADDED REVENUES FOR
THAT THE NOW THIS IS ONE
THOUSAND. JUST OVER FIFTY
THOUSAND WHICH WERE WERE WHITE
IT IS. IT'S TWO HUNDRED AND
TWELVE THOUSAND. SO THAT'S
QUITE A- QUITE A BIG DIFFERENCE
AND WE ARE TRYING TO FIGURE OUT
HOW TO CLOSE THAT. IN FACT LET
THE OWNED MIKE THIS IS IT IN
ASKED ME FIFTY THOUSAND DOLLARS
IN ANNUAL REVENUES. WE DO BEING
CORRECT. INDUSTRIES THAT ARE
THAT GENERATE LESS REVENUE IS
GENERALLY SO FOR EXAMPLE IN
HAIR AND NAILS THERE ALSO AS I
SAID EARLIER THERE TO TEND TO
BE NEWER AND THEN THE OFTEN
DON'T HAVE ACCESS TO THE
TYPICAL AVENUES OF BUSINESS
FINANCE SUCH AS CORPORATE
CREDIT CARDS COMMERCIAL BANKING
SERVICES AND LOANS. AND AS
WE'LL SEE THERE ARE OTHER
BARRIERS AT PLAY. SOONER IN
ORDER TO BETTER UNDERSTAND WHY
LATINOS BECOME BUSINESS OWNERS
IN THE FIRST PLACE AND HOW THEY
CAN BE BETTER SUPPORTED TO
START WRAPPING AND GROW A
BUSINESS WE CONDUCTED FOCUS
GROUPS. LIKE YEAH MIKE THIS
AUTHORS WHOSE ACTIVISTS
REVENUES ARE YOU THAT. AND WHO
HAVE NO EMPLOYEE. THESE WOMEN
THAT WE CONVENE WERE COUNT
TENSED ARTIST WHEN FORTY
THERE'S JEWELERS DESIGNERS
TRAVEL GEN PSYCHOLOGISTS DJ.
DAMAGE IN FACT THE PICTURE YOU
SEE. ARE THE GOAL SOME OF THE
ACTUAL PART DEFENSE ALTHOUGH OF
COURSE WE GRANT THEM
CONFIDENTIALITY. ALL OF THESE
WOMEN OF THOSE TO. COME FORWARD
AND I WANTED TO BE ABLE TO
SPEAK MORE PUBLICLY ABOUT THEIR
EXPERIENCES. WELL WE WEREN'T
ABLE TO HOLD A FOCUS GROUP IN
THE INLAND EMPIRE I DID
INTERVIEW SEVERAL LIKE IN A
BUSINESS OWNERS FROM THE INLAND
EMPIRE IN A PREVIOUS STUDY. AND
THEIR COMMENTS DIRECTLY
INFLUENCED THIS REPORT. I'M
GOING TO GO THROUGH THIS FAIRLY
QUICKLY BUT THE MAIN REASONS
LETTING US TOLD US THEY BECAME
BUSINESS OWNERS WAR AND- AND-
BUILDING. THEM TO DECIDE
CORRECTION BUSINESS TAKE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO IMPROVE THE
FINANCIAL SIX THIRTY. I'M WITH
ME. IN ABLE TO INTEGRATE
PERSONAL COMMUNITY VALUES WITH
THEIR BUSINESS VALUE AND THIS
ONE WAS BRILLIANT. MANY MY
MICHAEL THIS HONOR OUR FIELD
I'M NEED IN THEIR COMMUNITY AND
ADDITIONALLY THEY FEEL THIS
RESPONSIBILITY FOR PROMOTING
AND PRESERVING THEIR CULTURE SO
THAT'S USUALLY VERY MUCH PART
AND PARCEL OF THEIR BUSINESS
AND WHAT THEY'RE DOING AND
THEIR BUSINESS. MOST OF THE
WOMEN WE SPOKE WITH HOWEVER
DIDN'T. KNOW HOW TO GO ABOUT.
DOING THEIR BIT TEN ACCESSING
CAPITAL WHICH WAY THEY WERE THE
TWO GOALS FOR THEIR BUSINESSES.
OR IF THEY WERE TO OVER TO THE
DAY TO DAY. HEALTH OF KEEP
THEIR BUSINESS IS OPEN. I. THIS
IS GOING THEY'RE ALSO IN DOWN
WE A FULL TIME. OR PART TIME
JOB WHICH HAD FOR TO LEAVE
BECAUSE OF THE PARENTS BECAUSE
OF THE- ANTI. THE MONEY THAT IT
BRINGS AND- THEIR TAKE IN.
TYPICALLY PRIMARY
RESPONSIBILITY FOR CHILDCARE IF
THEY HAVE KIDS. ELDER CARE. I'M
HOUSEHOLD DUTIES AND THAT AND
THEY DIDN'T FEEL THEY HAD TIME
TO PLAN FOR STRATEGIC GROWTH TO
ACCOMPLISH THESE GOALS SO OF
TIME THAT GOAL THE GROWTH IS
HAPPENING IN A. YOU KNOW VERY
MUCH ABOUT YOU KNOW AS IT COMES
UP KIND OF A- IF YOU KNOW. THE
OPPORTUNITY SB JUMP BACK TO
FIGURE OUT MANY BY GINETTE FROM.
FROM A MONTH ON THEIR
GRANDMOTHER THEIR AUNT UNCLE
WHATEVER SO IT'S NOT VERY
STRATEGIC AND BECAUSE OF THAT
THEN THE TIME ISSUES ARE EVEN
EXACERBATED THAT WAY. OF
LETTING A BUSINESS WOMAN WE
SPOKE WITH SAID THAT THEY NEED
MORE OPPORTUNITIES TO IMPROVE
OUR BEST DEALS THEY DIDN'T KNOW
WHAT ROOMS ARE AVAILABLE HOW TO
ACQUIRE TECHNICAL TRAINING THAT
UNDERSTAND THAT THE. ACTUALLY
EVERY WOMAN AND THAT INCLUDES
EVEN OPEN THAT WE SPOKE. A
COUPLE OF OTHER WOMEN WITH
BACHELOR'S DEGREES IN PRETTY
HEAVY OTHERWISE THEY ALL ALL
FORTY FEELING. AND THEN IT
FORMED HOW TO ACCESS CAPITAL
SAMPLE BUSINESS PLANS CASH
WEBER SHINS LÀ STATEMENTS AND
THE DOCUMENTS THAT. FIVE OKAY
IT'LL. ALSO ARE MORE LIKELY TO
BUY. PARDON INSTEAD I SET UP.
ROLE IS THAT PART ON EXTRA FIND
THIS ROUTE. EVEN. EVEN WHEN THE
WORKS THESE WOMEN WHO DID KNOW
HOW THESE DOT MEN'S. OF THE
WOMEN TOLD US THAT SHE GONE TO
THE SBA WEBSITE AND WAS
OVERWHELMED AGAIN THE WOMAN
WITH THE NBA. FOR A LOT OF THE
OTHER WOMEN THEY WERE BASICALLY
YOU KNOW THEY'RE IN THE FOCUS
GROUP GIVEN THIS INFORMATION
WE'RE TRYING TO GET INFORMATION
ABOUT WHAT'S IMPORTANT TO THEM
AND HOW THEY FEEL AND THIS IS
ACTUALLY A LEARNING OPPORTUNITY
FOR THEM AS IT TURNS OUT. AND
MOST OF THESE WOMEN ADDED
ABSTAINED AFTER EACH OF THE
FOCUS GROUP BECAUSE THEY ENDED
UP LEARNING FROM THEIR PEERS
AND SOMETIMES IT WAS JUST AS A
SUPPORT GROUP AFTERWARDS JUST
NOW SHARING SOME OF THEIR
CONCERNS AND- ALL. SO WHEN THEY
DIDN'T KNOW WHERE TO FIND HELP
THEY ALSO DIDN'T HAVE THE TIME
TO TRACK ACROSS TOWN OR SIT
THROUGH A LONG WORKSHOP THAT.
THAT OFTEN DIDN'T QUITE MATCH
THEIR NEEDS. WE HEARD THAT A
LOT THAT YOU KNOW THIRD THE
THEY JUST DIDN'T HAVE A DATE TO
SPEND ON. ONE OR TWO OR THREE
SESSIONS WHERE THEY WERE
OVERWHELMED WITH INFORMATION
THAT DIDN'T QUITE FIT BUT THEY
WERE LOOKING AT OR WHERE THEIR
OWN PARTICULAR KNOWLEDGE LEVELS
WERE. ADDITIONALLY THE
EXPRESSED CONCERNS ABOUT. JUST
READ THAT I WAS A WOMAN
ADDITIONALLY THE EXPRESSED
CONCERNS ABOUT HOW LITTLE THEY
UNDERSTOOD ABOUT MARKETING AND
BRANDING HOW TO SET LONG TERM
GOALS. USING SOCIAL MEDIA AND
WHETHER TO OUT SOURCE WHEN
THEY'RE REVENUES WERE LIMITED
THEY GENERALLY. KNEW THAT THESE
WERE IMPORTANT THINGS BUT THEY
JUST REALLY DIDN'T KNOW HOW TO
ACTUALLY IMPLEMENT THEM HOW TO
CARRY THESE OUT. AND IF YOU
KNOW DO I HAVE THE MONEY I MEAN
OUTSOURCING IS VERY DIFFICULT
FOR WOMEN WHO ARE USED TO JUST
DOING EVERYTHING ON A
SHOESTRING AND DOING IT ON
THEIR OWN. AND NOW SOMEONE AND
SAY HEY HAVE YOU THOUGHT ABOUT
SENDING OUT YOUR TAXES. THERE
THE FIRST THOUGHT AS WELL I
CAN'T AFFORD THAT. AND AGAIN
EXACERBATING THE TIME
CONSTRAINTS. THING TO OUR
PARTICIPANTS BUSINESS OWNER IS
OFF LONG AND LEAN MATING AND
WOMEN ARE FOR MENTORS AND
PIERCED I'M TO HELP BUILD A
FINANCE FIRE THEM AND COUNTY I
SALUTE. I CAN'T UNDERSCORE HOW
IMPORTANT THIS ISSUE WHAT.
EVERY SINGLE WOMAN CITED IN
SOME WAY THIS ISSUE AS A PROP A
PROBLEM FOR THEM THAT EVEN WHEN
THEY ARE OUT THERE ARE GOING
DOING SOMETHING TAKING RISKS.
DOING THINGS THAT THEY NEVER
IMAGINED THEMSELVES DOING IT IS
STILL AT THE HEART VERY LONELY
AND THEY REALLY REALLY NEED OF
PEOPLE TO INSPIRE THEM ROLE
MODELS PEOPLE TO HOLD THEIR
HANDS AS THEY ARE GOING THROUGH
THIS. SO OUR PARTICIPANTS
GENERALLY EVERYONE SAID THAT AT
THAT BEING A LATINA IS A PLUS
TO THE SHARED LANGUAGE AND
CULTURE WITH THEIR CLIENTS
GIVES THEM. TRACK RETAINING
THEM. UP THAT'S THERE WERE ALSO
VERY EXPLICIT REFERENCES TO
DISCRIMINATE AN INSECT SOME
THAT THEY REGULARLY ENCOUNTER.
SO IN PRACTICE THEY FELT THAT
THEY HAVE TO WORK HARDER THAN
THE THAN MAN BUT ALSO HARDER
THAN WHITE WOMEN TO PROVE
THEMSELVES COMPETENT AS
BUSINESS WOMEN. TO GAIN THE
TRUST OF POTENTIAL CLIENTS AND
OF THE GATEKEEPERS TO COULD
OPEN DOORS TO THE RESOURCES
THAT THEY NEED. I LOOKED IN THE
BUSINESS WOMEN TOLD US THAT
THEY FACE POLICY AND REGULATORY
BARRIERS SUCH AS CITY RIGHT
CHEN SAID FEEL ARE NOT A
BUSINESS LATE. THEY ARE SELECT
BEFORE OFFICE AND RETAIL SPACE
I HAVE EXPRESSED A LOT CERTAIN
P. ABOUT TAXES FEES OTHER.
ISSUES UP INTERESTINGLY THOUGH
ALTHOUGH EVERYONE HAD CONCERN
IT WAS VERY DIFFICULT. GETTING
UP TOWARDS YOUR- ARTICULATED
MORE SPECIFIC ABOUT TAX ISN'T
USED IT WAS MORE LIKE A LIGHT
THIS IS IT WAS MORE OF THIS
THIS IS A EXTEND CONCERN AND
FEAR. MORE. THAN THE SPECIFICS
ABOUT ABOUT WHAT THEY WERE
TALKING ABOUT. SO WHY DO THESE
FINDINGS MATTER WILL CONSIDER
THAT LATINOS IN CALIFORNIA
COULD POTENTIALLY AT FIFTY TWO
THOUSAND YOU THIS IS IF THEY
CONTINUE GROWING UP RIGHT TO
HAVE BEEN. IN JANUARY TWO POINT
SEVEN BILLION FOR THE STATE'S
ECONOMY. AND IF EVERYTHING
ABOUT MICHAEL BUSINESS OWNER
COULD EMPLOY JUST ONE PERSON OR
JUST ONE PERSON. GOOD CREW
THREE HUNDRED FORTY THOUSAND
NEW JOBS. QUITE A. QUITE
ACCOMPLISHMENTS WITH JUST A
LITTLE BIT MORE SUPPORT. IT'S A
BASED ON OUR FINDINGS WE
DEVELOP SOME POLICY
RECOMMENDATIONS TO HELP LET THE
AS START RUNNING BROKE
BUSINESSES. I'M IN OVER SEVEN
LOOTED THESE WOMEN TOLD THAT
THEY NEED STEP BY STEP GUIDE.
THAT'S IF POSSIBLE MAN WHOSE
FIGURATIVELY HOLDING HANDS
REACH STEP. UGH THERE IS A
GREATER NEED FOR INDIVIDUALIZED
ASSISTANCE RATHER THAN WORK AND
SEVEN. TOO MUCH PUBLIC POLICY
CAN BE BEAR CAN BE BATES AND
SCALABILITY FOR COST MEASURE IS
INDIVIDUALS WHO NEED THE HELP
THROUGH ONE ON ONE THING WITH
THIS IS THAT. BUSINESS OWNER AT
THEIR LEVEL. IT'S LESS
EFFICIENT IT'S MORE CUMBERSOME
AND CERTAINLY MORE EXPENSE.
SHIPS WITHIN OVER TO THE
SCHOOLS AT THE IN A SERVING
COMMUNITY ORGANIZATIONS WOULD
HELP I THINK BUSINESS SKILLS
AND I'M PREPARED PAUL PFEIFFER
LÀ THEY NEED. AND FINALLY
WITHOUT BETTER DATA IT'S
DIFFICULT TO MAKE BETTER POLICY
DECISIONS. OF ACCURATE BUSINESS
DATA THAT IS GRANULAR ENOUGH
IT'S HARD TO COME BY. A NEW
SURVEY FROM THE US CENSUS
BUREAU IS COMING OUT AND- IT'S
IN THE FIELD NOW AND PROMISES
TO PROVIDE DATA ON MICRO
BUSINESSES SPECIFICALLY. PRIOR
PREVIOUSLY I OF THE SAID AT
THIS POINT IT'S BURIED THERE
ARE YOU HAVE A VERY DIFFERENT
VERY COMPLICATED. CALCULATIONS
TO FIGURE OUT THE NUMBERS AND
PERCENTAGES OF MICRO BUSINESSES
AND IT'S JUST NOT GRANULAR IF
YOU JUST WANT TO LOOK AT THE
NOW. LET THE IN A MICRO
BUSINESS OWNERS YOU JUST CAN'T
GET A VERY GOOD FIGURE FOR THAT
IN IN MANY AREAS. SO IT'S AND
IT'S- ALSO UNCLEAR HOW IT'S
GOING TO WILL IT WHETHER IT
WILL ALLOW US TO UNDERSTAND THE
NEEDS OF THAT IN THIS AND OTHER
WOMEN IN BUSINESS. AND THAT
DATA WON'T INCLUDE THE
QUALITATIVE THE QUALITATIVELY
RICH TYPE OF INFORMATION THAT
HELPS GIVE A FULLER PICTURE OF
THE ISSUES THAT THESE WOMEN ARE
FACING. SO LET ME KNOW
ENTERPRENEURS HAVE ALREADY BEEN
ROBUSTLY CONTRIBUTING TO THE
INLAND EMPIRE CON. SUPPORTED
BUT THE NIGHT MICHAEL BIZ OWNER
IS ALL THE GOOD FOR THE REGION
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR HELP FOR
ME WITH YOU CAN ACCESS THE ROOM
THE REPORT AT THE NEST ORDER.
MEDINA MICRO IS AND FOR MORE
INFORMATION YOU CAN REACH
EITHER MYSELF OR MY UNCLE
MYSELF GOT THESE HAPPY TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS THAT YOU
MAY HAVE. THANK YOU DOCTOR
MUSAEUS AND AGAIN JUST TO NOTE
THE INDIVIDUAL WHO IS GOING TO
BE DISCUSSING HOME BASED
BUSINESSES I WAS NOT ABLE TO
JOIN US TODAY BUT HOPEFULLY WE
CAN HAVE A FOLLOW UP DISCUSSION
ON THAT. I'D I WILL MOVE ON TO
OUR FINAL SPEAKER BEFORE Q. NA
BEGAN SIN THAT IS MATTHEW
HORTON ARE WHO WE WORK VERY
CLOSELY WITH WE HE WILL BE
PRESENTING. FROM THE MILKEN
INSTITUTE ON CD NOT REGIONAL
COMPETITIVENESS AND BUILDING
INNOVATIVE ECOSYSTEMS I BELIEVE
THIS IS VERY EXCITING RESEARCH
WHICH IS ALREADY IGNITING
UPWARD MOBILITY ACTIVITIES IN
THE INLAND EMPIRE MISTER HORTON
WHEN YOU ARE READY TO BEGIN
PLEASE DO. WELL THANK YOU SO
MUCH MADAM CHAIR AND A IT'S AN
HONOR TO BE HERE AND THANKS FOR
CONVENING SUCH A IMPORTANT
CONVERSATION. IT'S A IT'S LIKE
I SAID IT'S AN ARE TO BE HERE
AND TALK A BIT ABOUT THE MILK
THIS TO WORK AND HOW IT RELATES
TO THIS TOPIC WOULD HELP THIS
TO FOR EVERYBODY WHO MAY NOT BE
AWARE IS. A NONPARTISAN
NONPROFIT AT FAULT THANK THANK.
THE FOR INDIVIDUALS. TO OF OUR
PRIMARY RESEARCH DOCUMENTS THAT
WE DO ANNUALLY AND BI ANNUALLY.
ARE GOOD INDICATIONS OF WHERE
WE CAN BE MORE INTENTIONAL
AROUND HUMAN CAPITAL
INVESTMENTS. ONE ON THE OUTPUT
SIDE IS OUR BEST FOR ME CITIES
METRICS. WHICH TAKES GET SOME
THE GROUP IF I'M- WAGES AND HI
TO DOCTOR A G. PEAS. THROUGHOUT
THE AGENTS OF THE COUNTRY AND
IT WAS OF HOW IT LOOKS LIKE FOR
CALIFORNIA. WE SEE A NUMBER OF
OUR CITIES RANKING PRETTY HIGH.
ALTHOUGH. A LOT OF THOSE CITIES
TEND TO BE MORE NOR. BUS AND
READ ONLY WE'VE SEEN. OF THE
RIVER SIDE MEMBERS AREA START
TO SPORT. THIS METRIC WHICH
WILL SEE IN A FEW MINUTES BY
LOOKING AT SOME OF THE HIGHER
PERFORMERS AND HOW THEY'RE ABLE
TO LEVERAGE LOCAL AND REGION
ASSETS IN THIS SENSE. IT IS NO
SURPRISE US ABOUT EIGHT WITH
THEIR TAX YOUR ENDEAVOR FIVE HI
TECH ARE. OPPORTUNITIES IN THE
AREA OUR STATE WILL GENERATE A
NEW OPPORTUNITIES THROUGH
INNOVATION AND FURTHER
INVESTMENT YOU KNOW FOR THE
SUSTAIN ENTREPRENEURIAL CULTURE
FOR NOT JUST START UPS BUT
OTHER OTHER BUSINESSES SMALL
BUSINESSES IN THE AREA FOR
RIVERSIDE AND SAN BERNARDINO
WHAT WE'RE SEEING IS. OUR
ABILITY AS DR ROMER CHRISTIANS
DATA WE POINTED TO EARLIER THIS
THE LOOK. SIX PUB IS BASIS
INNING AND PROMOTER. BUSINESS
AT AND INNOVATION GROWTH IN THE
AREA. WITH OUR PROXIMITY TO.
MAJOR ONE IS SET. SOME OF THE
INDICATIONS THERE ARE TO WORRY
ABOUT ARE ARE ARE ASSOCIATED
WITH GROWING COST OF LIVING
CONCERNS AND THE DISCONNECTED
IN TERMS OF ECONOMIC VIABILITY
THAT WERE SEEN BEING LEFT OUT
ON THE INPUT SIDE WE TAKE A
LOOK AT THE STATE TECH AND ON
SCIENCE INDEX. AND HOW THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA OVER
PERFORMING IN TERMS OF ITS IN
ITS IN HUMAN CAP. HIGHER
PATIENTS SYSTEMS AND OTHER
EDUCATION OPPORTUNITIES AND WE
TEND TO SCORE OR OR OR RANK
PRETTY HIGH HERE BUT IT IT KIND
OF BE LIES THE INDICATIONS THAT
YOU KNOW A LOT OF PEOPLE ARE
FINDING CALIFORNIA. IN TERMS OF
COST OF LIVING UNTENABLE AND
THOSE WHO CAN ARE. WHILE THOSE
WHO ARE COMING IN TEND TO LOOK.
UP THE- FOR IT'S OR
PROFESSIONAL DEGREES UP
PROBABLY IN THE ASSOCIATED WITH
SOME OF THE TECH CENTERS THAT
WE START IN THE EARLIER SLIDE
AGAIN JUST A SOME OF THE
MIGRATION NUMBERS TO AND FROM
CALIFORNIA. AND AGAIN OUR
PERFORMANCE IN OUR BELIEVE HIS
SEED REGIONAL INNOVATIONS AND
TALENT HUBS ARE SO SHE WAS SOME
OF THE JOBS THAT OFFER INCREASE
IN GROWTH IN DEMAND. IS PIVOTAL
IN TERMS OF OUR ABILITY TO BE
AT A REGIONAL. THE OVERALL
CAPITAL INTO THIS FROM AN
INVESTMENT STANDPOINT SHOWS HOW
LIKE IN COMPARISON TO SOME
STATES I'M AND WHERE WE HAVE
ROOM FOR GROWTH AND WHAT REALLY
THAT INVESTMENT SHOULD LOOK
LIKE FROM A TECHNOLOGY AND
SCIENCE WORKFORCE. AND WHAT
THAT MEANS I'M UP AND INNOVATE
FIVE ALSO WE LOOK AT THAT. LEFT
GREEN ARROW AND HOW IT
TRANSITIONS INTO THAT BLUE AERO
THAT IT'S REALLY THE SOME OF
THE KEY AREAS THAT RECEIVE OR
STATE AND LOCAL OUR IN OUR FUND
INDEED. OUR IDEAS TRADITION
ROLE OR WAS A TRADITIONAL ROLE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT IN TERMS OF.
SPENDING AND IT WAS WE NOTED
ARE IN THE. AROUND SOME OF OUR
KEY ASSETS EDUCATION IS THIS
REALLY WHAT A LOT OF. ENERGY IF
YOU WILL THAT KEEPS OF REGIONAL
INNOVATION ECOSYSTEM VIBRANT
GROWING. I'M HOW THAT
TRANSLATES INTO TECH TRANSFER
AND FURTHER PROVISION WAS UP
REALLY CAPTURED IN A IN A
TECHNOLOGY THE OR CONCEPT
COMMERCIALIZATION REPORT DID IN
TWENTY SEVENTEEN THERE'S A
REASON THAT YOU SEE ARE AND
SOME OF OUR OTHER AND EDUCATION
TO SHINS COULDN'T BE IN THIS OF
RANKING INDEX WITHOUT WITH WITH
THE RIGHT INVESTMENTS AND
LEADERSHIP. AND ON THE OPPOSITE
SIDE OF THAT PRIVATE PENDING
I'M PRIVATE INVESTMENT.
DISTRIBUTION PROCESS STATE THE
TEND TO LOOK AT HOW THE STATE
BE MORE INTENSE WINTER OF
BRIDGING THAT DIVIDE FOR HOLES
AREN'T THE SPENDING. AND
LOOKING TO BE MORE PLACED.
AROUND SOMEWHERE EDUCATION IS
TO. I'M AND IN TERMS OF WHAT
THIS LOOKS LIKE SOME SOME KEY
STEPS NEXT UP FOR CONSIDERATION.
AS WE GET YOU KNOW INTO THE
NEXT LEGISLATIVE CYCLE IN ON.
TESTING WHERE INVESTMENTS CAN
BE. GROW AND OR OR OR MORE
INTENT ALL AROUND ARE IN THE
REGIONAL PARTNERSHIP ASPECT IT
IS A KEY YOU'RE AN AT AND
COMMUNITIES AND LEADERS ARE
COMING TOGETHER TO TAKE A LOOK
AT ASSETS AND DEVELOP
PARTNERSHIPS THAT THAT OUR
INTENTIONAL AROUND REGIONAL
INNOVATION. AND THE PLACE BASED
INVESTMENTS AROUND LOWERING
COSTS SO NOT JUST ACCESS TO
EDUCATION AND STEM
OPPORTUNITIES BUT MOBILITY AND
HOUSING OPPORTUNITIES AND AT
THE DISCRETION OF THE COMMITTEE
I'D LIKE TO INVITE SOME OF OUR
COLLABORATORS THAT ARE ARE
REALLY PROPELLING THESE
REGIONAL INNOVATION
COLLABORATIONS FORWARD AND AT A
LATER DATE WE CAN TALK MORE
ABOUT. HOW THIS LOOKS LIKE IN
TERMS OF THE FUTURE OF WORK BUT
IF TIME PERMITTING AND AS A
FUNCTION PUBLIC COMMENT I'D
LIKE. TO INVITE THEM TO GIVE A
FEW REMARKS. THANK YOU MATT.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR MY NAME
IS FRED WELTY. FOR A PERIOD OF
SIX YEARS I WAS THE FOUNDING
CEO THE LOS ANGELES CLEAN TECH
AND. IN IT LED THE CITY OF LOS
ANGELES EFFORTS. TO BUILD AN
INNOVATION HUB FOCUS ON CLEAN
TECHNOLOGY. WE BUILD IT FROM A
GARAGE. ONE FIFTH THE SIZE OF
THIS ROOM INTO A WORLD CLASS
WORLD RENOWNED INNOVATION
CENTER THAT TO DAY HAS
DELIVERED JUST ABOUT SIX
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS OF LONG
TERM ECONOMIC VALUE FOR THE
CITY OF LOS ANGELES. TODAY I AM
THE CEO OF THE NETWORK FOR
GLOBAL INNOVATION A NONPROFIT
THAT WHOSE MISSION IS TO DO
EXACTLY WHAT WE DID IN LA FOR
COMMUNITIES AROUND THE WORLD.
IN JUNE OF THIS YEAR OUR
ORGANIZATION WAS HIRED BY THE
RUSSIAN. A RIVERSIDE COUNCIL OF
GOVERNMENTS. TO HELP CREATE.
AND THEN IMPLEMENT A ROAD MAP.
FOR CREATING A- INNOVATION
DRIVEN ECONOMY ACROSS THIS AREA.
WE HAVE A WE ARE IN THE EARLY
STAGES OF THIS WORK WE SPENT
THE LAST FOUR YEARS FOUR MONTHS
NOT IF IT SOMETIMES IT'S FELT
LIKE FOUR YEARS MAINLY FOR
MUCH. OF TRYING TO UNDERSTAND
WHAT'S GOING ON WE'VE MET WITH
OVER FIFTY OF DIFFERENT
ORGANIZATIONS INCLUDING YOUR
STAFF. IN I'D LIKE TO SHARE
FIVE MUCH OF A COUPLE OF OUR
KEY FINDINGS AND WITH THE
IMPLICATIONS THOSE FINDINGS
HALF FOR. OF THE FUTURE OF THIS
AREA. I LIKE. MATIN CARDIGAN
RUSH TO THE FOLKS OF SAID THERE
ARE A LOT OF REALLY GOOD THINGS
HAPPENING A LOT OF REALLY GREAT
INNOVATION PROGRAMS GOING ON. A
LOT OF ACTIVITY. ALL THE REGION
HAS ENJOYED. QUITE A BIT OF
ECONOMIC SUCCESS. YET IT IS
PRETTY MUCH UNKNOWN. OUTSIDE I
MEAN IT THE INLAND EMPIRE IS
KNOWN FOR CONGESTION AND SMOG
IN TRAFFIC NOT INNOVATION. AND
THAT IS A HURDLE IN ATTRACTING
INNOVATORS TO THIS REGION. BUT
I'LL TELL YOU WHAT THE BIGGEST
FINDING WAS IT'S LIKE A. A
TRAIN COMING DOWN THE TRACK
HEADING RIGHT AT US AND IT THIS
TRAIN IS GOING TO ARRIVE HERE
JUST AS CERTAINLY AS METRO
TRAINS ARRIVE IN UNION STATION.
AND THAT TRAINS COLD AUTOMATION.
A OF PROFESSOR PROFESSOR MONEY
IS FROM WRESTLING UNIVERSITY
HAS DONE A REALLY TERRIFIC.
PIECE OF RESEARCH THAT PAINTS
IN VERY STARK TERMS WHAT'S IN
STORE FOR THIS REGION UNLESS WE
DO SOMETHING. AND HIS FINDINGS
INDICATE THAT 63% OF ALL JOBS
CURRENTLY IN THIS REGION ARE
VULNERABLE TO AUTOMATION. IN
THE NEXT TEN TWENTY YEARS. AND
THAT WOULD MAKE THAT MAKES THIS
REGION THE FOURTH MOST
VULNERABLE REGION IN THE
COUNTRY. FOR AUTOMATION. WHAT
THAT MEANS IS TODAY THERE ARE
ROUGHLY NINETY THOUSAND
UNEMPLOYED FOLKS IN IN MULLIN
EMPIRE. THAT WOULD GO TO ONE
POINT TWO MILLION. WHEN TEN TO
TWENTY YEARS THAT IS IN MY
ESTIMATION THE SCARIEST THING
I'VE COME ACROSS IN IN MY TIME
IN TRYING TO BUILD INNOVATION
SYSTEMS. SO OUR CONCLUSION IS
THAT WE NEED A PLAN B. WE NEED
A STRATEGY TO DEVELOP AND
INNOVATION DRIVEN ECONOMY THAT
OVER A PERIOD. TAKE PLACE AND
REPLACE THE JOBS THAT WE ARE
GOING TO LOSE THAT WE ARE
LOSING NOW WE ALL KNOW THAT WE
SEE THAT EVERY DAY. WE HAVE A
PLAN TO DO THAT. THAT PLAN IS
CALLED INNOVATION TWENTY THIRTY.
IT'S A PLAN IT'S NOT THAT THAT
IS BUILT ON TAKING AND BUILDING
INNOVATION HUBS ACROSS THIS
REGION. NEEDING THEM TOGETHER
GETTING THEM TO WORK TOGETHER
TO SHARE RESOURCES THE SHARE
CUSTOMERS SURE INVESTMENTS YOU
SHARE OPPORTUNITIES TO SHARE
BEST PRACTICES. AND TO PUT THAT
IN PLACE TO BUILD AN ECONOMY
THAT'S BASED ON INNOVATION THAT
WILL OUTLAST AND GET AHEAD OF
THIS AND COMING PROBLEM. WE
SHARE THAT PLAN WITH OVER FIFTY
ORGANIZATIONS AS I MENTIONED.
AND WITHOUT EXCEPTION. ALL
FIFTY THOSE ORGANIZATIONS HAVE
HAVE EMBRACED ARE PLANT
INFORMALLY OF COURSE. WHY.
BECAUSE IT IS THE FIRST PLAN
BUT NOT ONLY RECOGNIZES THE
ELEPHANT THAT'S IN THE ROOM
AUTOMATION AND HAS A VERY
SPECIFIC PLAN OF ACTION TO
ADDRESS THAT THAT IS REGION
WIDE AND I BELIEVE. IT WILL.
BENEFIT. EVERY SINGLE PERSON IN
THIS REGION FROM OF COURSE THE
ENTREPRENEURS TO CREATE THE
COMPANIES TO THE ACADEMIC
INSTITUTIONS THAT THAT HELP
TRAIN RETRAIN OF SKILL THE
TALENT FOR THOSE. COMPANIES TO
THE COMMUNITIES IN CITIES THAT
WILL BENEFIT FROM INCREASED
TAXES FROM THOSE EFFORTS SO
THAT WE BELIEVE LONG TERM DEBT
IT'S ABSOLUTELY CRITICAL TO
DEVELOP A NEW WAY OF DEVELOPING
A INNOVATION DRIVEN ECONOMY AND
THAT'S WHAT WE- INTEND TO DO.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME THANK
YOU FOR IT FOR SHARING. WE ALSO
HAVE CHRIS WITH THE STUDENT.
GOOD MORNING MEMBERS THE
COMMITTEE MY NAME IS CHRIS
GRAHAM THE DIRECTOR OF PLANNING
AND TRANSPORTATION FOR THE WEST
RIVERSIDE COUNCIL GOVERNMENTS
ARE WE'RE A REGIONAL AGENCY
THAT REPRESENTS ALL THE CITIES
IN WESTERN RIVERSIDE COUNTY AND
RIVERSIDE COUNTY A NUMBER OF
OTHER INSTITUTIONS I'M HERE
TODAY TO TELL YOU WHY WE CHOSE
TO INVEST. SOME OF OUR
RESOURCES INTO THE WORK AT FRED
IS DOING AND WHAT IS SIMPLY
COMES DOWN TO IS FOR THE PAST
TWENTY THIRTY YEARS WE'VE HAD
THE SAME PATTERN OF ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT AND WESTERNERS I
COUNTY WHICH IS THERE ARE HIGH
PAYING HIGH SKILL JOBS IN THE
COAST LOW PAYING LOW SKILL JOBS
HERE AND EVERY DAY THERE ARE
HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS OF PEOPLE
WHO GET IN THEIR CARS SOME OF
WHOM WERE LEAVING AT FOUR FIVE
IN THE MORNING. THEY'RE DRIVING
IN TRAFFIC TO GET TO ORANGE
COUNTY SAN DIEGO AND LA AND
THEY ARE COMING HOME AT THE END
OF THE DAY I PERSONALLY DO THAT
DRIVE FOR OVER TEN YEARS BEFORE
I RELOCATED MY WORK TO
RIVERSIDE AND I CAN TELL YOU
IT'S A SOUL CRUSHING
EXPERIENCE. AND PEOPLE ARE
DOING THAT BECAUSE IT'S FUN
THEY'RE NOT DOING IT BECAUSE
THEY CAN LISTEN TO PODCASTS ARE
DOING IT BECAUSE THOSE JOBS ARE
THERE AND THE JOBS THEY NEED TO
SUPPORT THEIR FAMILIES ARE IN
THOSE COASTAL REGIONS AND I
WOULD SAY THAT THIS HAS
HAPPENED FOR DECADES WE
COMMISSIONED A STUDY LOOKING
CUTE PATTERNS. WE FOUND THAT
THE PERCENTAGE OF PEOPLE IN TWO
THOUSAND AND WHO DROVE. THE
COUNTY FOR WORK IS THE SAME AS
TODAY AND WE'VE SPENT BILLIONS
OF DOLLARS AS A REGION
INVESTING IN FREEWAYS INVESTING
IN TRANSPORTATION
INFRASTRUCTURE THAT DOES WHAT
IT BASICALLY GETS PEOPLE TO
LEAVE THE COUNTY FOR THEIR WORK
SO THEREFORE WE THINK WE NEED
TO GO IN A DIFFERENT DIRECTION
AND WITH THE HELP OF EXPERTS
LIKE FRED PEOPLE LIKE MATT AND
OTHER KEY STAKEHOLDERS AROUND
THE REGION. WE REALLY EMBRACE
THIS IDEA OF WHAT WE CALL IT A
NATION BECAUSE AND THE IDEAS
THAT WE WANT TO CREATE
OPPORTUNITIES FOR PEOPLE WHO
ARE LOCAL OUT FOR NUMBERS LOCAL
BUSINESS OWNERS. AND PEOPLE WHO
WHO WANT TO START A BUSINESS
BUT MAYBE. OUR SYSTEM. GET IT
GOING AND THEN DEVELOP WHERE
THE PROCESS OF DEVELOPING A
PUBLIC PRIVATE PARTNERSHIP. BUT
WHAT IT REALLY NEEDS IS SOME
LEVEL OF STATE ASSISTANCE AND
WE BELIEVE THAT A MODEST
INVESTMENT STATE RESOURCES. IN
COMPARISON TO THE BILLIONS OF
DOLLARS THAT ARE BEING VESTED
IN TRANSPORTATION OTHER. AREAS
CAN REALLY JUMP START THE
INNOVATION ECOSYSTEM AND CREATE
OPPORTUNITIES FOR ALL OF THESE
PEOPLE WHO ARE HAVING TO LEAVE
THE COUNTY ON A DAILY BASIS. TO
WORK I WANTED TO THANK YOU FOR
THE OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK TO
THIS IS ADDITION TO WERE VERY
EXCITED ABOUT. AND IT'S
SOMETHING THAT DEBORAH KERR
WILL BE IN OF SPENDING A LOT OF
OUR TIME AND RESOURCES OVER THE
NEXT SEVERAL YEARS AND THANK
YOU AGAIN FOR THE OPPORTUNITY.
NOT RECKON IT BACK OFF TO YOU
TO CLOSE. THIS SEGMENT. I
REALLY APPRECIATE THE EXTENSION
OF DISCRETION THERE AND THANK
YOU FOR. ALLOWING US TO PRESENT
TODAY BUT THAT THAT THAT I'M
I'M DONE WITH CONTENT AND I'M
TRYING TO LOOK SMART FOR TODAY.
THANK YOU MATT SO WHAT WE'LL DO
IS OUT IN A MOMENT WE'RE
ACTUALLY GONNA MOVE TO PUBLIC
COMMENTS AND AGAIN IF YOU WOULD
LIKE TO SPEAK. ARE WE ASK THAT
EACH PUBLIC COMMENT BE LIMITED
TO THREE MINUTES MORE EXTENDED
COMMENTS SHOULD BE PROVIDED IN
WRITING. AT NEW DO HAVE UP
UNTIL OCTOBER THIRTIETH TO
SUBMIT YOUR COMMENTS IN WRITING
TO THE JOBS COMMITTEE. I DO
WANT TO JUST ASK A COUPLE
QUESTIONS SURE SPEAKERS BEFORE
WE MOVED TO PUBLIC COMMENT. I
AM ONE OF THEM BEING. IN THIS
COULD ANYONE COULD ANSWER THIS.
HOW CAN WE MAYBE PERHAPS LOOK
AT REGULATORY REQUIREMENTS ARE
THAT SUPPORT ENTREPRENEURSHIP
AND INNOVATION WITHIN THE
INLAND EMPIRE WORKING THE STATE
DO WHEN IT COMES TO TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE I KNOW THAT THERE
WAS A CHALLENGE WITH MAYBE
NAVIGATING THE SBA WEBSITE YOU
KNOW THINKING ABOUT HE COMMERCE
I JUST ANY TYPE OF MODIFICATION
OF OUR OUR REGULATORY
REQUIREMENTS TO SUPPORT A MORE.
UPWARD MOBILITY AND
ENTREPRENEURSHIP. ANY THOUGHTS.
TO US YES SOME I WOULD I WOULD
POINT BACK TO THAT ALREADY
INVESTMENT MAP AND TRYING TO
FIGURE OUT HOW TO LEVERAGE
STATE OR OR HOW WE CAN BETTER
LEVERAGE STATE INCENTIVES THAT
LIKE CALIFORNIA COMPETES OR OR
OTHER SIMILAR STYLE INCENTIVES
OR OR EVEN JUST OVER A PUBLIC
SPENDING ON ARE IN THE AS A
CATALYST FOR. REGIONAL
INNOVATION GROWTH. AND GET A
COMPETITIVENESS. AND WE HAVE
DONE SOME WORK AROUND
CALIFORNIA COMPETES OUT OVER
THE LAST SEVERAL SESSIONS WHAT
GOING BACK TO MISS WILSHIRE YOU
HAD MENTIONED THE- INDUSTRY
PRIVATE INDUSTRY THE BUY IN
FROM THE PRIVATE INDUSTRY HOW
DO YOU START WITH THAT
ENGAGEMENT BECAUSE I KNOW THAT
THERE MAY BE OTHER FOLKS IN THE
ROOM WHO JUST LEARNED ABOUT.
GENERATION GO AND- UPS MAY BE
CURIOUS WHAT IS WHAT DOES THAT
LOOK LIKE WHEN YOU FIRST REACH
OUT WHAT IS THE BEST METHOD OF
REACHING OUT TO THE PRIVATE
INDUSTRY. QUESTION THANK YOU SO
MUCH FOR THIS OPPORTUNITY SO WE
ARE DEPARTMENT HAS A WHAT WE
CALL REFER TO OUR BUSINESS
SERVICES TEAM AND THERE REALLY
ARE BOOTS ON THE GROUND FROM
OUR ADDITIONAL INITIAL POINT OF
CONTACT WITH OUR BUSINESSES. OF
WHAT WE REALIZE THOUGH IS THAT
SHE'S THE TEAM OF EIGHT OR SO
AND THIS IS A VERY LARGE COUNTY
AND SO RECOGNIZING WE REALLY
NEED TO LEVERAGE OTHER
PARTNERSHIPS IN ORDER TO GET IT
OUR FOOT IN THE DOOR TO THE
RIGHT. PEOPLE AND SO WHAT WE'VE
BEEN DOING IS TO MAKE IT OUR
OUR BUSINESS OUR BOARD MEMBERS
WHO ARE PRIVATE BUSINESS OWNERS
THEMSELVES. AND REALLY GET OUR
AN OPPORTUNITY TO PRESENT
BEFORE INDUSTRY ASSOCIATION BMA
OR CHAMBERS OF COMMERCE WE'VE
BEEN PRESENTING AS WE GET READY
TO LAUNCH AN AREA WE SET THE
STAGE BY FIRST GOING ON HIM AND
PRESENTING BEFORE. MEMBERS
ALREADY WHAT WE REALIZE IS THAT
THERE ARE ONLY SO MANY OF US
AND THERE ARE A LOT OF
BUSINESSES HERE TO KNOCK ON
THEIR DOOR AND SO. TRYING TO
MEET THEM WHERE THEY ALREADY
ARE IS THAT ONE OF OUR KEY
STRATEGIES BUT REALLY FOCUSING
ON ARE ARE CHAMPIONS OF THIS
EARLY ADOPTERS THOSE BUSINESSES
WHO HAVE ALREADY BOUGHT IN. AND
HAVING THEM TELL THE STORY IT'S
OF MUCH MORE MEANINGFUL THE
RATHER THAN IT COMING FROM
SOMETIMES IF YOU IS A
BUREAUCRAT KNOCKING ON THEIR
DOOR. IF IT'S A SOMEBODY WHO'S
IN OUR INDUSTRY WHO WHO
UNDERSTANDS THEIR NEEDS AND THE
DIFFICULTIES THAT MAY COME WITH
BRING IT ON THIS TYPE OF IN A
PROGRAM INTO THEIR INTO THEIR
BUSINESS. I'M HERE DIRECTLY
FROM THEM HAS HAD MUCH MORE
IMPACT. IT WAS A PLEASURE TO BE
LOW IS TO GO ON THE TWO FOUR
AND TO SEE HIS ADVOCACY IN
SACRAMENTO. I AND IN THE LAST
QUESTION I HAVE FOR THE ENTIRE
PANEL IS HOW CAN THE AYE EE.
REALLY LEVERAGE THE ADVANTAGES
OFFERED BY OUR DIVERSE
POPULATIONS ACROSS OUR REGION.
I'D LIKE TO JUST SAY. THERE'S
SO MUCH FOCUS ON SMALL BUSINESS
AND IT'S YOU KNOW CERTAINLY
APPROPRIATE BUT- A LOT OF OUR
RESEARCH SHOWS THAT THERE ARE
SO MANY MORE MICRO BUSINESSES
JUST IN TERMS OF SHEER NUMBER
AND IT'S INTERESTING IN MY
RESEARCH THAT THERE ARE A LOT
MORE FEWER RESOURCES THAT ARE
DEVOTED. SPECIFICALLY FOR MICRO
BUSINESSES AND INSTEAD OF FOR
SMALL BUSINESSES SO YOU KNOW IT
IT WOULD BE INTERESTING AND BE
NICE TO BE ABLE TO HAVE MORE
RESOURCES THAT ARE DEVOTED
SPECIFICALLY TO UNDERSTANDING
HOW MICRO BUSINESSES CAN
FLOURISH AND HOW THE NEWS CAN
GET THE RESOURCES THAT THEY
NEED TO BECOME MICRO BUSINESS
OWNERS. SO IN THAT I THINK THAT
WOULD BE ONE WAY IN WHICH WE
CAN SUPPORT THE KIND OF.
DEMOGRAPHICS THAT WE SEE HERE
IN THE INLAND EMPIRE. THANK YOU
DOCTOR MERCY IS AND I WAS JUST
WE'RE JUST CHATTING WITH MY
CHIEF CONSULTANT WE HAVE HAD
DISCUSSIONS ON MICRO BUSINESS
OWNERS IN SACRAMENTO AND HAVE I
MET WITH AN ORGANIZATION CAMEO
THAT I. WILL WE WERE INVOLVED
WITH EARLIER THIS YEAR OR
TOWARD THE END OF THIS YEAR
THIS SECTION BUT LOOK FOR TO
SEE AN ENGAGING PERHAPS WE CAN
HAVE A SEPARATE CONVERSATION.
TO SEE WHAT ELSE WE CAN DO FOR
A PRO BUSINESS CENTERS ACROSS
THE STATE THANK YOU. WHAT
WITHOUT I WANTED JUST THANK
EACH OF OUR PANEL I KNOW THAT
YOU KNOW YOUR TIME IS VALUE
DID. THE WORK THAT YOU DO IS A
WHILE I THANK YOU FOR YOUR YOUR
COMMITMENT TO OUR REGION AND
MAKING SURE THAT. WE ARE GOING
TO UPLIFT EVERY COMMUNITY I IN
CALIFORNIA BUT LOOKING AT THOSE
WHO ARE JUST FALLING FURTHER
BEHIND IS WHAT WE'RE LOOKING
AT. I'M SORRY PRESHEAF YOUR
ATTENTION TO THIS MATTER IN
YOUR COMMITMENT TO THE ISSUE.
NEXT ITEM WE CAN GO AHEAD AND
OPEN IT UP TO PUBLIC COMMENTS
AND THE FIRST INDIVIDUAL LIKE
TO BRING UP IS LOOSE GUIDE.
MOOSE IS WITH THAT
. GOOD
MORNING I HAVE TO START THANK
YOU ASSEMBLY WOMAN AND SABRINA
CERVANTES FOR ON FOR YOUR WORDS
EARLIER I REALLY APPRECIATE
THAT THAT THERE HAS TO BE
COMMUNITY ENGAGEMENT AND THAT A
CAT HAS TO BE FROM THE GROUND
UP IT HAS TO COME FROM THE
GRASSROOTS AS WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT WHAT'S HAPPENING OR STATE
THAT IT CAN BE A TOP DOWN
APPROACH. I'M HERE I'M
REPRESENTING THOUGHT THEY BUT
ALSO ARE A WE ARE A MEMBERSHIP
BASED ORGANIZATION IN THE
INLAND EMPIRE I'M NOT ONLY
SERVING RIVERSIDE SABATINO BUT
ALSO IMPERIAL COUNTIES AND AS
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT BE SPACES
IT'S VERY IMPORTANT THAT WE
CONTINUE ON BRINGING IN OUR
GRASSROOTS COMMUNITY OF BEING
IN THE GRASSROOTS GIVES US A
FEELING POLLS OF WHAT'S
ACTUALLY HAPPENING ON THE
GROUND. AND AS WE CONTINUE THIS
CONVERSATION TO KEEP ON MOVING
CALIFORNIA FORWARD THESE
CONVERSATIONS ARE WE NEED TO BE
PART OF THE SPACES AND I'M
HAPPY THAT WE'RE INVITED TO BE
HERE BUT I JUST WANT TO ELEVATE
BECAUSE WE ARE OUT AS YOU ALL
ARE ACCOUNTABLE TO US AS-
RESIDENTS OF CALIFORNIA US US
ORGANIZERS WERE ACCOUNTABLE TO
COMMUNITY AND ELEVATING THE
VOICES OF WHAT'S ACTUALLY
HAPPENING ON THE GROUND. AND
REALLY HAVING THOSE
CONVERSATIONS OF WHAT HAS
HAPPENED IN THE EYE IN THE PAST
SO THE TALKING AND LEARNING
FROM THE PAST SO WE CAN
CONTINUE MOVING TOWARDS THE
FUTURE AND MOVING CALIFORNIA OF
HAVING TO CALIFORNIA FOR ALL I
WANT TO ELEVATE SOMETHING
THAT'S VERY RELEVANT TO WHAT
I'VE HEARD FROM THE OTHER
PANELISTS ADAM AS WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT RECOMMENDATIONS IT AND
WHAT NOT OF THAT YOU WERE WE
WERE BACK THEN AND WHERE WE ARE
NOW. AND WHAT IS VERY RELEVANT
IS SOMETHING THAT I WANT TO
BRING UP AND I BROUGHT IT UP IN
ANOTHER SPACE I EARLIER THIS
MONTH IS HOW. OUR COMMUNITY HAS
SHIFTED ASSEMBLY WE HAVE DONE
SOME GREAT OUR PROGRESS IN THE
IT BUT THEN THERE'S SO MUCH TO
LEARN AND THERE'S SO MUCH. TO
DO. AND I WHY I WANT ALL OF ITS.
ASTRID ON APPROACH THAT WE TOOK
LAST MONTH WITH SOME OF OUR
YOUTH NOT ONLY HERE RIVERSIDE
BUT THROUGHOUT THE REGION. AND
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT HOW THE ARE
THEY SAW THEIR GRANDPARENTS SAW
THE AYE YOU BACK IN THE DAY. WE
DID RIVERSIDE COUNTY WE WERE WE
WHAT WE STILL HAVE A LOT OF
REAL COMMUNITY BUT WE WERE WE
WERE VERY ROLE. AND AS OUR OUR
GRANDPARENTS WERE ELEVATED THIS
THIS WAS A STUDY THAT WE FOCUS
GROUPS WITH THE FRONT OF A
GROUP FROM SIX YEAR OLD TWO
ELEVEN YEAR OLD. AND THE
GRANDPARENTS AND PARENTS WERE
TALKING ABOUT HOW THEY USED TO
BE FARMWORKERS. AND THIS IS THE
DRIVE FROM THE STORIES THAT
THE- RIGHT THE KIDS WERE
LISTENING. FOR THE GRANDPARENTS
AND PARENTS HELP DECIDE THE I.
E. A LOT OF THEM WERE
FARMWORKERS AND THEY LOVE THEY
WERE VERY HAPPY. THE WE SEE THE
ORANGE TREES AND WE SAW A VERY.
HAPPY SON. BUT NOW THIS IS HOW
OUR KIDS SEE THE I EAT. WE SEE
WAREHOUSES. THAT'S REALLY WE
SEE ALL THE TRAFFIC. ON THE
GROUND. AND MORSE IMPORTANTLY
WE CONTINUE SEEN HOW. ARE WE DO
THIS THIS COMES IN WITH HEALTH
AND ENVIRONMENT AND HOW IT'S
REALLY AFFECTING OUR CA AND
COMMUNITY AND ALSO OUR ECONOMY.
BECAUSE A LOT OF THESE.
LOGISTICS AND EVERYTHING THAT'S
COMING DOWN THE JOBS THAT WERE
BRINGING INTO THE TO OUR COUNTY
IS REALLY NOT THEY'RE NOT GIVEN
THE OPPORTUNITY CIRCUIT
COMMUNITY COULD BE THRIVING
ECONOMIC. COMMUNITY SO I BRING
THIS AS A COMMUNITY APPROACH WE
WANT TO BE PART OF THESE
CONTINUE BEING PART OF THESE
CONVERSATIONS. ARE BUT ALSO TO
CREATE A CONSCIOUS WITHIN ALL
OF US HERE THAT HAVE THE POWER
IN SIT IN THOSE SEATS. THAT WE
HAVE TO LISTEN TO COMMUNITY AND
WE HAVE TO BE ON THE GROUND
BECAUSE NOBODY ELSE KNOWS. MORE
THAN WHAT ARE AT THAT SUFFERING
OUR COMMUNITY THAT HAS TO HAVE
TWO TO THREE JOBS IN ORDER TO
MAKE MAKE ENDS MEET. SO I THINK
YOU ASSEMBLYMAN I SABRINA FOR
ALWAYS HOW IT HAD MAKING SURE
THAT. THAT THEY HAS TO COME
FROM THE GRASSROOTS AND I WANT
TO CONTINUE ELEVATING THAT
THAT. DOES HAVE TO COME FROM
THE GRASSROOTS IT CANNOT BE A
TOP DOWN APPROACH. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SO MUCH LOSE FOR YOUR
COMMENTS AND JUST YOU KNOW I
ALSO WANT TO GRADUATE THOUGH
THAT FIRST. CELEBRATING THE
THIRTY FIFTH ANNIVERSARY. THIS
IS PAST WEEK AND ALL THE
EFFORTS JUNE OUR COMMUNITY.
ACROSS BOTH REGIONS. ALL THE
WAY FROM THE EASTERN SHALLOW
VALLEY. TO THE WESTERN PART OF
RIVERSIDE COUNTY THANK YOU
LOOSE. NEXT WE HAVE MEDINA
SOLANO. WITH MY DS STILL WITH
US. GOOD MORNING GOOD MORNING
AND WE'RE SO EXCITED TO BE HERE
I'M THE EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR FOR
THE NATIONAL AT THE IN A
BUSINESS WOMAN ASSOCIATION
WE'RE EXCITED TO SEE THAT. THAT
THE LEGISLATIVE AREA IS LOOKING
AT OUR LATINA AND HOW WE'RE
DOING OUR RESPONSIBILITY AS AN
ORGANIZATION IS TO EMPOWER LET
THE NEST TO GROW THEIR
BUSINESSES AND ASSN
ORGANIZATION WE HAVE BEEN
AROUND TWENTY YEARS STARTING IN
LOS ANGELES. HERE IN THE I. E.
WE CAME HERE FIVE YEARS AGO AND
SO OUR FOCUS IS TO PROVIDE
CAPACITY BUILDING PROGRAMS FOR
THE SMALL BUSINESS COMMUNITY
THAT MICHAEL BUSINESS COMMUNITY
WE FOCUS ON OF A START UP SO WE
HAVE THE EMERGING AT THE NEST
PROGRAM AND IN A FOCUS ON
UNDERSTANDING FINANCIALS
LEADERSHIP AND HOW TO ACT HIDE
A CREATE IN ORGANIZATIONAL
STRUCTURE THAT'LL GROW AND
CREATE JOBS. AND THEN WE HAVE
FOR A MORE MATURE BUSINESSES WE
HAVE THE BUSINESS MANAGEMENT
ACADEMY THAT FOCUSES ON THE
SAME THING HOWEVER LOOKING NOW
AT ORGANISED A BUSINESSES THAT.
HAVE BEEN AROUND THREE YEARS
PLUS. AND ARE LOOKING TO GROW
AND SELL TO CORPORATE AMERICA
OUR PUBLIC ENTITIES. SO AS AN
ORGANIZATION WE CHAT WE SEE
WERE CHALLENGED TO GET OUR OUR
MICRO BUSINESSES ARE SMALL
BUSINESS OWNERS TO THE TABLE
FOR THE TRAININGS AND SOMEONE
MENTIONED EARLIER THAT. THAT
THAT DENIES IT THEY NOT ONLY DO
THEY ARE THEY STARTING THESE
THESE NEW BUSINESS SAYS BAD
THEY'RE HOLDING A BUSINESS JOB.
AND USUALLY THEY HAVE THEIR
FAMILIES AND THEY ARE THE CEOS
OF THEIR HOMES AS WELL. SO WE
SEE THAT CHALLENGE HOWEVER YOU
KNOW AS AN ORGANIZATION WE ALSO
FOLK. WE ARE ALSO FOCUSING ON
UNDERSTANDING WHAT THE SMALL
BUSINESS COMMUNITY THAT MICHAEL
BUSINESS COMMUNITY. MADE UP OF
LATINAS NEEDS SO WE HAVE
LAUNCHED THE STEADY IN
PARTNERSHIP WITH UC RIVERSIDE
AND THE SBA. TO UNDERSTAND WHAT
IT WHO ARE LETTING US HERE IN
THE I. E. WHAT ARE THEY DOING
WHAT THEY NEED AND WE ARE SO
EXCITED. THAT WE'RE MEETING.
WITH DOCTOR TODAY I AND.
LOOKING AT HER STUDY THAT SHE
HAS DONE FOR HOPE HOPE IS
FOCUSING ON ALL OF SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA OUT WE WANT TO FOCUS
ON THE AYE EE. OUR MAIN CONCERN
IS THAT THERE ISN'T ENOUGH
FUNDING FOR NONPROFITS IN THE
I. E. WHO WANT TO REPRESENT THE
SMALL BUSINESS COMMUNITY SUCH
AS OURSELVES BUT I IN TERMS OF
THIS STUDY WE WERE REALLY
SURPRISED WHEN WE DECIDED TO.
TO LAUNCH THE STUDY AS AN
ORGANIZATION THAT THERE IS NO
SUCH STUDY IN THE IP SO HOW DO
YOU HOW DO WE ALL UNDERSTAND.
WHAT THE SMALL BUSINESS
COMMUNITY ARE LETTING US IN
PARTICULAR ARE NEEDING ON THE
CHALLENGES THAT THEY'RE FACING
IF THERE'S NO SUCH STUDY. FIRST
AN ORGANIZATION WE WILL
CONTINUE THAT STUDY AND WE ASK
FOR YOUR SUPPORT AND PRIMARILY
ITS FINANCIAL SUPPORT AS ALL
NONPROFITS WHO WANT TO
REPRESENT THE MICHAEL
BUSINESSES AND SMALL BUSINESSES
IN THE I. E. SO THAT WE CAN
CONTINUE AND I'M SO EXCITED TO
SEE THAT THE MILKEN INSTITUTE
THIS YEAR AS WELL. I WAS THE
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OR NOT
PROFIT IN LA AS WELL AND WE
PARTNERED WITH THEM IN DOING A
SIMILAR STUDY FOR LOS ANGELES
WE WANT TO TALK TO YOU AS WELL.
SO EXCITED TO SEE THAT YOU ARE
DOING THIS AND WE WANT TO SEE
MORE OF THIS ISN'T GONNA
STATION ASPEN ORGAN THEY SHOT.
THAT WERE PARTNERING. WITH THE
RIGHT OF WAY RIGHT. IN
ASSISTANCE HERE THE I. B. I'M
VERY NEW TO THE I. E. SOME
STILL LEARNING WHO I NEED TO
TALK TO BUT RIVERSIDE WE
REPRESENT THE INLAND EMPIRE SO
WE PARTNER WITH RIVERSIDE AND
SAN BERNARDINO. AREAS TO PUT
OUR WORD OUT OUR CONFERENCES
COMING UP OCTOBER THE THIRTIETH
WE HOPE YOU WILL JOIN US. AND
THE FOCUS OF COURSE THE
SUPPLIER DIVERSITY. WE ARE
GOING TO DO CERTIFIED AS SMALL
BUSINESSES AND WOMEN OWNED
BUSINESSES. THAT WANT TO GROW
AND DO BUSINESS WITH. CORPORATE
AMERICA SO WE LOOK FORWARD TO
YOUR SUPPORT AND WHERE IS YOUR
CONFERENCE BEING HELD. AT THE
ONTARIO CONVENTION CENTER
OCTOBER THE THIRTIETH THANK YOU
THANK YOU FOR YOUR COMMENTS
ABSOLUTELY. WE HAVE DONE IS
SENDING. FOLLOWING DENNIS WE
HAVE STEPHANIE OLD IN DEN AND
ANGELICA GOVERNMENTS. THANK YOU
SABRINA CERVANTES ASSEMBLY
WOMAN SABRINA CERVANTES AND THE
COMMITTEE MEN NEVER MEMBERS FOR
MY INVITATION TODAY
CONGRATULATIONS TO YOU AND
COURTNEY MY NAME IS SUNNY
DENNIS SONNY I WORK THROUGH THE
DEPARTMENT OF COMMERCE'S ANY P.
THE MANUFACTURES EXTENSION
PARTNERSHIP PROGRAM SUPPORTING
THE INLAND EMPIRE FOR THIRTEEN
YEARS I'M HERE TO PUBLICLY
THANK SABRINA CERVANTES SOME
ASSEMBLY WOMAN SABRINA
CERVANTES. FOR HER
PARTICIPATION IN SUPPORTING THE
INLAND EMPIRE WOMEN IN
MANUFACTURING MOVEMENT WOMEN
ARE LARGELY UNDER REPRESENTED
AND THE MANUFACTURING INDUSTRY
AND IS BECAUSE OF YOUR
INVOLVEMENT IN OUR INLAND
EMPIRE WOMEN IN MANUFACTURING
MOVEMENT THAT WE'VE BEEN ABLE
TO INNOVATE MOTIVATE EDUCATE
CREATE CONNECTIONS DEMOLISH
STEREO TYPES EMPOWER WOMEN IN
MANUFACTURING CAREER PATHS
BUILD CONFIDENCE. INSPIRE THE
NEXT GENERATION WE AND THIS IS
OUR SECOND YEAR TWO THOUSAND
NINETEEN WAS OUR SECOND YEAR
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR COMING
AND SPEAKING AT OUR EVENTS WE
RAISED OVER TWENTY SIX THOUSAND
DOLLARS IN STEM SCHOLARSHIP
THAT WE GAVE BACK TO THE
COMMUNITY AND WE ARE CONSTANTLY
LOOKING FOR INVESTMENTS INTO
OUR MOVEMENTS. IT'S GROWING
LIKE CRAZY IN THE ON EMPIRE AND
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU
FOR WE DID DENNIS THANK YOU.
HELLO GOOD MORNING THANK YOU
SABRINA CERVANTES ASSEMBLY
MEMBER THANK YOU FOR INVITING
ME HERE TODAY I AM STEPHANIE
ODIN THE EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF
THE GARDENS RIVERSIDE I JUST
WANNA TALK ABOUT THE
PARTNERSHIP WE DO WITH
DIFFERENT SCHOOLS IN THE AREA.
WE TALKING OF UPWARD MOBILITY
AND ON EARLIER SOME OF THE
PANEL MEMBERS TALKING ABOUT YOU
KNOW. GENERATION GO WE PARTNER
WITH LAST HEARING OVERSEE THE
FOR THEIR STUDENTS TO CALM
STANFORD UNIVERSITY AND THAT'S
SOMETHING VERY IMPORTANT THAT
YOU KNOW ESPECIALLY BEING IN
HEALTHCARE. NOTE GETTING THOSE
CHILDREN GETTING THEM INVOLVED
BECAUSE AS HE SAID YOU KNOW
WE'RE GOING TO AUTOMATION BUT
YOU CAN'T AUTOMATE HEALTH CARE.
YOU KNOW YOU HAVE TO HAVE THAT
PERSONAL TOUCH YOU HAVE THAT
THE HUMAN TOUCH SO IF MORE
PEOPLE GET OUT THERE AND YOU
KNOW WITH YOUR ASSISTANCE IN
YOUR BACK WITH YOUR BACKING. TO
HELP PARTNER WITH OUR STUDENTS
AND OUR COLLEGES IN OUR SCHOOLS
YOU KNOW WE CAN CONTINUE
GROWING THE I. E. IN ON THAT ON
THAT FRONT AND I JUST WANNA
THANK YOU FOR INVITING ME THANK
YOU FOR ALL THAT YOU'VE DONE.
AND YOU KNOW JUST. SUPPORTING
THE ID. THANK STAFF MAKE LOCAL.
AFTER IN THE HOTEL WE HAVE
VERONICA. ERICA AND DAISY DAISY
LOCUSTS. GOOD MORNING THANK YOU
SO MUCH FOR HAVING ME AND
CONGRATULATIONS SABRINA AND
YOUR WITH YOUR FAMILY I'M MY
NAME IS ANGELA GOMEZ LIKE I
SAID I'M AN ORGANIZER WITH THE
INLAND EMPIRE LABOR COUNCIL THE
INLAND EMPIRE LABOR COUNCIL
REPRESENTS OVER MORE THAN
EIGHTY LOCAL UNIONS FROM EVERY
SECTOR OF THE LABOR MOVEMENT
WITH A MEMBERSHIP OF MORE THAN
A HUNDRED AND EIGHTY THOUSAND
WORKING PEOPLE. WE STRIVE TO
BETTER THE LIVES OF ALL WORKERS
AND THEIR FAMILIES OUR CONCERN
FOR THE REGION IS ENSURING GOOD
PAYING JOBS SAVE JOBS JOBS THAT
WILL PROVIDE THE COMMUNITY AND
MEMBERS WITH FORTY OUR
GUARANTEED WORK WITH BENEFITS
LIVABLE WAGES JOBS THAT WILL
COST US LESS TIME ON THE
FREEWAYS AND MORE TIME WITH OUR
FAMILIES ALSO ENSURING THAT
THESE LOCAL COMMUNITIES ARE THE
FIRST TO BENEFIT FROM IT THESE
NEW JOB OPPORTUNITIES. IT IS
OUR GOAL TO MAKE THIS REGION A
PLACE TO LIVE AND WORK AND HOW
DO WE DO THAT THROUGH
APPRENTICESHIP PROGRAMS MAKING
SURE THAT WHEN THEY'RE DONE
WITH THAT PROGRAM THAT THEY DO
HAVE A JOB WAITING FOR THEM
FIGHTING FOR BETTER WAGES FOR
HOME CARE PROVIDERS BECAUSE WE
SEE THAT THERE IS A HUGE RISE
FOR THAT AND THERE'S A GREAT
NEED FOR THAT EXPECTING IN OUR
REGION. AND TING ON IT. THE
BOOK OVER AND SHE WAS WITH. THE
ALLIES AND ELECTED IF. MUCH FOR
ME. THANK YOU MADAM CHAIRMAN
FOR HAVING ME AND IT WAS GOOD
TO SEE YOU AGAIN SO MY NAME IS
VERONICA WHAT I'M WITH THE
WAREHOUSE WORKER RESOURCE
CENTER SO THE WAREHOUSE WORKER
RESOURCE CENTER IS A NONPROFIT
FIVE OH ONE C. THREE ADVOCACY
ORGANIZATION THAT'S BEEN HERE
SINCE MY DAUGHTER WAS SIX
MONTHS SHE JUST TURNED ELEVEN
YEARS OLD OUR WE'VE BEEN DOING
ADVOCACY WORK SPECIFICALLY WITH
THE LOGISTICS INDUSTRY. I'M I
THINK IT'S IMPORTANT FOR ME TO
GIVE YOU A BACKGROUND OF HEALTH
THINGS WHERE WHEN I WAS JUST
GETTING HERE. I REMEMBER
SPEAKING TO WORKERS WHO HAD A
HOME. WHO HAD A CAR NOTE WHOSE
WIFE WAS ABLE TO STAY HOME AND
TAKE CARE OF THEIR KIDS. IN BY
THE TIME MY DAUGHTER WAS THREE
THESE PEOPLE WERE LOSING THEIR
HOME. THEY WERE LOSING THEIR
CARS. PEOPLE'S HOMES WERE BEING
SECTIONED OFF AND RENTED OUT IN
SUBSECTIONS TO BE ABLE TO PAY
THE RENT. BEFORE THE CRISIS.
BEFORE THE- HOUSING BUBBLE.
RIGHT JUST SO THAT THEY COULD
STAY IN THEIR HOME AND
CONNECTED TO THE COMMUNITY THAT
THEY HAD LIVED IN. AND IT
BECAME APPARENT THAT THE
CONDITIONS THAT THE WORKERS
WERE FACING WAS NOT. AN
ACCIDENT THIS WAS BY DESIGN
SPECIFICALLY BY SOME OF THE
LARGEST CORPORATIONS THAT WE
KNOW OFF LIKE THE WALMART IN
AMAZON'S OF THE WORLD. THAT HAD
REALIZE HOW TO SUBCONTRACT HAD
A TEMP OUT IN HOW TO CREATE
PRECARIOUS WORKING CONDITIONS.
THAT OUR COMMUNITY HE WOULD
HAVE TO STRIVE TO HOLD ON TO
SURVIVE. THE CONDITIONS THAT I.
THAT I BEGAN TO NOTE BECAUSE
WORKERS WALK INTO OUR OFFICE ON
A DAY TO DAY BASIS WHERE
PRECARIOUS WORKING
RELATIONSHIPS IN NATURE.
DANGEROUS WHERE A HIGH HAZARD
INDUSTRY SO WORK. FOR THE FIRST
TIME LAST YEAR WE- SENATOR
CONNIE LEVER WAS ABLE TO
INTRODUCE AN INDOOR HEAT
STANDARD. AND THAT TO ME THAT'S
INSANE. RIGHT THAT WORKERS
WOULD HAVE TO WORK INSIDE OF AN
ON VENTILATED LOGISTICS
FACILITY. WHERE THE DEGREES
OUTSIDE WERE UPWARDS OF ONE
HUNDRED DEGREES OF HAVING TO
WORK INSIDE OF A CORRUGATED
STEEL CONTAINER. WHOSE HE'D
COULD REACH OVER ONE TWENTY
DEGREES. AND HAVING TO STILL
EXERT PHYSICAL EXHAUSTION AND
STRAIN ON THEIR BODY. THEN
HAVING TO GO HOME WITHOUT BEING
ABLE TO AFFORD AIR
CONDITIONING. THESE ARE NOT.
THESE ARE NOT ONE ONE INSTANCE
THIS WAS THE THIS THIS IS A
SYSTEM. OF WITH RAMPANT LEGAL
VIOLATIONS WITH THE CLIMATE
CRISIS UPON UPON US WHERE
COMMUNITIES ARE CONSTANTLY
BEING. CONTINUED TO BE HARMED
CRIMINALIZING ARE POOR
COMMUNITIES IMMIGRANT
COMMUNITIES PEOPLE OF COLOR
COMMUNITIES. AND SO THE EROSION
CONTINUES. SO TODAY I HEARD A
LOT ABOUT HOW BUSINESS ARE CAN
COME IN AND WATER HOW CAN WE
CONTINUE TO GROW OUR IN. OUR
INDUSTRY AND OUR REGION FOR THE
POSITIVE. SO I JUST WANTED TO.
THREE THREE RESPONSES AND YOU
DIDN'T ASK ME BUT I WOULD LIKE
TO CHIME IN. AND I DON'T KNOW
IF I GOT THE QUESTION CORRECTLY
BUT YOU AS PROFESSOR. ARE ROMAN
CHRISTIAN ON WHAT COULD WE DO
IN THE NEXT YEAR TO GAIN
INVESTMENT IN OUR COMMUNITY.
AND SO I BELIEVE THAT THE
RESPONSE WAS SOMETHING AROUND A
PUBLIC DOLLARS FOR PRIVATE
INVESTMENT. BUT THAT CANNOT BE
WITHOUT DEMANDING STANDARDS ALL
OF THESE PUBLIC SUBSIDY
DOLLARS. THIS MONEY BELONGS TO
THE COMMUNITY AND ANY
INVESTMENT ANY PUBLIC SUBSIDIES
THAT ARE GOING TO BE GOING. TO
PRIVATE AS MEN NEED TO COME
ATTACHED WITH STAFF. UNDER THAT
ARE GOING TO ELEVATE OUR
COMMUNITY. THE SECOND ON A
RESPONSE THAT I JUST WANT TO
CHIME IN TO WAS BY MISS MOLLY
WILSHIRE. ON WHEN SHE WAS
TALKING ABOUT THE
SUSTAINABILITY CHALLENGE AND
ONE OF HER TECHNIQUES OF
BREAKING DOWN BARRIERS AND SHE
GAVE A VERY TOUCHING STORY
ABOUT THE DISNEYLAND IN AND HOW
GREAT IT WAS TO GIVE
OPPORTUNITIES TO CHILDREN TO GO
TO DISNEYLAND. BUT ANOTHER
OPPORTUNITY WOULD BE TO ENSURE
THAT WE'RE SUPPORTING OF
BUSINESSES THAT ARE RESPONSIBLE
IN NATURE THAT OUR PAIN LIVABLE
WAGES THAT ARE SUPPORTING.
THEIR EMPLOYEES WITH TOP WITH
BENEFITS WITHOUT CAPACITY TO
TAKE TIME OFF TO TAKE CARE OF
THEIR KIDS SO THAT THEY'RE NOT
RISKING BEING FIRED IF THEY DO
TAKE TIME OFF TO TAKE CARE OF
THEIR KIDS RIGHT AND THEN
LASTLY THE QUESTION ON THE
PHONE OR BEEN THE
VULNERABILITIES THAT OUR-
REGION IN PARTICULAR FACES WITH
AUTOMATION. AND ONCE AGAIN THAT
THE HOUSE WAS THAT A HEAVY
INVESTMENT BE MADE FOR THESE
TYPES OF GROWTH OPPORTUNITIES
RIGHT AND ONCE AGAIN AS LOSE
HAD MENTIONED THIS CANNOT GO
AND I CAN NOT RE ITERATE THIS
ENOUGH THIS CANNOT HAPPEN
WITHOUT TAKING THE COMMUNITY
THE FRONT LINE COMMUNITIES.
THAT HAVE BEEN HIT THE HARDEST
THAT I'VE BEEN DEALING WITH THE
IMPACTS OF THE LOGISTICS
INDUSTRY WITHOUT TAKING THEM
INTO ACCOUNT HAVING A SEAT AT
THE TABLE TO FIGURE OUT WHAT
COMMUNITY BENEFITS AGREEMENTS
COULD LOOK LIKE WHEN COMMUNITY.
IS REALLY TAKING INTO ACCOUNT.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME. THANK
YOU SO MUCH RUN AGAIN YES WE
DID HAVE A CONVERSATION
YESTERDAY ON THESE ISSUES AND I
WHICH IS WHY I DID INTRODUCE A
I'VE BEEN AB ONE SEVENTY SIX
THAT I MENTIONED DISCUSSING THE
QUALITY OF JOBS. THAT WE ARE
BRINGING TO OUR REGION AND THAT
THEY HAVE TO HAVE. I DO KNOW
THERE HAS TO BE CRITERIA
INVOLVED WITH THESE QUALITY OF
JOBS AND THERE HAS TO BE.
ACCOUNTABILITY IS WELL FOLLOW
UP ONCE PUBLIC DOLLARS ARE
RECEIVED AND SO AGAIN FOR ME
IT'S GOING TO CONTINUE LOOKING
OUT THE REPORTING OF WAGES I
THAT HAVE NOT BEEN REPORTED. IN
THE PAST TO CONTINUE TO GO ON
REPORTED REQUIRING FULL TIME
EMPLOYMENT. I SEE TOUCH ON A
LOT OF IMPORTANT ISSUES THAT MY
TEAM AND I HAVE BEEN DISCUSSING
A WHEN IT COMES TO BE AN
INTENTIONAL WITH OUR PUBLIC
POLICY. AND SO AGAIN I A
BELIEVER IN BRINGING POLICY
FROM THE GROUND UP AND WORKING
WITH AS SO MANY STAKEHOLDERS
THAT WITNESS HE DIDN'T IN.
FEELING THIS ON THE GROUND IN
SO I APPRECIATE YOUR. I CHOOSE
FAMILIES IN OUR REGION AND LOOK
FOR TO CONTINUE ENGAGING ON
THIS MATTER. WE HAVE OUR NEXT
SPEAKER. HELLO MY NAME IS ERICA
CAPTAIN WITH THE WAREHOUSE
WORKER RESOURCE CENTER WHICH
FIRST LIKE TO THANK THE
ASSEMBLY WOMAN SABRINA
CERVANTES FOR HOLDING THIS
MEETING AND ALLOWING US THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK ON THESE
ISSUES. SO I'D LIKE TO START
OFF BY SAYING THAT THE
WAREHOUSE WORKER RESOURCE
CENTER HAS RECENTLY TAKEN PART
IN MOVING FORWARD LEGISLATION
FOR EXAMPLE AB FIVE WAS JUST
PASSED INTO LAW. REQUIRING
CORPORATIONS TO CORRECTLY
CLASSIFY WORKERS GIVING THEM
THE WAGES AND BENEFITS THAT GO
ALONG WITH THAT. IN ADDITION AB
FORTY FIVE IS ANOTHER BILL THAT
WE HAVE WORKED ON. A BILL TO
BILL TRANSFERS TRANSPARENCY
WITHIN. WHEN CORPORATIONS
WAREHOUSE CORPORATIONS TAKE ON
GOVERNMENT SUBSIDIES. IN
CITIES. AND THIS REQUIRES THEM
TO DISCLOSE INFORMATION ABOUT
JOBS JOB TYPES WAGES AND
BENEFITS AND- THE AVAILABILITY
OF HIRING PROGRAMS. ON THINGS
OF THAT NATURE. BUT WHEN WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT THESE KINDS OF
NEW LEGISLATION'S THESE NEWLY
BORN LINES. IT KIND OF SEEMS
LIKE THE BARE MINIMUM THAT WE
CAN BE DOING FOR WORKERS.
CLASSIFYING WORKERS CORRECTLY
ALLOWING WORKERS BREAKS WHEN
THE HEAT EXCEEDS WORKING
WORKABLE CONDITIONS. REQUIRING
THAT WE KNOW WHAT CORPORATIONS
WILL OFFER THE COMMUNITY WHEN
THEY COME INTO THE COMMUNITY ON
TAX BREAKS AND THESE KIND OF
SEEN THIS KINDA SEEMS LIKE.
THIS IS THE BOTTOM LINE IN WHAT
THE BARE MINIMUM WE CAN BE
DOING. FOR WORKERS AND FOR OUR
COMMUNITIES HAN. SO WHEN WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT IMPROVING THE
REGION'S ECONOMY IT IS CRUCIAL
THAT. WE REALIZE. THE PROCESS
IS ALREADY IN PLACE HERE AND SO
A LOT OF PEOPLE HAVE SPOKEN
ABOUT. THE NORTH AB FORTY FIVE
WE KNOW THAT. IT IS IMPORTANT
TO BUILD THIS KIND OF
ACCOUNTABILITY AND TRANSPARENCY
WITHIN CORPORATIONS BECAUSE ON
A LOT OF THESE WAREHOUSES
CONTRIBUTE TO THE BALLOONING
LEVELS OF LOW WAGE AND LOW
BENEFIT WORK ALREADY AVAILABLE
HERE AND SO WHAT I HEARD A LOT
EARLIER WAS PEOPLE TALKING
ABOUT THE NEXT AND NECESSITY OF
NOT JUST FOCUSING ON WHAT IS
BAD OR WHAT IS DAMAGED IN THE
AREA AND KEEPING OUR MINDS ON
THE- ON A VISION OF THE FUTURE
THAT. WE DON'T WE HAVEN'T TAKEN
THE STEPS TO BUILD YET AND SO I
AGREE I THINK IT'S IMPORTANT TO
NOT THINK OF THE REGION AS
DAMAGED IN ANY WAY BUT ALSO. AS
EQUALLY IMPORTANT IS REALIZING
ALL THE WAYS THAT WORKERS HAVE
BEEN EXPLOITED AND HAVE BEEN.
PUSH DOWN. I THESE CORPORATIONS
IN BY THESE BY THE LOGISTICS
INJURES INDUSTRY SPECIFICALLY.
SO I THINK ALONG WITH THAT IF
WE DON'T STOP TO SERIOUSLY
CONSIDER THAT HISTORY AND HOW
WORKERS HAVE BEEN EXPLOITED
THEN WE CAN NEVER FULLY PREPARE
FOR THE FUTURE FOR ALL THE
ACCOUNT FOR. WHAT HAS BEEN DONE
IN THIS AREA AND MY HUSBAND
ALLOWED TO BE DONE. SO WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT IMPROVING THE FIT
THE REGION'S ECONOMY IT'S
CRUCIAL THAT WE HAVE WORKERS ON
BOARD IN THE CONVERSATIONS.
LEADING THE CONVERSATIONS
BECAUSE THESE ARE THE PEOPLE
THAT ARE POWERING THE
INDUSTRIES THAT. NOW MAKE UP SO
MUCH OF OUR REGION'S COMMERCE
AND ECONOMY. AND SO MOVING
FORWARD I THINK THAT. MOVING
FORWARD ON THE BEST. PLAN TO
IMPROVE THE REGION'S ECONOMY IN
THE FUTURE I HOPE THAT THIS IS
SOMETHING THAT WE REMEMBER THAT
THE WORKERS. ARE THE PEOPLE
THAT ULTIMATELY. POWER THESE
REGIONS AND HAVE TO DEAL WITH
THE BRUNT OF THE WORK AND SO
NOTHING CAN BE DONE WITHOUT
HAVING THEM ON BOARD AND HAVING
THEM LEAD THESE CONVERSATIONS
AND THINKING OF THE SOLUTIONS
THAT WE NEED TO FOLLOW IN ORDER
TO BUILD A MORE ECHOED
EQUITABLE FUTURE. AND I'LL JUST
LEAVE ANA THANK YOU THANK HERE.
AFTER NEXT SPEAKER WE HAVE
RECEIVED GOLD CORD MIGHT GO
COST CO AND JORDANA ONE. GOOD
AFTERNOON ASSEMBLY MEMBERS
ABOUT THIS AND COMMITTEE
MEMBERS SO ERICA SPOKE A LITTLE
BIT ABOUT WHAT WE'RE TRYING TO
DO ON THE STATE LEVEL TO PUSH
POLICIES TO IMPROVE WORKING
CONDITIONS FOR WORKERS IN
CALIFORNIA ON THE LOCAL LEVEL
WE'VE BEEN WORKING WITH OTHER
LABOR ENVIRONMENTAL FAITH AND
IMMIGRANT. JUSTICE
ORGANIZATIONS AS A IN THEM
COALITION FOR SUSTAINABLE GOODS
MOVEMENT IN ORDER TO ADDRESS
SOME OF THE CHALLENGES THAT ARE
COMMUNITIES FACE TO THE
INCREASINGLY DOMINANCE
LOGISTICS CENTER SOME OF THESE
ORGANIZATIONS INCLUDE WITH THE
CENTER FOR COMMUNITY ACTION AN
ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE. INLAND
EMPOWERMENT AND THEN EMPIRE
LABOR COUNCIL INLAND COALITION
FOR IMMIGRANT JUSTICE IN THE
CONGREGATIONS UNITED FOR CHANGE
A TEAMSTERS LOCAL NINETEEN
THIRTY TWO A SIERRA CLUB IS MY
GENERATION CAMPAIGN AND OTHER
SUPPORTERS. THE INLAND EMPIRE
HAS BECOME DOMINATED BY THE
LOGISTICS INDUSTRY WHERE MORE
THAN ONE HUNDRED THOUSAND
PEOPLE WORK AND LOCAL
WAREHOUSES. AND THEY MOVE HALF
A TRILLION DOLLARS WORTH OF
GOODS A YEAR MOST OF THESE
WORKERS AT THESE WAREHOUSES AND
RESIDENTS LIVING FIVE IS
WAREHOUSES HAVE NOT SEEN THE
BENEFITS OF THESE DEVELOPMENTS
SUBSTANTIAL PORTIONS OF THIS
WORKFORCE ARE STUCK IN
TEMPORARY JOBS THE MINIMUM WAGE
AND COMMUNITIES HERE THESE
WAREHOUSES READING SOME OF THE
MOST CONTAMINATED AIR IN THE
REGION. THIS SUMMER WE HAD
EIGHTY SEVEN THIRTY THAT
SURPASS THE ROLES TENDERED.
THAT'S WHY WE'VE TOGETHER TO
THE MAN RESPONSIBLE AND.
ACCOUNTABLE DEVELOPMENT OF THE
OPERATE. OF THE MOVIE BUSINESS
IN THE I. E. SOME OF THE THINGS
THAT WERE WORKING TO PUSH AS A
STANDARD FOR THIS REGION IN
ADDITION TO WORKERS RIGHTS SO
WE NEED TO PUSH FOR GOOD JOBS
AND GOOD JOB SHOULD NOT BE
DEFINED BY JUST MAKING EIGHTEEN
DOLLARS AN HOUR. BECAUSE THAT'S
NOT ENOUGH WORKERS NEED ACCESS
TO HEALTH CARE THEY NEED ACCESS
TO JOB TRAINING WE NEED TO
ENSURE THAT WE'RE HIRING
LOCALLY WE NEED TO LIMIT OR IF
NOT ALTOGETHER ELIMINATE THE
USE OF STAFFING AGENCIES WE
NEED COMPREHENSIVE AND
ENFORCEABLE SAFETY PROGRAMS. WE
ALSO NEED TO ENSURE THAT
THERE'S FISCAL ACCOUNTABILITY
AND TRANSPARENCY FOR SUBSIDIES
ANY PRIVATE INVESTMENT
RECEIVING PUBLIC FUNDS SHOULD
BENEFIT THE COMMUNITIES MOST
IMPACTED WE NEED A PUSH TOWARDS.
ZERO MISSIONS OF THESE
DEVELOPMENTS SHOULD HAVE A PLAN
IN PLACE TO MOVE TOWARDS OUR
OMISSIONS AND PROTECT OUR
ENVIRONMENTS WE NEED FUNDS FOR
OF SOUND PROOFING AND AIR
FILTERS. FOR SCHOOLS AND
COMMUNITIES MOST DIRECTLY
IMPACTED BY THE LOGISTICS
INTERESTS INDUSTRY AND THE
INCREASING TRUCK TRAFFIC WE
NEED ALSO A SIGNIFICANT FUNDS
DIRECTED FOR IMPROVING
INFRASTRUCTURE AND INVEST INTO
SCHOOL AND SPECIFICALLY WE'VE
AND WORKING ON GETTING A
COMMUNITY BENEFITS AGREEMENT
FOR THE SAN BERNADINO
INTERNATIONAL AIRPORT EXPANSION
ALSO KNOWN AS THE EAST GATE
LOGISTICS CENTER. IN OCTOBER OF
THIS YEAR THE SAN BERNARDINO
INTERNATIONAL AIRPORT AUTHORITY
APPROVED THE DEVELOPMENT OF A
SIX HUNDRED FIFTY EIGHT
THOUSAND SQUARE FOOT
DISTRIBUTION CENTER THAT WOULD
HOUSE TO SIXTEEN AIRCRAFT AND
ONCE THIS DEVELOPMENT IS FULLY
ESTABLISHED IT'S GOING TO ADD
TWENTY FOUR ROUND THE CLOCK
FLIGHTS AND THE DEVELOPER KNOWN.
AS HILL WOOD INTERNATIONAL
WHICH IS A TEXAS BASED COMPANY.
HAS NOT PROVIDED MUCH CLARITY
ON THE NUMBER AND THE QUALITY
OF THE JOBS THAT ARE GOING TO
BE DEVELOPED THROUGH THIS
PROJECT IN TWO THOUSAND AND TWO
THE INLAND VALLEY DEVELOPMENTAL
AGENCY ONE OF THE JOINT POWERS
AUTHORITIES THAT IS RESPONSIBLE
FOR THE ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT.
OF THE FORMER NORTON AIRFORCE
BASE ENTERED INTO THE MASTER
DISPOSITION AND DEVELOP AN
AGREEMENT WITH HILL. TO CREATE
WHAT IS KNOWN AS ALLIANCE
CALIFORNIA WHICH MIMICS THEIR
ALLIANCE TEXAS SINCE THEN HILL
WOULD HAS DEVELOPED TWENTY SIX
FACILITIES. IN AND NEAR SAN
BERNARDINO BUT WE HAVE YET TO
SEE THE COMMUNITY SHARE THE
BENEFITS FROM THESE
DEVELOPMENTS IN COMPARISON TO
RIVERSIDE COUNTY OF THE STATE
AND THE COUNTRY AS A WHOLE SAN
BERNARDINO COUNTY HAS HIGHER
LEVELS OF PARTY AT SEVENTEEN
POINT SIX PERCENT. WHICH WAS
MENTIONED IN THE- STATE OF THE
WORK REPORT AND THESE RATES ARE
HIGHER FOR COMMUNITIES OF
COLOR. OUR HOPES ARE THAT THIS
COMMITTEE CONSIDERED WORKING
ORGANIZATIONS LIKE OURS THAT
ARE WORKING WITH FRONTLINE
COMMUNITIES WE ARE TALKING
ABOUT OF MOBILITY AND THE IP.
THANK YOU. I BELIEVE WE HAVE.
THREE THREE MICHAEL JORDAN AND
NEXT TO SPEAK
. IF YOU WOULD
LIKE TO THE PUBLIC
. BUT UP TO
SUPPORT IT. I THINK THAT'S GOOD.
ALL RIGHT ARM THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR THIS IS A UNIQUE AND
INTIMATE OPPORTUNITY AND I
THINK IT WORKS VERY WELL FOR
THE COMMUNITIES IN
COMMUNICATING WITH ELECTED
OFFICIALS FROM BEYOND OUR LOCAL
LEVEL MY NAME IS RUTHIE GOLD
CORN I AM ON A TWENTY FOUR YEAR
OLD MICRO BUSINESS NO BARRIERS
DISABLED ACCESS CONSULTING AND
ADVOCACY SERVICES I ALSO SERVE
ON THE EXECUTIVE COMMITTEE
LEGISLATIVE COMMITTEE AND
LEGISLATION NEGOTIATING TEAM.
OF CALIFORNIANS FOR DISABILITY
RIGHTS I SERVE ON THE LOS
ANGELES WORLD AIRPORT AUTHORITY
DISABILITY ACCESSIBILITY
ADVISORY COMMITTEE AS WELL AS
THE INLAND EMPIRE DISABILITIES
COLLABORATIVE AMONG OTHERS THAT
SERVE BUSINESS INTERESTS AND
TRANSPORTATION AND I LIKE TO
REMIND EVERYBODY WE DON'T GO
MILES PER HOUR. WE GO HOURS PER
MILE. TRANSPORTATION
DIFFICULTIES THE ADVERSE AFFECT
THE TRANSPORTATION IS
ESPECIALLY ACUTE AND HAS AN
ADVERSE AFFECT ON PEOPLE WITH
DISABILITIES AND EMPLOYMENT. IT
IS SHOCKING TO SAY THIS WHAT'S.
Y'ALL HAVEN'T TALKED ABOUT US.
AT NO TIME IS ANYWHERE IN THESE
REPORTS THE DISABILITY MINORITY.
KEEP IN MIND WE ARE OPEN DORMAN
ALREADY WE ARE THE ONLY OPEN
DOOR MINORITY WE HAVE NO
CONSTITUTIONAL. QUALIFIERS OR
CHARACTERISTICS. MINORITIES OF
COLOR ARE ASKS AND WE ARE THE
DAY WHEN YOU TALK ABOUT
MINORITY INTEREST MINORITIES OF
COLOR WHEN YOU TALK ABOUT
EMPLOYMENT AND ACCELERATION
PROGRAMS AND ALL THESE
WONDERFUL THINGS THAT ARE GOING
FORWARD WITH A BIRD MOBILITY IN
THE I. E. ETCETERA. WHERE ARE
WE. WE THE DISABILITY COMMUNITY
STILL. HAVE AN 80% UNEMPLOYMENT
UNDEREMPLOYMENT RATE. HOW IS
THAT ACCEPTABLE IS THAT
ACCEPTABLE TO WOMEN OF COLOR.
NOW ARE WE WOMEN OF COLOR
WITHIN THE DISABILITY CAN
COMMUNITY YEAH WE ARE WITHOUT
QUESTION AND THE KEY STRATEGY
NUMBER FOUR. ECONOMIC
DIVERSIFICATION THERE IS NO
DIVERSITY WITHOUT THE
DISABILITY COMMUNITY. AND WHEN
YOU ARE DRESSED PEOPLE
DISABILITIES AND ECONOMIC
OPPORTUNITIES YOU CAN NOT UNDER
ANY CIRCUMSTANCES. IGNORE THE
ABLE ACT. AND THE CAL ABLE
OPPORTUNITIES THAT GIVE PEOPLE
WITH DISABILITIES THE RIGHT TO
WORK AND MAINTAIN THEIR
BENEFITS AND ELEVATE THEIR
STANDARD OF LIVING WE ARE NOT
REPRESENTED ON WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT BOARD'S WE ARE NOT
AT THE TABLE WITH EDA WITHOUT
COMMITMENT BY STATE AND LOCAL.
ELECTED OFFICIALS AND ALL OF
THE ECONOMIC. RESOURCES THAT
ARE HERE TODAY THE SERVERS. THE
CATALYST. WE'RE IN A CATTLE CAR.
WE ARE NOT PART OF THE CATALYST.
WE MUST HAVE SUPPORT. FROM THE
PUBLIC AND PRIVATE SECTORS THIS
WILL NEVER CHANGE CSI IS
IGNORING US ARE WE AT THE TABLE
ARE WE AT ANYBODY'S TABLE.
ACCESSIBLE OR NOT AS THIS ONE
ISN'T. BRING US IN THE DOOR.
MAKE YOUR DOOR FIVE POUNDS OF
PRESSURE TO OPEN OPEN A
90 DEGREES STAY OPEN LONG
ENOUGH ABOUT SMACKING A
SYNTHESIZER THE BEHIND AND WE
WILL BE THERE. WE ARE NOT AS
NIKE HAS CHARACTERIZED US
DROOLING GLASSY EYED MORONS IN
POWER CHAIRS. THAT IMAGE
PORTRAYED BY NIKE IS INDELIBLE.
WE ARE IN SCHOOL WE ARE AT
SCHOOL. WE ARE AT THE ASKS. WE
ARE IN BUILDINGS. WE ARE IN THE
WAREHOUSES. THE ABUSIVE
WAREHOUSES. FORTUNATELY THAT
ONE THE SIZE OF SEVEN HUNDRED
ROSE BOWLS. THAT IS. STILL
THANK GOD NOT COME TO FRUITION
IN MORENO VALLEY SEVEN HUNDRED
ROSE BOWLS THAT'S A HELL OF A
WAREHOUSE. WHAT'S GOING TO
OPERATE THAT WAREHOUSE ROBOT
NOT PEOPLE. WHEN YOU TALK ABOUT
PEOPLE. YOU HAVE TO TALK ABOUT
PEOPLE DISABILITIES DIVERSITY
AND INCLUSION THAT DOES NOT
SPECIFICALLY SAY. WITH
DISABILITIES IS NOT DIVERSITY
IT IS NOT INCLUSION. AGAIN I
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ASSEMBLY
WOMAN FOR HOLDING THIS HEARING.
MANY HEARING IN THIS UNIQUE AND
INTIMATE SETTING I THINK THAT
MORE PEOPLE FROM THE GENERAL
PUBLIC. WOULD FEEL VERY
COMFORTABLE COMING TO THEIR OWN
COMMUNITIES AND HAVING THESE
OFFICIAL HEARINGS TAKING PLACE.
AND YOU WOULD HEAR MORE DIVERSE
AND INCLUSIVE COMMENT. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU REVIEW FOR YOUR
COMMENTS. WE HAVE A COUPLE MORE
SPEAKERS BEFORE I CLOSE TO DAYS
FILLED HEARING IF WE CAN HAVE
MICHAEL. JORDANA AND OUR LAST
SPEAKER WILL BE DAVID NELSON.
POSSIBLE YES. AT THE LAST WEEK
SORRY. GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM
CHAIRMAN AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS
AGAIN MY NAME IS MICHAEL CASCIO
I WANT TO START OUT BY MITCH IN
FACT THEM A LONG TIME RESIDENT
OF THE I. E. OF. CITY RESIDENTS
PARTICULAR. WITHIN THE CONTEXT
OF GOLD THIS GOVERNOR'S OFFICE
OF BUSINESS AND ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT IS A SMALL AGENCY
THAT YOU'RE PROBABLY FAMILIAR
WITH CALL THE AYE BANK WHICH IS
THE CALIFORNIA INFRASTRUCTURE
AND ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT BANK.
WITH AN AYE BANK WHICH IS
CALIFORNIA'S MISSILE BANK THEY
GUARANTEE BONDS THE ISSUE
BONDS. ANY PROVIDE
INFRASTRUCTURE FINANCING IS A
SMALL BUSINESS FINANCE CENTER
AND WITHIN A SMALL BUSINESS
FINANCE CENTER. THEY OPERATE A
PLETHORA OF SMALL BUSINESS
CAPITAL ACCESS PROGRAMS WHICH
ARE OPERATED BY SEVEN FINANCIAL
DEVELOPMENT CORPORATIONS IN THE
STATE I HAPPEN OPERATE THE ONE.
IN ORANGE COUNTY WE HAVE
STATEWIDE AUTHORITY WE ISSUE WE
DO DIRECT LENDING AND WE ISSUE
CREDIT GUARANTEES. AND THAT'S
WHAT WE DO SO WE SUPPORT SMALL
BUSINESS OWNERS DISABLED OWNER
TABLE BUSINESS OWNERS VETERANS
IN. PROJECTS LOCATED IN PROJECT
AREAS. OF LOW INCOME AREAS AND
WE PROVIDE THOSE CAPITAL ACCESS
PROGRAMS SO I JUST WANT TO
MENTION WERE AVAILABLE. TO YOU
AND YOUR STAFF IN THE INLAND
EMPIRE WE COVER. WE'RE FUNDING
PROJECTS ALL WE OUT COACHELLA
VALLEY. UP TO THE HIGH DESERT.
THANK YOU THANK YOU ARE. GOOD
MORNING A GOOD MORNING MADAM
CHAIRWOMAN AND THANK YOU TO
EVERYONE THAT HAS BEEN DOING
THIS WORK AND FOR PROVIDING THE
SPACE MY NAME IS JORDAN ALONG
AND I WORK FOR STARTING OVER
INK AND I ALSO REPRESENT THE
RIVERSIDE CHAPTER OF ALL OF US
ARE NINE AND NATIONAL
INITIATIVE. STARTING OVER IS A
NON PROFIT IT'S ACTUALLY BASED
RIGHT HERE IN CORONA AND WE
PROVIDE A DIRECT SERVICES TO
PEOPLE EXPERIENCING
HOMELESSNESS AND ALSO THOSE
THAT ARE IMPACTED BY
INCARCERATION AND LA AND
RIVERSIDE COUNTIES WE ACTUALLY
HAVE SIX GOING ON EIGHT
TRANSITIONAL HOMES WILL REFER
VIED TRANSITIONAL AND ALSO
PERMANENT HOUSING TO THAT
SPECIFIC TO THOSE AS PACIFIC
POPULATIONS. SO ADVOCATE FOR
THE FURTHERING OF OUR RIGHTS
AND PART OF THE SERVICES THAT
WE PROVIDE OUR JOB READINESS
AND EMPLOYMENT PARTNERSHIPS AND
OPPORTUNITIES TO THE PEOPLE
THAT WE SERVE WE ARE
CONTINUALLY RECEIVING PUSH BACK
FROM EMPLOYERS WHEN IT COMES TO
OF PLACEMENT OF FOR THOSE THAT
HAVE BEEN FORMALLY INCARCERATED.
AND IN TALKING ABOUT
INCLUSIVITY AND JOB ACCESS WE
WANT TO KNOW HOW ARE PEOPLE
IMPACTED BY INCARCERATION
INCLUDED AN UPWARD MOBILITY.
ALSO AB TEN A THE FAIR CHANCE
ACT OF TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN
PROHIBITS EMPLOYERS FROM ASKING
JOB SEEKERS TO DISCLOSE THEIR
CONVICTION HISTORY PRIOR TO
PROVIDING A CONDITIONAL OFFER
BUT MOST AYE IAN PLAYERS REMAIN
OUT OF COMPLIANCE. AND MANY
PEOPLE ARE STILL UNAWARE OF
THEIR RIGHTS ACCORDING TO THE
FAIR CHANCE ACT SO MY THE
SECOND QUESTION IS HOW ARE I
IAN PLEA IS GOING TO BE HELD
ACCOUNTABLE AND TO ABIDE BY THE
FAIR CHANCE ACT AND GIVE
FORMALLY INCARCERATED PEOPLE
AND ALSO THOSE EXPERIENCING
HOMELESSNESS WHO HAVE. SIMILAR
BARRIERS ACCESS JOB ACCESS.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. IF WOULD
STILL HAVE DAVID NELSON WITH US.
BUT ALAS. SPEAKER OF THE PUBLIC
COMMENT SECTION. THE MORE
INSURANCE CERVANTES A BEGIN MY
TWENTY MINUTE PRESENTATION NOW.
BUT I'M DAVID NELSON IN THE
STATE WHERE LAYS ON FOR THE
CALIFORNIA SMALL BUSINESS
DEVELOPMENT CENTERS AND IT WAS
GREAT THE MICE HERE HE'S A
FANTASTIC RESOURCE NOT ONLY FOR
THE INLAND EMPIRE BUT FOR
REALLY FOR ALL OUR OUR ENTIRE
PROGRAM AND REALLY MY COMMENTS
TWO THANK YOU FOR COMING OUT
TO THE FIELD I THINK IT'S SO
IMPORTANT TO REALLY HEAR THE
NEED TO THE CONSTITUENCIES
THAT YOU REPRESENT AND THAT
THE COMMITTEE REPRESENTS AS
A WHOLE AND ALSO FOR -- I
GUESS YOU COULD SAY ECONOMIC
INDUSTRY PARTNERS TO COME
TO THE TABLE AND AND THAT'S
WERE SO MY COMMENTS ARE TWO
TWO REMINDS -- THOSE FOLKS
SAID THAT A PRESENTS THAT
PRESENTED TODAY THAT -- THE
CALIFORNIA SPDC WHICH IS A
PROGRAM OUT OF THE U. S.
SMALL BUSINESS ADMINISTRATION
IS A REGIONAL PROGRAM IS
NORTHERN CALIFORNIA CENTRAL
CALIFORNIA ORANGE COUNTY INLAND
EMPIRE LA LONG BEACH AND SAN
DIEGO WERE FIVE REGIONS AND
SO WE WILL WE ARE ACTIVELY
AND HAVE ACTUALLY BEEN WORKING
ON ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT AND
BUSINESS GROWTH -- AND FOR
THOSE THAT DON'T KNOW WHAT
WE PROVIDE IS WE PROVIDE
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE AT NO
COST TO THE BUSINESS ON OUR
WEATHER'S TO START A BUSINESS
TO EXPAND THE BUSINESS TO
HIRE TO DO INTERNATIONAL TRADE
CELEBRATIONS TO MOVE ON AND
-- THEY WERE ONE OF THE BEST
KEPT SECRETS REGRETS ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT THAT'S WHY WE'RE
GONNA BE PARTNERING VERY --
PROACTIVELY WITH CALIFORNIA
FORWARD IN THE ECONOMIC SUMMIT
COMING UP IN NOVEMBER AND WILL
BE ACTIVE -- WITH WELLS FARGO
AROUND -- ENTREPRENEURSHIP
AND SO ACT PLEASE CONTINUE NO
THANK YOU FOR YOUR CONTINUED
SUPPORT AND REMEMBER THAT
WE'RE HERE AS A RESOURCE NOT
ONLY TO THE COMMITTEE AND TO
THE AMAZING STAFF BUT ALSO TO
THOSE THAT -- THAT ARE DOING
THE THE THE GOOD HARD WORK ON
THE GROUND -- AS WELL AND AND
JUST TO GIVE A LITTLE -- IDEAS
TO LAST YEAR IN TWO THOUSAND
EIGHTEEN WE TOUCH THE THE
ALL FIVE NETWORKS COMBINED WE
TOUCH SEVEN HUNDRED THIRTY FIVE
MILLION IN CAPITAL INFUSION --
HELP CREATE OVER TEN THOUSAND
JOBS -- AND -- TOUCH OVER TWO
THOUSAND BUSINESSES BUSINESS
START UPS SO AND OVER A HUNDRED
THOUSAND HOURS IN -- ONE ON
ONE BUSINESS CONSULTING AT NO
COST TO THE BUSINESS OWNER SO
WE'RE REALLY PROUD OF THOSE
NUMBERS AND WE LOOK FORWARD
TO CONTINUE TO GROW AND --
HELPING ALL REGIONS RICE THANKS
THANK YOU THAT CONCLUDES OUR
THE PUBLIC COMMENT PORTION
I DO JUST WANT TO GIVE A FEW
CLOSING REMARKS I THANK YOU
TO ALL THOSE WHO VOICE THEIR
THOUGHTS CONCERNS ARE TODAY
DURING PUBLIC COMMENTS ALSO
WANT TO THANK THE SPEAKERS
WERE ABLE TO JOIN US AND SHARE
THEIR FINDINGS -- BUT THIS
IS ONE OF THE MOST IMPORTANT
PARTS OF THE COMMITTEE HEARING
PROCESS IS TO HAVE THESE FIELD
HEARINGS AND TO MAKE SURE THAT
WE HAVE ALL DIFFERENT VOICES
AT THE TABLE AND -- THIS IS
A COMMUNITY LEVEL WORK THAT I
ENJOY THE MOST I BELIEVE THAT
IT'S IMPORTANT IT REQUIRES
EACH CONVENER TO REALLY THINK
ABOUT -- WHO IS NOT AT THE
TABLE AND WHO NEEDS TO BE AT
THE TABLE I WHEN IT COMES TO
DISCUSSING THESE CHALLENGES
THAT WE HAVE BEFORE US AND
HOW TO MOVE FORWARD -- SO I
WOULD ENCOURAGE EACH OF US
TO JUST BE MORE INCLUSIVE AND
RECOGNIZE -- ONE WERE WHEN WE
ARE TOGETHER IN A ROOM -- WHO
ELSE WE NEED TO REACH OUT TO
I THINK THAT IT WOULD BE GREAT
FOR EXAMPLE FOR THE WAREHOUSE
WORKERS RESOURCE CENTER AND
THEIR COALITION TO PERHAPS I
GETTING GAUGE WITH THE REGION'S
RISE TOGETHER INITIATIVE I
SAID THAT YOU BOTH CAN BE A
PART OF THIS DISCUSSION IN THE
SOLUTIONS AS WE MOVE FORWARD
-- BUT JUST SOMETHING ALWAYS
KEEP IN MIND -- FOR EACH OF US
WHO ARE HERE TODAY IT IS ALSO
SOMETHING THAT WE'VE SPOKEN
ABOUT A LOT TODAY IS RESHAPING
OUR NARRATIVE I THAT WE HAVE
ARE BAD ABILITY TO DO SO AND IT
REQUIRES THAT UNITY AMONGST THE
COUNTIES IN ORDER TO DO SO WILL
FORD AND SHARE THE POSITIVE
THINGS THAT ARE HAPPENING IN
THE INLAND EMPIRE BOOK WHAT
MORE CAN BE DONE SO THAT WE
CAN ENCOURAGE A DIFFERENT TYPE
OF OPPORTUNITIES TO OUR REGION
SO I WILL SHARE YOU KNOW THAT
NARRATED THE POSITIVE NARRATIVE
AND WHAT MORE WE NEED TO DO
TO ATTRACT -- THE RIGHT TYPE
OF BUSINESS OPPORTUNITIES
HERE DISCUSSING THE QUALITY
OF JOBS THAT WERE BRINGING
HERE IS THE UTMOST IMPORTANCE
NOT TO NOT JUST MYSELF BUT
TOO MANY OF THE COMMUNITY
MEMBERS THAT YOU JUST HEARD
FROM UP WITH THAT I WILL CLOSE
TWO DAYS ASSEMBLY COMMITTEE
ON JOBS I WANT TO THINK OF
ALL MY COMMITTEE MEMBERS WHO
HAVE BEEN ACTIVELY ENGAGED --
THROUGHOUT THIS LEGISLATIVE
SESSION WHEN IT COMES TO
POLICY PROPOSALS AND BUDGET
PROPOSALS I WANT TO THANK OUR
EXCELLENT WITNESSES AND FOR
THE PUBLIC FOR PARTICIPATING
TODAY WE ARE NOW ADJOURNED